[Music]
hey folks we are back again with another
c plus plus audio tutorial today we are
going to build this plug-in from scratch
using modern c plus and the juice
framework check the description for
links to the repository and to download
the final build okay what is this thing
this is the little brother of my new
audio plug-in and course for programming
for musicians where you can learn to
build these other plugins
also where you can learn modern c plus
and the juice framework taught from the
context of writing audio software in a
mentored environment
in programming for musicians you are not
following videos you are not watching
someone else code and you are not
copying them either you are coding it
yourself from a design spec and i'm
reviewing your work every step of the
way
alright enough about those let's learn
about what we are going to build today
this is a 3-band compressor audio signal
is split into three discrete bands and
compression is applied to each band
separately
the bottom of the gui contains the
controls for the selected band you'll
find standard compressor controls here
attack release threshold and ratio on
the right side you'll find buttons to
mute solo or bypass an individual audio
band these buttons are helpful for
dialing in an individual compressor or
hearing how it is affecting the overall
audio signal the band select buttons are
on the left these control which
compressor is being controlled remember
we have three of them
in the middle of the gui are the global
controls you'll find input trim on the
left crossover controls in the middle
and output trim on the right
crossover sliders control where the
audio is split into the 3-band
the top portion of the gui features a
spectrum analyzer which shows us what we
are hearing where the crossovers are in
the frequency spectrum and what our
thresholds are set to as well as the
current gain reduction per band at the
very top of the gui you'll find the
analyzer bypass button on the left this
button turns off the fft analysis in the
spectrum analyzer
finally we have the global bypass button
on the right which disables or enables
all three compressors simultaneously we
are going to learn to build all of the
dsp that's going on in the background we
are going to learn how to build this gui
okay that's the feature set for this
plugin and for this course my name is
chuck i go by the name matcat music on
youtube instagram and twitter once again
check the description for links to the
repository and where to download the
final builds let's get started and write
a multi-band compressor using modern c
plus plus and the juice framework from
scratch
[Music]
welcome to this tutorial teaching the
simple multiband compressor if you
happen to get stuck during uh any part
of the setup or in the actual tutorial
itself grab any free product from
programming for musicians you will be
sent an invite link to a slack workspace
where you can send me a message directly
i will help you get unstuck we can work
on error messages if you have setup
issues that sort of thing all right on
with the show
hey folks welcome to this tutorial
documenting how to build this three-band
compressor
before we start building anything we
need to have a working development
environment that is what we're going to
do first i'm going to show how to do
this for mac and then how to do this for
windows
here is what we are going to accomplish
in this first part of the course we're
going to install the ide which could be
xcode or visual studio we're going to
clone the juice framework we're going to
build producer create a project and then
create a repository for the project
then we're going to build and run the
standalone app version of the project
then we're going to set up audio plug
and host we're going to configure the
ide to launch audio plug and host
whenever we build and run the project
then we're going to configure audio
plugin host so it can load our plugin
and set up a filter graph so audio will
run through our plugin then we are going
to set up an audio file player so that
we can actually play audio files through
our plugin then we are going to
configure audio plugin host to use the
audio file player plugin to send audio
into our plugin and out to our sound
card if you are a windows user you can
skip ahead to the time stamp shown below
for your steps all right let's begin the
first thing we need is xcode now i have
already downloaded and installed xcode
but if you haven't there are two ways
you can get it number one is to get it
from the app store just go here and
search xcode oops
search here xcode this is going to get
the version that is
the most recent version that is
available for most people to get if you
have an older computer the other way you
can do it is to grab a
apple developer account
these are free you only need to pay for
the account if you are code signing okay
so
if you don't
um if you're not planning on signing any
of your binaries you can just go to
developer.apple.com
developer.apple.com
uh sign up for a free account
and then
uh sign on in
all right once you are signed on in go
to downloads
click on more
and then search for xcode all right
you will see all of the versions of
xcode that have ever been released
xcode 11 12 13
keep scrolling on down there's 11.7
there's 11.4
xcode 4.6.2 xcode 10 11.
all that stuff so if you're running an
older version of mac os and you cannot
get um you cannot run xcode
12 or xcode13 this is what you can do
we have successfully grabbed xcode and
our next thing to do is to clone the
juice repository
navigate
to
juce github.comuce framework slash juc
we are going to clone using fork which
is a get gui
you can grab that from
https colon slash fork dot dev
once you've got fork
go ahead and launch it now we need to
configure
where fork looks for all of its
repositories so go to the fork menu go
to preferences
and you're going to specify the default
source folder in my case i am putting
all of my code
here in my users folder in a folder
called programming okay
once you've got that configured
you can go
back to we can close this we can go back
to github we can copy this url right
here click the green button for code um
copy this url
and then go to fork file
clone it's going to automatically
populate this url
if it doesn't that's fine you can just
paste it
click clone
now if fork if you're running an older
version of mac os and it throws some
kind of errors at you
you need to install the swift runtime so
again you can grab that
you can grab that either you can grab
that from the developer your developer
account
go to your account
go to downloads
search for more
and swift
somewhere in here is it here there it is
swift's uh runtime support for command
line tools this is what you need to
install
that will make fork run
again this is only if you have an older
version of mac
juice has been around for like a decade
or so i'm not quite sure how long um by
default it checks out the master branch
but the master branch
there's quite a few commits
that have happened between when the
master branch was released and when the
developer branch which contains the most
recent fixes had its most recent commit
push to it
so we want to check out the develop
branch so go ahead and double click on
origin developer that'll check out a
branch
and now we've got the latest set of
changes in producer
all right our next step is to build
producer which will create juice
projects for us okay so just click open
in finder your little button right there
navigate to the juice
extras folder
the producer folder and the builds
folder and then mac os x
double click on the juicer file
this is going to open up xcode if this
is the first time launching xcode it may
ask you to install
it may ask you to install additional
command line tools just click yes
and then get it to this point all right
i've already built this a few times
because i was doing test runs in this
video
what we want to do is go to the product
menu and choose build
now we can watch what it's doing uh
during the compilation process by
clicking on this button right here of
these buttons right here it's the
rightmost one and just click on this and
it will take us to this report showing
us what is being compiled while it is
being compiled
we just need to wait for it to finish
all right currently compiling
gui basics linking signing there we go
build succeeded all right we are done
with xcode for right now go ahead and
close the project
all right navigate to the builds folder
in the debug folder is where you will
find the produced binary double click on
this to launch producer
producer is here
now the first thing we need to do is
turn on gpl mode if we go to file
by default it might be on it may not be
on
choose sign in
and select gpl mode now the next thing
to do is to
customize where the juice paths are
because this was cloned to the
to a location other than the users
folder pro juicer is not going to be
able to find the modules
so go to the globalpaths menu choice
under producer
and we need to set our path to juice
okay
so that's over here
and all we need to do is find our juice
folder which in my case is in this
programming directory
matcap music programming there's the
juice folder whoops
mad cat music
programming
juice
open
all right now we need to do the same
thing for the juice modules
modules are found inside of the juice
folder so
we just need to navigate to that
and then choose open again this is like
programming
juice
modules
okay once we've done that we're good to
go here now we can create an audio
plugin in the simple eq video there were
a lot of comments of people who created
an audio application
we do not want an audio application we
want to create a basic plugin
okay
the first thing to do is set the name
we're going to do simple mb comp short
for simple multiband compressor and
click create project we just need to
choose a valid place to save the project
so i'm going to save it into my
programming folder
okay next we need to make sure that the
plugin copy step is enabled so click on
exporters click on debug and scroll down
for the plug-in copy step
make sure it is enabled
all right the next thing to do is to set
the c plus plus version to c plus 17.
click this little gear icon for project
settings
and scroll down to the bottom
and then up a little bit
we can change the c plus plus language
standard here change it to c plus plus
17.
finally let's set the company name
that's up at the top i'm going to put
matcat music llc
when we scan for plugins in audio plug
and host
this is
our plug this is how our plugin will
show up it will show up under the name
of whatever we put here
all right now we can click save and open
in ide
let's create a repository next
let's go over to fork
in fork we're going to choose file
create new local repository
and then we just need to pick this
directory
notice that there are a ton of files
that are unstaged
okay we need to customize the git ignore
file for this project and we're doing
this because we don't want any of these
files that producer automatically
generates every time we save the project
to be stored in the repository again
they're auto-generated so there's no
reason for us to keep track of how they
changed
okay so right click on one of these
files i'm going to right click on this
builds directory and choose ignore
custom pattern
now i'm going to type some stuff here
the first thing i'm going to type is
star star slash builds
that's going to ignore everything in the
builds directory next i'm going to just
type star star
whoops star star
juice
library code that's going to ignore
everything in the juice library code
folder
and then because this is mac i'm going
to type star star
dot ds store
that's going to ignore the ds store
files which are generated by mac os
every time you customize the view of a
folder
all right add to git ignore
now we only have six files
awesome we've got our four
source folders and our ignore file and
then the juicer file for the project
now we can stage these by clicking this
button right here to stage all
and now we can make our initial commit
initial
commit
all right
every time we click save and open in ide
it's not going to produce new changes
it's only when we change source code
that it will do that
all right we can go back to producer
and we can choose save and open in ide
let's build and run the standalone app
version
first of all change the scheme right
here to the standalone plugin
and then click the play button to build
and run
all right we can watch the build happen
again go to the report navigator click
on the entry with the spinning wheel
all right build succeeded we're waiting
for it to run
this is the default audio plug-in
that comes from producer running within
a standalone plug-in app
it is our job to customize the dsp and
the graphics but let's not get ahead of
ourselves
we need to set up a test bed that we can
use to run audio through our plug-in so
let's set that up next
go ahead and close this
all right we can close this project as
well
close project
if you uh were not aware i am doing this
in a virtual machine that has nothing
set up in it
um that's just to show you if you've
never done this before here's how you
can get set up real quickly
show me later never okay all right the
first thing to do is to set up audio
plug and host we need to navigate to
that folder okay so users folder
programming it's inside the juice folder
it's under extras it's audio plugin host
open up the juicer file
save and open in ide
and build it
product build
linking build succeeded okay close the
project once building is
complete we are going to configure our
plug-in project to launch audio
plug-and-host every time we use the vst3
scheme all right we can close this
juicer file let's go back to our simple
multiband compressor
and open this up
all right we can make this full screen
now
go to the xcode project we're going to
edit the vst3 scheme okay click on this
guy to select it
and now edit the scheme
all right we're going to change the
executable from none
to audio plug-in host so choose other
and we're going to search for audio
plug-in host
there it is
click choose
now let's see close this now we just
need to run this and that's going to
launch audio plug-in host
well first it has to build the vst3
version
linking build succeeded okay launching
audio plug-in host
there's audio plug-and-host yes you can
use my microphone
okay the first thing we need to do is
configure audio plugin host to load our
plugin
go to the options menu
and click edit the list of available
plugins
we're going to scan
all right so choose options
and scan for new or updated vst3 plugins
that's fine
there's our compressor right there
simple mb comp
okay we can close this window
now that our plug-in has been found we
can load it into the filter graph so
right-click select it from the pop-up
again this is where you set your company
name and there's your compressor now if
we double click this
it looks the same as the standalone
version
cool
let's wire it up to the output
go like this click right there
click right there and drag that okay
right now any audio that our plugin
produces will go to the sound card
all right now we're not going to hear
anything because there's nothing feeding
audio into our plugin so let's do that
next and then the other thing is if we
go to options we can change our audio
device settings
again i'm running this in parallels so
it's using a virtual machine and the
virtual machine devices okay
let's set up audio file
player next
we can save this
and we want to save this into our
we want to save this with our project
so let's see where's my documents full
not documents we want to save this with
our programming programming simple
multiband comp this is like um
simple mb comp test
testbed
cool that'll work
we can quit audio plug-in host for now
in the previous tutorial video that i
created the simple eq tutorial i used
apple's au audio file player let me show
you what that looks like let me see if
that's even on here
hey i just wanted to interject i'm
editing this video the next day
the au audio file player does show up on
a default installation of mac
you just need to scan for audio units
and it will be there
so if i do that then i can scan and
it'll show up under apple
au audio file player
there it is okay this is what i used in
simple eq all right i just wanted to let
you know that this stuff does come on
here if you do
have um a fresh install of the operating
system you do not need garageband and
you do not need logic to access this
this comes with the operating system
this time we're going to use the audio
file player plugin that i created this
plugin is a port of the juice audio
playback demo app to work as an audio
plugin the demo app if you're curious
you can go to file
open example audio audio playback demo
and this is an actual audio application
so what i have done is i have ported
this into an actual plugin that you can
use in your daw in audio plug and host
on mac and windows to handle all of
these playback duties so we need to go
grab this let's close our project for
now it's close we're not going to close
that
we need to go grab it so let's open up
our browser we're going to navigate to
github.com
mathcat music slash audio file player
this is what we need to clone so click
on the code button copy it and then
clone it in fork file clone
paste that url and let's clone it all
right successfully cloned
now we need to compile it open in finder
let's go to our audio file player
audio file player.juicer save and open
in ide it's going to launch xcode we
just need to build it and it's going to
build um all of these it's going to be
able to the standalone version the vsd3
and the audio unit build
all right cool once it's built um we
should be able to launch audio plug and
host and uh
be good to go so close this project we
can close audio let's not close it yet
because we may need to um
do it again let's open up our simple mb
comp
all right let's run it and now we are
going to scan
for audio file player
all right options menu edit the list of
available plugins
options scan for new or updated vst3
scan
there it is audio file player perfect
close this window
right click mat cat music my company
name audio file player
here's the audio file player
double click it to view the gui
now we just need to wire up the outputs
of this
uh to the inputs of our simple multiband
compressor
now let's just add an audio file we can
either drag one in or
select something from here
and if it prompts you to grant
permission uh to the desktop and the
documents folder in the music folder
just click accept
that's all it's you know mac security
stuff let's press play to hear the audio
file
awesome there we go let's push stop
all right save the filter graph
now audio plug and host is configured
every time we run the vst 3 version of
the project audio plugin host will
launch and it will load our plugin and
it will load this audio player let's go
ahead and quit this
and show what i mean
we run this
it's gonna launch there's our audio file
player plug-in and we can just stream
audio right into the plug-in
all right perfect
we are ready to start coding up this
plug-in mac users you can jump to the
time stamp shown below
to start
the tutorial that actually codes up the
plugin windows users we are going to
cover setting up your system next
all right windows users
as a reminder i am using windows 10
inside of a virtual machine on my mac i
am doing this to show
uh how to get started using a relatively
fresh and clean operating system
installation and also because i love the
pain of using windows 10 in a virtual
machine
sad face okay ah let's dive in the first
thing we need to do is grab visual
studio community from the website
not visual studio code but visual studio
we can get the community edition just go
up here
and just google for it
visual studio community
all right we want the 2019 community
edition go ahead and download it
once you have that then resume this
video okay once you have the installer
downloaded go here
and run the installer
and we need to configure it to build c
plus plus apps if you already have
visual studio installed
but you're using it for javascript or c
sharp or something else but you don't
have c plus plus installed
run the installer and
set it up the way i'm about to show you
once this thing launches in
10 minutes so we have this here uh
visual studio community 2019 click the
modify button and what we want to do is
set it up for c plus development so go
to here desktop development with c plus
make sure that's enabled and what you
want to configure um you're going to
want clang tools
you're going to want the address
sanitizer you're going to want
intellicode you uh we don't need live
share we don't need test adapter for
google tests we do not need boost.test
we need a latest
we need the latest v142 build tools we
need we don't need cmake we need the
profiling tools we need the just in time
debugger
we need this guy and we need this guy
all right so set your thing up so that
way it's got these
and then
um just click install while downloading
all right once everything is installed
you can quit visual studio the next step
is to download the juice framework or
sorry not download but clone the juice
framework okay we always want to clone
it so we have access to the repository
history so the first thing we're going
to do is we're going to use fork which
is the get gui to interact with this
repository so you can get that if you
open your browser you can grab that from
fork.dev it's available for mac and for
windows okay
so you can go ahead and grab it here
download fork for windows okay once
you've got fork installed we need to
configure it to store everything
um
in our preferred location any
repositories that it clones all that
sort of thing
launch fork go to the file menu
go to preferences and we need to specify
the default clone folder
i like to keep things in a folder called
programming i have it right here on my
desktop you know i could move it
somewhere else but for the sake of this
tutorial it's right here on the desktop
so i just navigate to that you know
click this folder button
find where i'm going to put it basically
anything that i'm going to clone is
going to go there so i'm going to put it
on the desktop programming like that
select folder okay now anything that i
clone is going to go into that folder in
its own repository now we need to
navigate to the juice framework and get
the url for that so open up your browser
open up a new tab then visit
com
github.com
juice dash framework
w-o-r-k
j-u-c-e in all caps
here's the juice framework now we need
to click this code button right here
click the copy button and go back to
fork and now we can do file
clone
it's going to auto populate this
repository url and it's going to save it
into the programming folder that we
requested click the clone button and you
will be downloading a copy of the juice
repository to your computer
okay cloned alright perfect
now we have a copy of juice on our
computer the next thing to do is to
build the producer which creates juice
projects for us but before we do that
juice is a pretty old framework by
default the master branch or main branch
is checked out
however there have been several commits
since the
most recent branch oh spinning wheel a
lot of things have been fixed in the
juice framework since the master branch
was last updated so we want to check out
the develop branch okay so just double
click right on origin slash develop and
then it will prompt to create a branch
and track the remote branch click the
track button now we can open up producer
and build it okay so click on this open
in
button right here and choose open in
file explorer
now we need to navigate to the extras
pro juicer
navigate to builds
visual studio 2019
and then we're going to open up this
solution file
we can just go to the build menu and
choose build solution
this is going to build producer for us
now we just need to wait for it to
finish compiling all right build
succeeded fantastic
we can close the visual studio project
now now we can create a plug-in project
next
navigate to the x64 folder
click on debug click on app and now
we're looking for producer.exe
there it is
all right double click it to launch
now if this is the first time you are
using producer it's going to ask you to
sign in we want to turn on gpl mode if
this is not the first time you've
probably already set it up but normally
what you will see you'll go to the file
menu you will choose sign in it'll show
this thing you can if you have a juice
account you can set that up or you can
enable gpl mode now gpl mode has the
requirement that we make our projects
open source so
uh yeah make your project open source
okay
in the simple eq project a lot of people
left comments that they created an audio
application or they were missing
um they were missing the plug-in
processor file
and that's because they created an audio
application instead of a plug-in
instead of a basic plug-in so for this
you definitely want to make sure you are
definitely going to want to make sure
that you choose plug-in category and
that you choose basic
all right first thing that we need to do
we need to give it the name
simple mbcomp
and then create project oh i'm sorry
before you do that
if producer says you need to set your
paths because you had downloaded juice
to a directory that's not the standard
directory it's expecting
go here under the file menu go to global
paths and then customize these paths
here this is what i'm talking about
when you
install it to the default location it's
expecting juice to go
in a folder on the root level of your
hard drive
so obviously i put mine in this
programming folder on the desktop so
that is not where my juice folder is and
that is not where the modules folder is
so i'm going to click these three dots
i'm going to choose the juice folder
and then select folder and i'm going to
do the same thing for the modules
the modules folder
select folder
and i can close this window now all
right now i can create this
all right i want to put this in my
programming folder with juice and the
other stuff i've made
this is going to create the project the
next thing that we need to do is enable
the plugin copy step this is going to
copy the plugin when we compile it to
the
folder that
most
hosts you know reaper cubase ableton
they're all looking for plugins in this
one folder so this is going to enable
copying it there automatically
in this view click on exporters click on
debug scroll down to the scroll down a
little bit and you'll see where it says
enable plug-in copy step
make sure this is set to enabled all
right we'll figure out where this
actually gets copied to in a little bit
next we need to um
change the c plus version so go up here
go to
let's see this is down at the bottom of
this list okay scroll all the way to the
end then scroll up a little bit and
change the c plus plus language standard
to c plus plus 17.
all right next we want to
supply our company name
so let's do that first i'm going to type
mine matcat music llc
when we scan for the plugin in audio
plug-in host
whatever we put here is the
name that it's going to appear as it's
going to show up as a sub menu under
this name right here
okay
we may or may not need to set this using
namespace juice so we'll come back to
that first thing we're going to do is
we're going to save and launch this
save and open in ide this is going to
launch visual studio
we're going to find out whether or not
we need to turn on that
using namespace juice so go to the build
menu
and we're just going to try to build
this real quick rebuild solution
and if we get any errors about namespace
stuff then we will turn that on
let's see what happens
okay cool all right so the copy step
failed but we don't have any error
messages relating to the namespace juice
let's do the next thing which is to
create a repository for our project
first and then we will deal with this
copy step all right we can close this
for now
okay to create a repository open fork
and then do file
init new repository and choose the
simple mbcomp folder for the project
now you'll notice that there are a ton
of files here
um listed under under local changes so
we need to customize the get ignore file
for this project and ignore all of this
stuff the reason we are doing that is
because all of this stuff gets created
automatically by producer whenever we
save
and
whenever we save and open in ide or when
we compile like you'll see there's all
these object files and stuff so we want
to right click
choose ignore custom pattern
star star and for this we're going to
type star star slash
builds
then
and what this is going to do is it's
going to ignore all of the files that
are in the builds directory
we want to do the same thing for juice
library code so star star slash
juice
library code
like that now if for some reason we want
to migrate this project over to mac
it's very handy to add star star slash
dot ds store that's going to ignore any
ds store files on mac
these files control how the
finders view
looks basically if it's showing icons or
if it's showing a list or if it's
showing um
if it's arranged by name or if it's
arranged by day created that sort of
stuff that information is stored in
these ds store files okay add to git
ignore
you can see we only have the four source
files our git ignore file and the juicer
file
now we can make our initial commit let's
stage these by clicking the stage all
button
and now
committing them initial
commit
now we can save and open in ide go ahead
and go back to visual studio
save and open in ide this will launch
visual studio one more time
okay on the right side is the solution
explorer we want to right click on the
standalone plugin
and choose
set as startup project
okay now we can build and run it by
clicking on this local windows debugger
let's see if this throws an error with
regard to the
copy step or not it shouldn't because
we're not spawning the copy stop version
we're not spawning the vst3
this is the default audio plugin from
producer okay it is running inside of a
standalone app
that is part of the juice framework that
hosts this okay it is our job to
customize the dsp that runs on our
plug-in as well as the graphics let's
not get ahead of ourselves though we
need to come up with a test bed so that
we can actually run audio through our
plug-in that's what we're going to set
up next all right close that
close this
let's go set up audio plugin host
navigate to your juice directory
navigate to extras navigate to audio
plugin host
navigate to the juicer file and open it
up in producer
save and open in ide
build it build the solution
okay
build one succeeded zero failed awesome
all right we're done with audio plug and
host
okay
we can close the juicer file as well
all right let's configure audio plugin
host to launch whenever we have the vst3
as to startup project
right click on the vst3 target
go down to properties
navigate to where it says debugging
we're going to change this command so
click on this arrow
go to browse and we're going to look for
audio plug and host
all right got that
build simple me comp navigate to the
juice folder
navigate to the extras folder audio
plugin host
builds
visual studio 2019
x64
debug
app
and now audiopluginhost.exe
click apply and okay
now we need to change the target from
standalone to vst3
change that to the startup project
and now if we build and run it's going
to fail on that copy step like we saw
earlier let's do it anyway all right
copy step failed it's trying to copy to
common programs
wherever this thing is okay so we what
we need to do is change the permissions
of this folder
to allow
the current user
which is you know whoever we are logged
in as we need to give them write
permission to this folder so open up
explorer
this is located in the c drive program
files common files this is where
um
x this is where visual studio is trying
to copy this file to so
right click create new create a folder
call it vst3
and then the second part of this is to
change the permissions so that the
logged-in user
can write to this folder because visual
studio is being
run under that user's settings okay so
right click on this
go to properties
go to security
click on edit to change the permissions
and then we need to change the
permissions for the user
to be able to modify
all right apply
okay
okay
all right let's try this one more time
let's see if it throws an error or not
okay cool copy step completed if we go
back over here
let's see where was that let's just
press stop real quick if we go to the
build
and scroll to the top we can see that
one file was copied correctly
all right let's go ahead and launch this
now we need to scan for our plugin
so choose options edit the list of
available plugins
and now this is where we need to scan
all right so i've already done this scan
before but i'm going to clear this list
and now i'm going to scan for new or
updated vst3 plugins
right like i said it's looking for
program files common files vst3 scan
all right here's our plugin
okay now we can load it into the filter
graph
right click
go to your company name
and here's your plugin if we double
click on it it looks identical to the
standalone version we saw earlier okay
let's wire it up to the outputs
just click and drag
and we're not going to hear anything
because there's nothing feeding audio
into our plug-in and thus going to the
speakers let's fix that next
go ahead and
we can save this and add it to our
repository choose file save
and let's see
let's add this to our repository desktop
programming simple mbq
and then we can say this is the um
oh it's called simple mb comp
filter graph
now we'll get the extension
save all right we can close that let's
make a commit that we added this
added filter graph
go ahead and stage that
commit that all right
we are going to set up audio file player
so that we can run audio files through
our plugin
go ahead and close this project
okay
in the previous tutorial video that i
created i used apple's au audio file
player to run audio files through the
simple eq
windows users did not have a plug-in
like that at their disposal and i saw a
lot of comments in
in the comments section of that video
about that like people were just like
hey what's the windows equivalent to
this so this time we're going to use the
audio file player plug-in that i created
this plug-in is a port of the juice
audio playback demo app
it has been ported to work as a
audio plugin so you can see that project
if you want if you go to open example
audio audio playback demo
this is what this guy well we're not
going to look at that right now but if
you want to check it out just load that
up um save it build it you know what to
do because you know you've already done
it a few times with producer and
uh this project and with audio plugin
host okay let's go get this thing all
right open up your browser
navigate to github
dot com slash mat cat music
slash
audio
let me spell that right audio file
player
okay now we want to grab the code from
this
copy
we're done here
in fork we want to clone
all right it's already populated for us
clone it
all right let's open it in finder or in
file explorer
okay open up the juicer file
save and open in ide
now we just need to build it
build solution
this should also copy the vst3 to that
folder
let's see what it does
may need to change the build target
creating library one file copied
okay that should be okay
all right let's close this
now we can go back to our project let's
close audio file
player the juicer file close that guy
and we can also close this repository we
don't need that anymore
all right go back to our simple
multiband comp
let's load up xcode let's launch it and
then we will configure audio plugin host
to use it
go ahead and run it
now we need to scan for our plugins one
more time because we just compiled the
new one so go to the options menu edit
the list of available plugins
options scan for new or updated threes
scan
there is our audio file player so
we can right click here
mat cat music llc that's the name it's
going to be under and then choose audio
file player
and here's our plugin
all right this is what's going to play
the files
we just need to wire it up
we've got our instance
in the filter graph
okay let's add an audio file um i've got
one on the desktop
it's this guy right here
let's start that over
all right perfect
let's save the filter graph
save
all right we can close this
what's great about this is that every
time we launch this project
it's going to load that audio file
automatically for us we're not gonna
have to you know go find the audio file
every time
we relaunch audio plug-in host that's
the problem that existed in the earlier
version of this plug-in that i had which
i
that plug-in was just a band-aid fix
when i first created this simple eq
tutorial for the windows users because i
didn't realize that they would have this
problem i have since fixed that so that
it now
it now shows you
it now remembers what file you had
loaded so if we go ahead and launch this
again
there's our file and if we press play
gonna work as expected
so that's fantastic all right we'll put
this guy over here
audio plugin host is configured and um
we have set up our project so that way
every time we have the vst3 version set
as the startup project it's going to
launch audio plug-in host and we'll have
a
real easy time of you know debugging our
plug-in and adding features to it and
being able to run audio through it using
audio plug-in host
now we are ready to start coding our
plug-in
now we will be reusing and modifying
some elements from the simple eq
tutorial that i made for free code camp
if you haven't completed that tutorial i
recommend that you pause this video and
start watching that one i'm not going to
explain how the things we are reusing
were created if you want that
information you can watch that video
where all that stuff is explained okay i
will be explaining the modifications
that we will be making to those classes
though so with that said let's begin
building this simple multiband
compressor
let's survey the lay of the land before
we start writing any code
also thanks to everybody who watched
simple eq and said i looked like
guilfoyle i had never heard of that show
silicon valley before i started checking
the comments for that video and
that's good times okay number one there
are several important parts to any audio
plugin the first one is the dsp code
itself
this code is responsible for the actual
audio that we hear we are responsible
for making it fast and efficient
number two is the audio parameters these
control the various parts of the dsp
code
examples include the filter frequency or
the pitch of a node being played by a
synthesizer for example
if we were writing a reverb plugin
we might have a parameter that controls
the reverb time
in dsp programming it's all state-based
programming we are constantly updating
the state of our dsp based on math that
modifies the audio signal in some way
for example when we filter audio
we keep track of the previously filtered
samples these samples which are known as
the previous filter output
get added to the incoming samples after
being scaled with some coefficient
the newly filtered samples become the
previous filter output for the next time
that we process incoming samples
number three preparing our dsp before we
start processing anything with it
before we can run audio through our dsp
we need to configure some basic
information about it the number of
samples we're going to be processing the
sample rate we will be processing those
samples at and the number of channels we
will be processing for example we might
have a stereo feed which is two channels
we might have a mono feed which is one
channel or we might even have a dolby
5.1 which is six channels
now if you are unfamiliar with the
concept of sample rate
there are numerous videos on youtube
that explain how digital audio works
let me grab my whiteboard
so i'm reading my script over on this
side so bear with me as a brief overview
the audio we hear with our ears is an
analog signal like this graph that i've
got drawn here
our eardrums detect changes in air
pressure and they convert that change
into an electrical signal which gets
turned into
sound
by our brain
this signal this graph that i've got
right here this is a graph of the
changes of the air pressure it is
continuous
if we uh take this signal right here if
we were to continually zoom in on it
like i've got down here on the bottom
part if we continually zoom in on it
it's always going to appear smooth
okay now on computers
that's not the case computers on the
other hand
operate using ones and zeros
like i was saying computers operate on
ones and zeros what this means is that
the computer has to sample this smooth
audio signal at a specific rate
and produce an approximation of this
smooth audio signal the more frequently
that the signal is sampled the smoother
the approximation becomes
as an example let me use this blue color
here
if we sample at every tick
like this blip
blip
blip and blip we are left with and also
right there we are left with a wave form
that looks like this
if we sample at these tick marks
we and we remove the continuous line we
are left with this lollipop graph like
this which has these little dots
the more frequently that we sample the
signal the smoother this approximation
becomes as you can see right now it's
not
it's not a very good approximation of
the original so let's sample it twice as
often all right we'll sample here
and here
here and here that's going to give us a
circle there
circle there circle there
circle there
okay
let's see the more frequently that the
signal is sampled the smoother the
approximation becomes this is the sample
rate you know we can keep going we can
keep bumping this up blip blip
blip
like that like that like that like that
this is starting to look like the
original
waveform
which is great
which means like our approximation this
digital approximation
is much more accurate
it's much more true to the original
waveform okay
this is the concept of sample rate the
higher the sample rate the more
frequently the signal is sampled
now our ears
they can hear up to around 20 000 hertz
there's a theory called the nyquist
theory that basically says that digital
audio needs to be sampled at a rate of
twice the highest frequency that you
want to reproduce
so this comes back to
the way the waveform is shaped across
the grid
if i want to reproduce this pink line i
can't sample it here and only there i
need to have an intermediate point so
that way
um the full
shape of the waveform is captured
that's what the nyquist is talking about
if i only capture here and here i'm
gonna miss the fact that this
actually goes up and goes back down
that's the whole point behind the whole
nyquist theory and whatnot so since we
want to hear things up to about 20
kilohertz
we need to sample that audio that 20
kilohertz um signal we need to sample
that at 20 kilohertz times roughly 2.
then this is where that sample rate of
44.1 kilohertz or 48 kilohertz comes in
the sound card in the computer is
converting 44
100 or 48 000 audio samples into an
analog waveform literally an electric
signal
and it's sending that to the analog
outputs every second
you might have speakers or you might
have headphones plugged into that analog
output
and this is where that analog signal
goes and then the speakers themselves or
the headphones might have an amplifier
built into them that actually boosts
this electrical signal that comes out of
the analog output and then this boosted
signal from the amplifier
it is sent through some wires that wrap
around a magnet that is attached to the
speaker cone
then the speaker cone vibrates when it
gets that electrical signal goes like
this
which moves the air which our eardrums
detect that change in pressure and then
our brain
translates that into sound that we hear
okay now there is a ton of math and
science behind these numbers of 44.1
kilohertz and 48 and like the way the
ears work and the electrical signals and
all that stuff
we don't need to know any of that we
just need to know that what sample rate
means is it's like we have this
we have this curved line which is
continuous that's air pressure moving
back and forth and we need to convert it
into a digital signal that represents it
and the more often we sample it
the closer our representation will be
now in the juice project there are two
important functions that are always
called the first one is called prepare
to play let's go find the declaration of
that that's right here
i hope this font is big enough for those
of you watching this on a tablet
let's go look for the actual
implementation of it
also if you're using xcode or visual
studio there are navigator
things in the bars at the top which lets
you
jump directly to a function so you know
learn to use those tools they're very
handy the first one is called prepare to
play and this is where we configure that
basic information
of our dsp code the sample rate the
number of channels
the size of the blocks and stuff
the next one is called process block
that's right here that's declared right
here let's go to where that is over here
okay this function process block brings
us to our fourth important piece of the
audio plugin
processing audio samples at a regularly
recurring interval using our dsp code
this is what happens in the process
block function
now if you recall
let's see let me hide that ring light
that's in the back if you recall our
sound card has to send 44 or 48 000
samples of audio to our speakers every
second now internally
let's pretend that this chunk right here
on the bottom let's pretend this is 48
000 samples
okay internally the sound card splits
this into small chunks of samples called
blocks or buffers so let me just
draw what i mean by that okay so instead
of sending let's just say this is zero
and then this is 48
000. okay imagine there are 48 000
samples right here
now internal as i said internally the
sound card is going to split this into
smaller chunks they're going to be
called blocks and buffers now by doing
this the sound card can lessen its
burden of having to send this huge chunk
of data to the speakers
and to the amplifier and the digital
audio converter all at once every second
so instead of sending one big chunk of
audio
it can send lots of little ones such
that the total number of samples per
second ends up equaling
the sample rate so for example it might
say here's a chunk right here
all right then here's the next chunk
and then here's the next chunk
and it's going to keep chunkifying this
up into just these little blocks well
that was terrible
these little blocks like this until it
gets the total number it needs to send
per second
if the buffer size was 512 samples let's
pretend each of these is you know 512
samples
and the sample rate is 48 000 then the
sound card is going to send 48 000
divided by 512 buffers to the sound card
every second or
93.75 buffers okay so
obviously my picture is not totally
accurate there should be 93 orange uh
chunks right there okay now it's much
easier to send 512 samples 93 times a
second than it is to send
samples one time per second and it's
also easier to design hardware that can
deal with 512 samples versus hardware
that can handle 48 000 samples at a time
okay so that's one of the things that
goes into why we have these smaller
chunks called blocks or buffers that are
like 64 samples or whatever
now this is how that idea affects our
plug-in and how we design our dsp code
the process block function receives a
buffer of samples whenever the sound
card is ready for more audio to send to
the speakers
using a sample rate of 48 000 and a
buffer size of 512 we know that the
sound card is going to send audio to the
speakers
93-ish times per second or
once every 10 milliseconds
one 10-ish milliseconds so that means
that all the stuff that happens in our
process block
it needs to do whatever it's going to do
in within those 10-ish milliseconds the
faster it does it the better
however if the buffer size is even
smaller maybe it's only 64 samples
then our dsp code must be that much more
efficient the sound card needs to send
48 000 samples
to the speaker in blocks of 64 samples
that means it needs to send 750 of these
little blocks
per second to the speaker that means it
needs to send one block of 64 samples
every 1.3333
milliseconds that's pretty fast
we need to make sure that our dsp code
runs as fast as possible as a result the
sound card is not going to wait for us
if we don't have that block that we were
working on ready to go
and this is what causes audio dropouts
to happen the sound card will just send
a block of silence to the speakers if
the buffer it sent to our plugin wasn't
processed in time so now you know what
the process block function does and the
constraints that exist for it
audio dsp is a serial process there's a
loop that is always sending a buffer of
samples to our code and then our code in
our process block runs from top to
bottom
and then the loop sends another buffer
and there is no asynchronous coding
happening here on the dsp side of things
it's all happening in series which
simplifies thinking about the code a bit
this is also why i said earlier that dsp
programming is all state-based
programming
we update the state every time the loop
sends us a new buffer of samples to
process
and finally we have the gui which is the
last piece of any audio plugin
the gui is where we have all of the
sliders all of the knobs all of the
buttons that control the audio
parameters which in turn control the dsp
state
it's important to design a gui that is
very intuitive to use
in terms of
how this shows up in the code the plugin
processor is where we handle the audio
sides of things the
dot
plugin
and cpp source files is where our gui is
programmed
while we are designing the audio
parameters and the dsp for our plugin we
will be using the generic audio
processor editor instead of our own
custom editor this class is really cool
because it will automatically create all
of the sliders knobs and buttons and
combo boxes for every audio parameter
that we declare this will allow us to
dial in the dsp first and then add a
pretty paint job later in the form of
the gui now this is important because
there are often times where we can't see
the gui but the dsp code still runs for
example the user might be using
automation in their daw to control the
audio parameters instead of the gui our
gui always reflects the state of these
parameters it's never the other way
around the gui always shows the state of
the audio parameters
with this understanding let's switch to
the generic audio processor editor so
navigate to the create editor function
in
pluginprocessor.cpp
create editor
comment out this line
that
currently returns the custom editor we
will develop later
and change this to return
the generic audio processor editor
instead return new juice
generic
audio processor editor
oh that's deprecated all right
add the star
all right let's run this and take a look
at our gui
don't forget our plugin will
automatically show up because we already
configured audio plug-in host which is
awesome
it's this guy right here simple mb comp
okay we don't have any audio parameters
yet so the gui is not going to show
anything we will add some audio
parameters next
let's talk about compressors and what
they do
now audio signals have different levels
they can be loud they can be soft it
could be a medium level there can be
signals that can be too loud for a given
system now when i say system i'm
referring to the circuitry and the code
that is either converting an analog
signal into a digital one or converting
a digital signal into an analog
what this means is that the signal's
amplitude can be greater than what the
system can support let's use an example
let's say that we have a sine wave that
is represented digitally
if we plot this wave on a graph that
shows time on the x-axis and amplitude
on the y-axis
uh let's let's give it an amplitude with
a range of negative 0.5 to positive 0.5
so we'll start here
and we'll just go that high
that high
like that okay
so let's just pretend this lines up with
0.5 and this lines up with negative 0.5
let's add some gain to this signal right
we're going to
boost it and by doing that we're going
to double the signal
okay so
i'm going to turn up my volume knob
crank it up it's going to double it
add some more gain
all right cool so now the wave has an
amplitude of positive one to negative
one that's the range of the signal so
that's the range of the signal's
amplitude okay let's add some more again
some more we're going to double it again
so now it goes from
zero goes up to plus two let's see i'll
use this red color
hopefully this shows up
i'm gonna add this guy right here
we're gonna double it we go up to two
our waveform has an amplitude of minus
two
to plus two what happens if we try to
send this signal to our speakers through
our sound card now the sound card can
only handle
signals between negative one and plus
one let me use this green color i really
hope this shows up
now the sound card can only handle
signals between negative one and plus
one so the sound card is going to clamp
any value that is outside of this range
to this range so it's going to take this
red signal
and instead of it doing this
instead of it doing that
it's going to clamp it right across like
that
same for the top one it's just gonna go
blip
and right here it's gonna go blip
just like that
all right this is gonna turn it into a
quasi square wave this doesn't sound
good when that happens this form of
signal clamping is a form of brick wall
limiting this signal is hard limited to
a specific range of values with no
regard for what sort of distortion this
will cause to the original signal
by distortion i mean the fact that we
had a nice smooth curve and now it's got
like a square top and a square bottom
it is no longer
accurate to the original
a compressor allows us to control the
signal's amplitude in a musical way and
in an automated way there are four parts
to every compressor the two main parts
are the threshold and the ratio
so we're going to talk about our
hypothetical signal for a little bit our
signal is currently being clamped by the
sound card whenever the absolute value
of the signal is greater than one that's
happening right here and then right here
this plus one
this absolute value plus one that is the
threshold
the threshold control tells the
compressor whenever the absolute value
of the incoming signal is greater than
this threshold whenever it's greater
than this
apply gain to the signal it can be
negative gain apply it to the signal so
that the signal stays near or below this
threshold
now the next part is the ratio control
the ratio control affects how much gain
is actually applied to the signal is it
is written as x colon y like this you've
got
x
y so you could have three to one you
could have ten to one
you could have two point five
to one
like that okay
these are the different ratios
what they mean is that for every x
decibels of input signal above the
threshold
the output signal will actually show y
decibels of signal above the threshold
so let's do an example to understand how
this works because it's easier to think
of this stuff in terms of decibels
versus negative one and plus one
normalized samples
let's say that we have a signal
that has a value
of plus six decibels we can see that it
goes over this threshold right here i've
changed the scale on the side
we still have zero plus one and minus
one but you can think of zero as
negative infinity because it means
silence like the signal level in terms
of decibels is
infinitely small
and then the plus one
is the same as zero decibels below full
scale and then any signal above that is
reflected as a positive value
okay let's say that our ratio is
two
to one
and we're going to have a threshold of
zero db
okay now let's say that our signal is
plus 6 db
that means that our signal is 6 decibels
above the threshold
so let's plug the ratio into this line
for every x db of input signal above the
threshold the output will show y db of
signal above the threshold
so that means for every two decibels of
input signal above the threshold
the output will show one decibel of
signal above the threshold so our signal
is six decibels of the threshold so the
output will actually only show
three
decibels of signal above the threshold
that's going to look like this
okay i should have probably used a
different color but you get the idea
this is plus six here
this is plus three
now let's try a different ratio like 10
to 1.
what that means is that for every 10
decibels of input signal that is above
the threshold the output will show only
1 db of signal above the threshold our
output is 6 over the threshold so the
output will only be 0.6 above the
threshold
which means our signal let me use a
different color
means our signal
is actually going to look like this
i think that math is right if it's 6
above the
yeah 10 decibel 10 to 1 ratio so we're
going to get a 0.6 out of it now we can
continue to increase this ratio and get
more and more reduction
of the input signal however we can never
make the output not produce a signal
over the threshold unless we use an
infinite ratio and that's what that
brick wall limiting was that we saw
before where the signal was just
just chopped off that's where it just
went
like that and like that that's that
brick wall limiter thing that i
mentioned earlier that's using that same
ratio of infinity to one
okay so that covers threshold and ratio
these are the two of the four parameters
you can see them here we got threshold
and ratio
now clamping the audio like this doesn't
sound musically pleasing
furthermore
going from clamping the signal to
suddenly not clamping it doesn't sound
good either and this brings us to the
other two parameters the attack and the
release the attack parameter controls
how long to wait after the signal
exceeds the threshold before gain
reduction is applied
the release parameter controls how long
to wait once the signal stops exceeding
the threshold before the gain reduction
is no longer applied
let me show you what that looks like on
this graph
all right we're back with our signal it
goes from it's got a plus 6 db range on
it
uh the threshold is zero is still zero
let's give it an attack time of
one of these ticks right here so what
that means if we draw a vertical line
where this intersection
happens let's just let's just pretend it
happens right on this line right here
that means that we're gonna wait until
this tick
to actually start compressing this
signal okay
so now i've got this orange line right
here
what this means is that it's not going
to start applying compression until this
point in time so this chunk of signal
right here is not compressed it's going
to go over the threshold
and what is actually going to happen is
we're going to apply the same rule right
here of you know let's do two to one
so this is you know let's say this is
this looks like four
so we're at four db
so this is going to produce an output of
two
which means we're going to get something
like this here
we're going to see that
okay so like i was saying we have this
one intersection point
what's going to happen is the signal is
going to come to here
it's going to rise the way it was
normally going and then when it's going
to hit that attack time
let's say this is attack right there
and this is going to go down like this
and go like that
so it's going to wait before
gain
reduction is applied based on however
long this time is set to
okay
that's the attack time
again the release parameter is going to
control how long to wait once the signal
stops exceeding the threshold before
gain reduction is no longer applied
so what that means on this side is that
let's say the release time if we draw
this line down here let's say this is
our release right here
just it's just one chunk of this right
here
so what that means is it's going to
continue to apply
gain reduction to this
until we get to about there and then
it'll drop across
and how much gain reduction is applied
depends on the ratio these two
parameters the attack and release time
allow us to smooth the transition
between compressing the input signal and
not compressing the input signal
and then finally the threshold is always
expressed in decibels and the attack and
release times are expressed in
milliseconds
so the ratio is not expressed in any
units even though conceptually we like
to think of it as input decibels versus
output decibels
so with this knowledge in hand let's
begin coding up some audio parameters to
control our
soon to be functional compressor
one of the things we need to think about
is synchronizing these audio parameters
with our gui
thankfully juice solves that for us with
the audio processor value tree state
class
this class synchronizes our audio
parameters with the host application
that is loading our plugin and with our
plugins gui we're going to need one of
these in our audio processor
it's going to need to be public so that
the gui can attach all of its knobs and
sliders and buttons etc to it now
parameters must be declared when the
plugin is created they cannot be
dynamically created as such the apvts
expects us to provide the list of
parameters when it is constructed so
we're going to need a function that will
provide that list for us in the form of
an audio processor value tree state
parameter layout object let's head on
over to
our pluginprocessor.h
let's go to the end of the public
section right here
and i'm going to use an alias using
apbts equals juice audio processor value
tree state
now i'm going to declare this function
first static ap oops
um parameter layout
create parameter layout
all right now we can declare our ap vts
give me the argument list
all right we want this one all right we
want to connect to this
we're not going to use an undo manager
we're just going to call it parameters
and then the parameter layout will be
provided by our create parameter
layout
function
all right let's declare
let's see i'm going to use my alias now
a b v t s
and then i got to use curly braces here
instead of parentheses because it's
initialization
now we can go implement our uh the
function that will provide the param the
parameter layout let's go to the cpp
file i'm going to put this all on one
screen let me hide this uh
hide this assistant guy all right i'm
going to put this down in
put this past the set state information
put this right here
first things first return type
parameter layout
and then the name of our class and the
function
[Music]
all right first thing we need is uh the
thing we're going to return
lay out and we're going to return that
all right we're going to be using the
juice name space a lot i don't want to
have to type it so we're going to use
the using alias
okay the first parameter we will create
is the threshold parameter i'm going to
set the range for the threshold to be
between negative 60 and plus 12. i'm
going to set the step size to one
decibel meaning we can adjust the
threshold in one decibel increments
the skew parameter will be one
now the skew parameter affects how this
range of values from negative 60 to plus
12 is distributed across the slider
that for the slider that's going to be
attached to this parameter if you want
to learn about this stuff i covered all
of this in detail in the simple eq
tutorial okay here we go layout.add we
need to make a unique pointer
all right we want to make a
audio parameter
float this one right here that guy off
we're not going to use this
my first parameter is going to be
threshold parameter name is also
threshold normalizable range we'll
figure that out in a second all right we
want to have a default value of zero
decibels for our threshold let's define
a normalizable range next
normalizable range let's see which one
do we want
uh this one has start
and interval and skew we'll use that one
all right it's going to be a float type
our range start is going to be negative
60 range end is positive 12. our
interval value is 1
and our skew is 1.
all right awesome next i'm going to dial
in the attack and release i want to have
a minimum attack and release time of 5
milliseconds so that means our
compressor will always take at least 5
milliseconds to start compressing once
the input signal goes over the threshold
i'm going to set the max time to 500
milliseconds and i'm going to set the
step size and the skew to 1.
the slider controlling the attack and
release will be linear just like the
threshold slider let's do that next
first let's define the range
auto attack release range equals
normalizable range
this guy right here floats our range
start is going to be five milliseconds
like we said
um then we're gonna have 500 as the end
and then one and one for the skew and
for the step size let's add an attack
param and a release param
layout.add
make
unique
uh this is audio parameter float
and
oops i forgot
this we want this one right here okay
this is attack
attack our normalizable range will be
this thing
our default value will be 50
milliseconds
all right we can do the exact same thing
for the release
just need to change the name
paste that there
i'm going to change this release time to
be 250
and we need to add the closing carrot to
the template type
and then let's change this to say
release
and let's line these guys up now finally
we need to give ourselves some ratios
a one-to-one ratio results in no
compression and a 100 to 1 ratio is
basically brick wall limiting i'm going
to use those values as like my start and
end range and i'm going to add some
values in between and since i don't want
to use linear steps between 1 and 100
because that would just provide a huge
list of ratios i'm going to use audio
parameter choice and hard code
the choices that i'm going to use okay
the audio parameter choice constructor
requires a string array of choices so
i'm going to declare my choices first
i'm going to convert them into strings
and then i'm going to add them to the
string array
then i will create the parameter
so here's my choices
so i'm going to do i'm going to start at
1
1 2 3 4 5 with a 1.5 this is a pretty
common
um just you know very very light
compression basically one two three four
five six seven eight you know linear
steps and then once we hit 10 i do 10 15
20 then 50 then 100. okay this 20 50 and
100 are all basically gonna sound the
same they're just
variously more aggressive forms of brick
wall limiting
now i can declare my string array
and now i can use i can convert my
choices into juice string
objects now there's a string
constructor
that takes a um takes a double and we
can specify how many decimal places get
used so that's the one i want here
double double value into number of
decimal places i only want to display
one decimal place so we're going to do
that first
and we're going to pass the choice to it
that takes care of that
now
we can create the parameter and i do not
want one to one to be the default ratio
so i think three to one would be better
so i'm going to use the index of this
guy right here as the default value and
remember that indexing starts with zero
in c plus so we go like this layout dot
add
std make unique
audio parameter choice
all right this is going to be called
ratio
this is also ratio and my choices are
the string array my default index is
let's see this is zero one two three
that guy right there all right
like that and then we need our
carrot
all right there we go let's run it and
we will see our sliders let's see what
we got
this should show us some sliders okay
look at this we got our threshold guy
right here we've got our attack time
we have our release time and here we
have our ratio
awesome
let's add saving and loading of the
parameters next
let's implement saving and loading of
our plug-in parameters state
it's very easy to do because the plug-in
state is stored in the audio processor
value tree states
state member i'll show you what i'm
talking about
go over here let's go to where it's
actually
defined jump to definition
way down here in the at the end of the
public section
there is a state member let's just look
for that state
right here yes it was at the
bottom of this okay this is the public
member the state okay this is the state
of the whole processor all right let's
go back to where we were plugin
processor.cpp
let's move to the get state information
function
it's very easy to implement saving and
loading of our plugins parameter state
and that's because the
plug-in state is stored in that state
value tree okay now the value tree
serializes to memory very easily we can
use a memory output stream to handle the
busy work which is needed to write the
ap vts state to the memory block that
this function has been given by the host
it's this thing right here so all we
have to do is create a memory stream
juice memory output stream
uh here's the block we're going to write
to
okay we're going to write to destination
data
um yes we can append because who knows
if we're getting an empty one or a full
one
one that's empty or one that's already
got a bunch of stuff in it let's give
ourselves a member name a variable name
and then we can just do apvcs dot state
dot write to stream and then write it to
our memory output stream
all right wasn't that easy now we can do
the reverse and restore our plug-in
state from memory using a value tree
helper function
the only thing we need to check for is
whether or not the tree that was pulled
from
the uh chunk of memory we were given
this stuff right here we just need to
check if it's valid um before we copy it
into our plug-in state once we know that
it's valid we can replace the plug-in
state appropriately
here's the free function to use juice
value tree
read from data this is the one we want
so we're going to pass the data we're
going to pass its size in bytes
this is going to give us back a value
tree auto tree equals we just need to
make sure it's valid if tree dot is
valid
if it's valid then we can replace it ap
vts.replace
state with our tree
awesome let's test it out
where did that go
oh you're hiding okay we'll put you here
all right i'm going to change the ratio
from 3 to 10
then i'm going to save and quit
and i'm going to re-run it
the ratio should appear as 10.
and there it is perfect all right cool
let's add a compressor next and get it
to modify some audio next
if you get stuck or run into trouble
while coding this or simple eq just grab
one of my free products from programming
for musicians.com and you can message me
directly in the slack workspace and i
will help you directly
juice has a generic compressor that we
will be using for this project in order
to access it we need to include the dsp
module first before we can use it so
let's go to our juicer file
okay go to the modules section click on
this plus icon right here
add a module global juice modules path
and choose the juice dsp class
dsp module save and reopen
all right now
there it is now we can use the juice dsp
classes let's go to the private section
of our header file
plugin processor let's declare an
instance and then next we will prepare
it in prepare to play
so juice dsp
compressor
float
compressor
that was easy
all right let's head over to the cpp
file and prepare it go to plug-in
processor
and go to prepare to play now we need to
prepare our compressor we do this by
passing a process spec object to the
compressor we must first set up this
spec object let's declare one juice
dsp process spec give it the name spec
first it needs to know the maximum
number of samples that will be processed
at any time so spec dot maximum block
size equals this parameter here
samples per block next it needs to know
the number of channels this compressor
can handle multiple channels we will use
the number of output channels that our
plug-in can support as the number of
channels to configure our compressor
with spec dot num channels equals get
total num output channels
okay and now it finally it needs to know
the sample rate which is this parameter
here
spec dot sample rate equals sample rate
now we can pass it to our compressor
which will prepare it
compressor
dot prepare
spec
next go to process block
all right now we can start using our
compressor to squish our audio the
compressor wants a context to process
and this context requires an audio block
in order to be constructed so let's
create an audio block out of the buffer
that was provided to us
let's get rid of this stuff right here
and we're going to leave this code which
clears channels that are not in the
input okay so first let's declare an
audio block juice dsp audio block
and we want to use the one that takes a
buffer as the constructor
float
pass it the buffer
pass it this thing right here all right
let's give it a name auto block equals
whoops let's spell that right
all right now that we've got our block
we can create a context
auto context equals juice dsp and here's
where we want our context we're going to
use a replacing context
which means we're going to replace the
audio in the buffer with our processed
audio
and we want the one that takes a block
as its constructor argument
float
block
now that we have our context we can
process audio with our compressor
compressor.process
context
let's run it
everything should sound the same
let's try it out
and just to be sure that i've got some
signal
that stuff is actually happening i'm
going to instantiate
project 12. i'm going to feed
project 12 with our output
and this is just going to be over here
so we can see what's going on
okay let's play it we're going to run
some sound through it
all right
now
not doing anything to the sound and if
we bypass this
sound is the same
all right so this is because we have not
wired up any parameters to our
compressor to adjust
the threshold attack release and whatnot
we've got our parameters here but they
are not connected to the compressor
that's actually doing signal processing
let's do that next
head on over to the header file plug-in
processor dot h
okay now the apvts has a member function
that returns pointers to the parameters
that we created in the create parameter
layout function it does not make sense
to call this member function for every
single parameter every time process
block is called remember process block
if our buffer size is small it could be
being called 750 times a second
so the cost of looking up those
parameters could get expensive very
quickly and this is one of those
optimizations that we can do i know the
rule don't prematurely optimize but this
is one of the ones where it's okay to do
it alright so let's create some member
variables that will act as cached
versions of our audio parameters for
this compressor instance we're going to
use the same types that we used when we
created our parameters if we go over
here go to our create parameter layout
we used audio parameter float float
float and audio parameter choice so we
will create pointers to those okay so go
to pluginprocessor.h
and start declaring them here juice
audio parameter oops let's spell that
right parameter float make pointer
attack
initialize it
okay we're going to do the same thing
for the release
and the threshold release
threshold and then
the ratio is a choice parameter juice
audio parameter choice
let's move over to the process block
next and use these guys first before we
set them up okay go to process block
all right now here is how we use these
guys first of all we need to use them we
need to configure all this stuff before
we start processing audio i'm going to
do that before i create the block and
the context
okay here is how we use these parameters
the float parameters have a get function
that we can use and we just need to call
the appropriate compressor function
with this parameter value so we do
compressor
dot set
and you can see we've got choices here
attack release threshold ratio so let's
start with the attack set attack
and then we call attack param
and just get the value
let's do the same thing for the release
and the threshold compressor dot set
release
release
get
compressor dot set threshold
threshold
get
now for the ratio setting we need to
extract the float value from the current
ratio choice if you recall let's scroll
down here
if you recall uh the choices are stored
in a string array
all right so we need to get the float
value of the current choice from the
string and thankfully there is a helper
function
in the string class which does this for
us and all we need to do is get the name
of the current choice and then call that
helper function so let's do that next we
can do compressor
dot set ratio
and do the ratio parameter and we need
to get the current choice name this guy
right here returns a string and then we
just need to call that string helper
function get float value
now before we actually test this we need
to initialize our member variables so
they aren't null
let's go to the constructor to do that
because if you remember when we declared
these guys
they're all currently null if we were to
run this now we would get a big old
crash all right so let's go on up to the
constructor
all right now as i said earlier there is
a member function in the ap vts that
allows us to retrieve pointers to
parameters that we have added
and all of these parameters are stored
internally as ranged audio parameter
this is the base class that all
parameter types come from so we need to
cast these parameters these ranged audio
parameters to their correct type before
we can assign them to the cached
instances that we declared
so let's do that we need let's do the
attack parameter first let's do attack
equals
like i said we need to cast it to a
juice audio parameter float
and this is where we call
apvts.getparameter
and our name was attack okay now the
getparameter function will return a
nullpointer if the parameter name that
we provided is not found in the
list of parameters in case we type the
parameter name incorrectly it's very
useful if we assert when the parameter
is null so this is going to help us
catch any misspelled parameter names so
we can do jsert
attack
is not a null pointer
remember this function returns null
if it doesn't find this parameter and if
it does find this parameter
then
if this cast succeeds then the attack
will not be null pointer if this cast
fails like for instance let's say the
attack was actually an integer audio
parameter in
or this cast would fail and we would
have a null pointer here and we would
hit a j assert so this is really handy
so let's do that same thing for the
uh two other float parameters just copy
this
we'll make this the release
release
and change this to release and then we
can do threshold
threshold
threshold
and threshold for the ratio we need to
cast to audio parameter choice is this
ratio
ratio ratio
choice
audio parameter choice
and ratio all right perfect let's
compile it and run it and tweak some
sliders
we should hear some audible effects
here's how we're gonna test this out
okay change the ratio to like 50 to one
and then we're going to set the
threshold pretty low and then we're
gonna start messing with the attack time
so
highly recommend get yourself some
headphones to hear this
all right let's run some audio through
it though
all right change that ratio to 50
drop that threshold down
and we can really hear it clamping on
that signal let's adjust this attack
time
so you can hear how the signal goes
you can hear how the signal peeks
through and then gets clamped down real
quick that's that attack time the weight
once the signal is past the threshold
before it actually starts getting
clamped
we can hear if we change the change the
ratio to something
more subtle
uh to a lower ratio we can hear that
it's going to
um
it's not going to be as drastic of an
effect
so if we go back to 50 we can really
hear it doing something major
and then
if we set that attack time as fast as
possible we're not going to hear any
attack at all because our ears just
don't hear
we just hear the audio getting really
slammed
[Music]
okay
if we set that release time really fast
we're not going to hear so much
oh we can start to hear a lot of
distortion happening it's really
smashing the signal
all right let's bypass it
see what's going on
[Music]
all right let's increase that release
time
all right cool
so there we go our compressor is
currently compressing
all right let's find something else to
do to make this turn this into a
multi-band compressor next
all right cool
let's add a bypass parameter it's much
easier to click on this parameter than
it is to right-click on the plug-in in
the audio plug-in hosts filter graph and
toggle that menu option so let's head on
over to the create parameter layout and
add a bypass parameter stick this at the
end
layout
dot add
std make
unique we want to add an audio parameter
bool audio parameter
bool this one right here all right this
is called bypassed
same name by passed and the default
value is false meaning it is not
bypassed
that means it's active
next let's declare a cached version of
this plugin processor.h down to the
bottom stick this guy right here
juice audio parameter bool pointer
bypassed
nullpointer
we can toggle whether or not our
compressor processes the audio by
setting the is bypassed flag on the
context let's head on over to the plugin
processor dot cpp go to process block
and we can modify this context okay this
is the simplest way to do this
we can toggle whether or not our
compressor processes the audio let's
just actually go look at this okay if
context is bypassed then just copy from
the input to the output and get out of
here okay otherwise
do all this stuff which actually
processes the code processes the audio
samples all right this is the simplest
way to
toggle bypassing all we have to do is go
context dot is bypassed equals our
bypass parameter
and get that value
okay another option would be to write an
if statement and wrap all of this stuff
that creates
um that creates the block and the
context and does the processing in that
but this is much much simpler to just do
this okay so let's finally move to the
constructor and initialize this param we
will follow the same pattern as before
initialize and then
check it out all right we copied it
let's change this to be bypassed
and we want audio parameter bool
and this is
bypassed
and then we just check it if it's null
or not all right let's run and test it
let's see what happens
grab these headphones one more time
all right there's our bypass parameter
go ahead and start the music
wow it's really slammed
there we go
bypass parameter is
working as uh expected
so this makes it much easier to compare
the unprocessed and the processed audio
so we can hear what our compressor is
doing
all right cool
that was easy
super easy
we are trying to build a three band
compressor
what we have done so far is implemented
the functionality of a single band
so it makes sense for us to wrap this
functionality into a class so it can be
reused easily
let's do that next
let's declare a compressor band struct
let's go to our plugin processor dot h
and turn on the assistant editor
actually before we do this let's make a
commit let's go over here
stage all this stuff
i'll say implemented basic compressor
functionality
all right there's our juicer file
filter graph yes we want that right we
added our params
and then here's where we initialized our
params
here's where we initialized our
compressor here's where we processed our
audio
here's where we saved the uh here's
where we're using the generic audio
processor editor
here's where we are saving and loading
the state
and then here's where we are creating
our parameter layout
all right as i was saying let's go to
our header file go up to the top
let's declare a compressor band struct
let's add an instance of the compressor
class to this and make it private
now for the ease of initialization i'm
going to make the audio parameters
public in this class let's just go copy
them from our audio processor
copy these guys
let's make them public
next we are going to need some member
functions that update the compressor
settings that prepare the compressor and
that also process audio through the
compressor
let's declare the prepare function first
put that down here
it's going to take a process spec object
let's prepare our compressor with it
now we can update our compressor
settings by copying the code from the
process block function that we had
written earlier so let's do that
let's just write this function right
here void update compressor settings
and then let's go to our process block
that's right here
and we're going to grab these things
and just copy that right over like that
okay the same goes for processing audio
we are going to copy the code that we
used here it's these guys
and we just have to remember to pass in
a buffer by reference since we will be
modifying that buffer
so let's declare that here void process
juice audio buffer float
reference buffer
and now we need our block and our
context we need to set the bypass state
and then process
boom
now we can replace our compressor and
the parameters in our audio processor
with one instance of this compressor
band class let's do that go way down to
the bottom
let's comment all of this out
and change it to compressor
band
compressor
like that
now we need to do a bit of revision in
the process block it's right here so
let's take care of that
it's coming out the old way of using the
compressor
to come with that stuff out now we just
need to call the update function that
updates the compressor compressor dot
update
settings
and then pass our buffer directly to the
compressor compressor dot
process
buffer
okay the last thing we need to do is
configure these parameters
like we were doing but um we need to
configure these in the constructor but
for this object instead of these
directly
all right we just need to go up to here
now we need to make these all say
compressor dot attack that sort of thing
so these cached parameters now live in
the
compressor band class so we just need to
update these variable names here
compressor dot attack like that
ratio
and bypassed
okay let's test it everything should
function exactly as it did a moment ago
let's try it out
all right
i got my headphones
all right um let's do a quick clean and
rebuild just to make sure
clean
rebuild
all right one more time
[Music]
[Applause]
all right that works as expected we can
now start to think about
how to ride a multi-band compressor now
that we have this building block of the
compressor band
all right let's make a commit now that
we have our compressor banned
um let's clean up this code
let's get rid of this dead stuff too
let's see
it's gonna be in process block
that's down here let's get rid of this
okay let's make a commit
added compressor band wrapper
that's that that's that
that's that guy that's that all right
and our filter graph stage
okay great
let's figure out the roadmap for
implementing the rest of the dsp in our
plug-in
let's go to the top we'll put this at
the top of the header file there's that
file here we go at the very top but this
below the fragment once
okay
road map
number one is figure out how to split
the audio into three bands figure out
how to split the audio into three bands
number two is going to be create
parameters
to control where this split
happens
number three we need to prove that
splitting into three bands produces no
audible
audible artifacts
okay number four we need to create audio
parameters for the three compressor
bands
create audio parameters for
the three compressor bands
and these need to live on each band
instance
just like we currently have one
compressor band which has
the parameters as cached members okay
number five we need to create the two
remaining compressors
create the two remaining not create we
need to add the two add two
remaining compressors
because we already have one
all right number six
we need to add the ability to mute solo
and bypass individual compressors add
ability
to mute solo bypass individual
compressors
number seven
we need to add input and output gain
because compression lowers the output
level
add input and output gain
to offset
uh
changes in output level
number eight we need to clean up
anything that needs cleaning up clean up
any
um
anything that needs cleaning up
all right that will conclude the dsp
side of the plug-in dsp road map
okay let's get started on the first one
uh figuring out how to split the audio
into three bands
all right it's time to break out the
white board
[Music]
okay
let me erase this graph of how the sound
card talks to the process block and the
speakers
okay
sorry for the ring light
okay here we go all right we learned in
the simple eq project about low pass and
high pass filters
let's just draw what those are so say
we've got
um say we've got a
filter spectrum like this
um here's like
here are the different frequency ranges
this is like 20 hertz this is
20k
all right
low pass is
eliminating all the frequencies above
whatever the crop the threshold is let's
say we got something like this so if i
go let's say i want to eliminate all the
frequencies below
let's just call this 1k right here
if i want to eliminate all the
frequencies i would use a
high cut filter which is going to cut
out the high stuff and our frequency
response will look like this
likewise we can have a
a low cut which is going to
eliminate all of the frequencies below
whatever our cutoff is set to let's set
it to the same frequency
so i will have a filter response like
this
all right so that's what we learned in
simple eq the
low pass and high pass or low cut and
high cut however you want to think of it
okay now if we duplicate our audio
buffer
we can filter the copies separately and
if we set the cutoff of these two
filters to the same frequency then we
will get a frequency response like this
where we have roughly flat except for
right here
now there's a special type of filter
that we can use for the low pass and
high pass filters that will actually
produce a flat magnitude response when
we sum the output of both
of both of these filters
this is the linquitz reilly filter let
me write that here
l-i-n-k-w-i-t-z riley
filter
oh geez that's like a terrible r there
we go that looks like an r
okay now these are known as audio
crossover filters if you have a speaker
that has multiple drivers in it it is
using some kind of audio crossover to
send part of the signal to each of the
drivers separately
for instance you might have a 10 inch
woofer you might have a 5 inch mid-range
driver and you might have a two inch
tweeter
so let me show you um let me move this
stuff over here and just draw a quick
diagram of the speaker
the speaker's crossovers might be set up
so that the 10 inch woofer
only covers
frequencies below
100 hertz let me draw that on here
so the uh speakers crossover filters may
be set up such that the 10-inch woofer
only outputs uh
audio that is below 100 hertz
so that might be that's this guy right
here this might only cover 100 hertz
and below which means it's only covering
this range
like that
the 5 inch driver
might be set up to only output
100 to 5000
that might look like this
let's see here's here's 5k right about
there
and that means the tweeter can only
output stuff above well not can the
tweeter may be set up so that it only
outputs audio above 5000 hertz
so this is 5
k
plus
that looks like this
let me clean up this line right here
because this one's bad
okay now on a frequency plot we can see
that this is a pretty even distribution
the mid-range is doing a decent amount
the um
little range is kind of handling there
now why do we do this
the reason is because it's pretty
difficult to make a big heavy 10-inch
speaker move fast enough
to produce frequencies above 5000 hertz
right you got all that mass you're
trying to move it
at a really really fast frequency and
it's really difficult it takes a lot of
energy to do that
likewise it's really difficult to make a
small two inch speaker like this tweeter
produce any kind of frequency below 100
hertz you know all of us are very
familiar with listening to
audio on our cell phones
on the speakers that are built in and
there's no bass whatsoever coming out of
that tiny little speaker so
some really smart people figured out
that if we split the signal using these
special filters these link with reilly
filters
we can have much better sounding music
come out of our speakers when we
dedicate each speaker to a specific
frequency range all right now in the
juice module there are link with reilly
objects that we can use to split our
audio into separate bands before we
start using those however we need to
start creating parameters that can
control our filters and compressors
so we're going to have a lot of
parameters for these compressor bands so
it makes sense now to refactor how our
audio parameters are being created
we don't want to have to type so much
code since there will be a lot of
repetitive code in the next few sections
of this course
okay
let's get started creating a new
approach to declaring our parameters
the system we are going to create will
let us easily look up the names of our
parameters and not have to worry about
misspelling anything either which is
cool all right let's go to our header
file
first let's declare a namespace
called params let's put this above
compressor brand
namespace
params
i am going to add an enumeration and
this enumeration will represent all of
the parameters that we are going to have
in this project
we are going to add to it as we add more
dsp functionality and add more gui
functionality as well for now here is
the basic enum
i'm going to call it names
i'm going to add two entries for the
crossover frequency parameter first
low
mid
mid crossover
freak
and then mid high
crossover freak
and then i'm going to add entries for
the threshold attack release and ratio
for each of the three bands
finally i am going to add an entry for
the ability to bypass each of these
bands
bypassed
band
we'll do low mid and high
all right now i'm going to create a map
that will act as a lookup table for the
string name of the parameters if you
remember when we create our parameters
let's go way down here
when we create our parameters we pass a
string in
okay
so we're going to pass in the name's
enumeration value and that will give us
back our string name that's how this map
is going to work so this is going to
eliminate the chance of misspelling
anything
and we'll be able to use autocomplete to
choose items from the enumeration when
we look up our parameter names
as well which is cool so here we go
inline const std map
we're going to use our names enumeration
paired with juice string
and this function is going to return
this
map as a const reference i'm going to
call it get params
all right now this is what is known as a
myers singleton pattern well it's kind
of like meyer singleton it's more like a
local function
singleton pattern first we're going to
declare a static map
and we're just going to return that map
map
we'll call it params
and we'll declare what it is in just a
second
and then we will return params
okay so now we just need to um supply
um
pairs for the map so we just need to
start declaring them so let's do the
first one
we're going to use this guy
low mid high crossover
and then i'm going to provide the name
for what i want this parameter to
actually be called
low
mid
crossover freak
when see
i'll just do free so it's all within one
line
okay we just need to do this
for
all of these guys here
so i'm going to copy this
all right last is to add a
oops we need to add commas at the end of
all these
there's our map now what is interesting
about this pattern is that this static
map that we've got right here it does
not get created until we actually call
this function so that's pretty handy
okay let's update our existing
parameters to use this map now
so we need to change where the
parameters are created and also where
they are assigned to the current
compressor band so let's do that first
all right head on over to the create
parameter layout function i'm going to
switch from using um
i'm going to get rid of the assistant
editor all right head over to
pluginprocessor.cpp
and go to create parameter layout
i'm gonna save myself a lot of time by
adding the namespace alias right here
not alias by using the using keyword
and i'm going to get a local reference
copy of the parameters map
const auto params equals get params
now i just need to replace all of these
strings with
the correct entry in the map and i'm
going to set all these as though they
were being assigned to the low
compressor band so the first one becomes
params.at
names
threshold low band
let's do the same thing for the attack
and the release
and change this to attack low band
attack low band
and then for the release
let's fix this indentation as well
this is release low band
next we need to do our ratio
let's put these on separate lines
copy these guys right here
ratio low band
and then finally the bypassed
bypass low band
bypass low band
all right that was easy enough let's
revise our um constructor where we
initialize the cached parameters next
head on up to the constructor
we're going to do the same trick i used
before of using
the namespace and caching the
sorry not caching but getting a local
reference copy of the params map using
namespace
params const auto params equals get
params
if we look at our enumeration in the
params class
we have a lot of float parameters and
the plan is to add solo and bypass
functionality as well as mute which are
boolean parameters and i don't want to
have to keep typing this casting code
more than i need to so let's write a
helper function
to do that let's go back to our
constructor you can see what i'm talking
about i don't want to have to write this
line more than i need to
okay so let's write a helper function
we're going to use an in place lambda
and i'm going to capture all the stuff
that i use in the lambda by reference
call this float helper
auto float helper
equals lambda lambda lambda
all right we're going to need to capture
the ap vts because we're using that to
look up the parameters
so actually let's do this let's um
let's copy these lines into here and
we'll adjust what we've got so we're
going to change this to say param equals
that
and then we'll just say param is not an
alternator no pointer param
and then for this we wanted to say uh
params at
name like that
or we can do program name
okay so what do we need to capture let's
capture apbts
apvts equals this abvts
we need to capture the params
capture those guys capture these guys by
reference
now we need to pass in the parameter
this thing right here
so we'll just use auto
and then we also need to pass in the
param
name autopram name
all right cool unused variable let's use
it now
i'm using auto here because i want the
compiler to figure it out and you can do
that with lambdas which is pretty cool
again all of these are being treated as
though they are
being attached to the low filter band
the first one we're going to do is the
attack param so do float helper
and our
parameter is compressor dot attack
and then our parameter name is the
names low band
attack
okay
that takes care of this
now we need to do the release param
that takes care of this
and now threshold
that takes care of this
now i just need one for the choice
parameter and the boolean parameter
and remember we're going to have three
different choice parameters because
we're going to have three different
compressors with ratios and a boolean
one for the bypassed mute and solo so it
makes sense to just create it now so i'm
just going to copy this and we're just
changing with the cast
we're just changing the cast that gets
used really so this is going to be audio
parameter
bool
uh not but we're doing choice first
choice
so this is the choice helper
we can call it
choice helper
we got compressor dot ratio
and our param name is names
uh ratio low band
all right that takes care of this guy
and now let's add our
uh boolean helper
duplicate paste
bool helper
change the cast type
and now we just call it bullhelper
compressor.bypassed and we got names
bypassed low band
all right let's run it just to make sure
everything works as expected
all right my headphones
we're going to adjust all the parameters
and see if they work the way they should
or if we get a js or false
all right node.jser that's cool
when you make big changes like this
sometimes you need to recompile the code
so let's do a you need to clean it out
and recompile it from scratch so let's
do that
all right here we go
change that to 50
drop that down
[Music]
all right that works for me
save quit
all right awesome all the controls are
doing what they're supposed to be doing
all right if you were curious as to why
when we loaded this up our previous
parameter settings were no longer found
it's because we changed parameter names
so they
fell back to their default values
okay
onward
let's make a commit of our changes let's
see what we've done
added
road
added road map and params
namespace
all right that's that
and then we added where we use our
params and all that good stuff
okay
now let's uh go to our roadmap
let's tackle this guy right here figure
out how to split the audio into three
bands
i had mentioned link with riley filters
earlier now we're going to use them
let's go look at the documentation for
this class okay it says that um these
are used in audio crossovers that have
two outputs a low pass and a high pass
such that there's some
is equivalent to an all pass filter with
a flat magnitude frequency response
remember this it's they're talking about
this like the response of the filter
when you sum them together gives you a
flat response
okay they are saying that summing the
output of two filters is identical to
the same result you would get if you ran
your audio through an all pass filter
we are going to use that information
later when we prove that the filters do
not add any audible artifacts to the
signal for now here is what we need to
know we can split the audio into two
bands using the
juice linquit's reilly filters
low band and high band once we do that
we need to split one of these bands into
two other bands
that comes with its own set of problems
that we need to deal with so for now
let's just get a high band and a low
band working first before we add a mid
band okay so let's go down to our plugin
processor dot h so we're going to go to
our private section
of plug-in processor
way down at the bottom
we're going to do this after our
compressor band
let's declare two instances of this
linquist reilly filter i'm going to use
an alias to make typing it easier using
filter equals juice dsp
link widths
riley
come on auto complete
filter
float
all right give me two instances filter
low pass high pass
all right we are also going to need a
cached audio parameter for the crossover
frequency
juice audio parameter float
low crossover
little pointer
all right each of these filters modifies
the audio
if we low pass our process block buffer
then high pass filtering it will not
give us the expected results here's my
audio band
okay we're doing low pass and high pass
so if we low pass a bunch of signal like
this
this is what's left in the buffer
okay this stuff right here this is
what's left in the audio buffer right we
originally had
you know this was full spectrum
and then
you know we chopped out all of the high
pass we did a low pass which kept all of
the low frequency and everything above
it got cut now if we try to high pass
this
at the same frequency
you know we're trying to
cut out everything below
you know let's say this is our high pass
that means we're trying to cut out
everything below this point but there's
nothing here this is all gone so the
only thing we're gonna get left with
is this chunk right here
that's not what we want
that is not the result that we want to
have okay so what we need to do is use
separate buffers and these are what
we're going to sum later as the
documentation said if you sum the
results together you'll get a flat
magnitude response
all right let's declare an array of
buffers std array
juice audio whoops let's spell that
right audio buffer float two of them
filter buffers
let's spell that right
okay let's create a filter parameter
next and then initialize it and then
prepare our filters and buffers
head over to
pluginprocessor.cpp create parameter
layout let's do this at the bottom after
we make our bypass param
layout.add
here we want std make unique
we want an audio parameter float
all right we are going to set the
crossover's range to be the auditory
range of human here of human hearing 20
hertz to 20 000 hertz and we're going to
set the default frequency to 500
okay so first things first let's provide
our um
our names so params.at
names
crossover low mid
right copy that
duplicate it
let's give our default value of 500
and then we need a normalizable range
normalizable range
our range start
will be 20 our range end will be 20 000.
our interval value will be 1
meaning our
value can change in increments of one
hertz so 20 21 22 23 all the way to 20
000 and our skew will be one
next let's initialize our parameter
go on up to the constructor
can use our helper for that float helper
let's put this at the bottom
float helper we are initializing our low
crossover
with the names low crossover
awesome
now we need to prepare our filters so go
to prepare to play
let's do this here lp dot prepare
spec
high pass dot prepare spec
and now we need to prepare our buffers
so that they don't allocate whenever we
copy the input buffer into them let's do
that next for
auto buffer filter buffers
buffer dot set size
the number of channels is spec.num
channels number of samples is samples
per block
all right let's go to process block now
let's disable the uh compressor while we
mess with these um while we mess with
these filters for a little bit
comment those guys out
first
let's copy our incoming buffer into
these dedicated filter buffers for auto
filter buffer
filter buffers
fb equals buffer
each buffer in our filter buffers array
now contains a copy
of the
input of the buffer that we were given
from the sound card
all right next we will update our
filters cut offs both of the filters are
going to share the same cut off so auto
cut off
equals low crossover get
now we can do lp dot set cutoff
cut off
then hp dot set cutoff
cut off
now we must create blocks and contexts
for the filters all right so we do auto
fb0
block filter buffer zero block equals
okay so we've got one
audio block pointing to the first filter
buffer and then another audio block
pointing to the second filter buffer now
we can create our context
all right just initialize each context
from the appropriate filter block
and now we can process our audio lp dot
process lp gets the first filter buffer
of the two
fb0 context
hp
dot process
fb1 dot context oops
no dot
okay
now that our input buffer has been
turned into
two separate buffers each of which has
been filtered separately we need to sum
them back into a single buffer
now in order to ease some of this
struggle with copying let's cache some
of the details of the
input buffer so auto num samples equals
buffer dot get num samples
auto num
channels
equals
buffer.get whoops let's spell that right
getting them channels
and we need to clear our input before we
start um adding our filter buffers to it
so buffer dot clear
okay each channel of our filter buffer
needs to be copied back to the input
buffer so i'm going to write a helper
function to do that i'm going to use a
use a lambda in here to do it
auto add filter band
equals
lambda lambda lambda
first thing
let's see first thing we're going to do
is create a parameter for our input and
then
a parameter for the source that we're
going to copy from so here's our input
buffer
input buffer
and then where we're going to copy from
so const auto source
all right now we just need to simply
loop through all of the channels that
were in the input buffer and copy
from a source buffer into that so we can
do 4
auto i equals 0. i is less than
num channels is what we want so let's
capture that by copy
num channels
eyes let's numb channels
plus plus i
now we can do input buffer dot
add from
and let's see what are our parameters
let's see buffer
dot add from
let's do this okay our destination
channel is going to be i our destination
start sample is going to be 0.
so let's just do this we're going to do
i
we're going to do 0 our source is going
to be the source
source channel is going to be i
star source start sample is going to be
0 and then our num samples is going to
be
um this because buffer and the source
have the same number of channels so
we'll just call that ns
all right
this is what we add here
like that
all right and we need to capture n
s
n s equals num samples
okay
and just to go over that so we are
capturing our num channels and num
samples we are passing in
this guy we're going to pass it in as a
parameter and we're going to copy every
single channel from the source one at a
time
and add it to our input buffer
now we just need to call this helper
function with our filter buffers
add filter band our input buffer is
buffer and our source is filter buffers
zero
add filter band buffer
filter buffers
second one
all right perfect
let's run this and see what happens
grab my headphones
all right
[Music]
okay all the top end is gone
let's go figure out why that happened
let's go look at how this class gets uh
created
all right
we have a type parameter sets the filter
type well we didn't do that let's see
what type this thing defaults to
all right default filter type low pass
so that makes sense we're basically
running our audio
uh this is low passing it and then this
is also low passing it at the same
frequency let's solve that we need to
call that set um set type function let's
do that in the constructor
going up to the constructor
all right go down to the bottom let's
configure our filters lp dot set type
here we go juice dsp
link what's riley filter
all right now our lp is low pass and
then let's do it again for the high pass
this is hp
and this is high pass
all right let's test this again now
remember we don't have our compressors
turned on so we're literally just going
to hear this filtering
the result of our audio going through
the lp and the hp filters
here we
go all right no audible um no audible
effects to me
if we adjust the slider which is
adjusting the crossover
nothing no audible effects so that's
fantastic
all right perfect we are halfway through
splitting the audio into three bands
before we go further let's prove that
our filters are producing no audible
artifacts
we will also demo that the filters are
actually doing something by soloing each
one we'll do all that stuff next
let's make a commit of our progress it's
always a good idea to do that what did
we do
we added
link with
riley
filtering
here's what we did all the processing
here's where we set up our filters
that's where we prepared them
here's what we processed with them
here's where we created the parameter
let's go back here let's save and quit
this
okay we can bypass the filtering by
exiting the process block
before we clear our input buffer and
copy our filter buffers to it it's just
temporary but we can use our single
compressor's bypass parameter to control
this
alright the purpose is just to show that
the filters don't introduce any audible
effects
when the buffer copy step is bypassed we
are listening to the input buffer still
and when it's not bypassed we are
listening to the sum of the filter
buffers being copied into the input
buffer so this is very easy to write
we just need to do it after this num
channel so we can just say if compressor
dot bypassed
if it's bypassed um don't clear just
leave the function
right we've done our filtering but we're
not clearing our buffer and we're not
copying stuff into it okay
okay here is how we can prove that this
is actually what is happening let's run
this
okay first things first make sure this
bypass low band is toggled on
next let's add a breakpoint right on
buffer.clear now if we press play
notice that the breakpoint does not get
hit and it's not until we
uncheck the toggle button that it
actually gets hit and this is going to
cause like some weird audio stuff but
you know just bear with me
okay here we go gonna unbypass this
all right hit the breakpoint
so let's remove the breakpoint
all right now we can stop our audio
okay
but that proves uh the point i try i was
trying to make that our audio is
actually running through our filters and
we can hear the difference between if
it's um
between if we're hearing just like the
raw buffer input or if we're hearing our
filtered input okay
all right let's talk about this
crossover filter and one of the special
properties of it when you have a pair of
these filters like we have here
and you sum their output like we are
doing here
the result is the same as though you had
run your signal through an all pass
filter with the same cutoff frequency
i want to show you what i mean by that
so let's add an all pass filter and then
demonstrate toggling it with our lp and
hp filters so we can see how they sound
the same okay let's go to our header
file
let's go down here to our filter
let's add another filter filter ap like
that for all pass filter and now it
needs its own buffer so let's give it
one of those
juice
audio buffer
float
ap buffer
all right we will prepare it and set the
type next
let's go to the prepare to play function
prepare to play
let's do
ap dot prepare
spec
all right let's uh set the buffer size
ap buffer dot set size
spec.num channels
samples per block
all right let's go set the type in our
constructor we learned our lesson from
the first time we messed with these
filters and
we're going to make sure we're going to
set that type now
ap dot set type whoops
set type
juice
dsp let me just copy this
all pass
next we will make our process block
toggle between our low pass and high
pass doing the filtering versus our
all pass doing the filtering and we're
going to use that bypass parameter
like we used earlier because it's you
know it gives us a toggle button that we
can just easily click on and off
okay let's go do that next alright let's
go to our
process block let's get rid of this
bypass code let's just comment it out
for now
now we can copy our input buffer to our
all pass buffer ap buffer equals in uh
buffer
okay we got to make sure we do that
before we clear
all right let's do the same processing
you know we're going to create a block
and a context and then process with the
filter
so i'll just grab these two lines right
here and i will just rename them
this is ap block
and then this will be ap block
this is going to be ap buffer
and then this will just call this a
all pass context
and let's do our processing ap dot
process ap
context all right now we can revise our
logic that does the copying
if the bypass toggle is unchecked use
the low pass and high pass buffers
otherwise use the all pass buffer
so if
compressor
bypassed
get
if that toggle button is
unchecked
use these guys
otherwise
add filter band buffer
from the ap buffer
this logic will let us hear the lp and
hp buffers by default we already know
that they don't add audible artifacts
and toggling this checkbox will show
that the ap buffer produces the same
result so let's test this out we're
going to just run this we're going to
toggle the thing on and on
on and off
let's grab our headphones
all right so let's play it
turn this down
so if i toggle this
all right let's push stop real quick
now we can confirm that it's working by
making sure bypass is unchecked and then
setting a breakpoint in the else block
let's press start once we click that
check box the break point will be hit
perfect
this is expected
show all the dewey
okay so that works as expected
so let's investigate soloing the low and
the high bands next okay our compressors
will be able to compress either band so
it's important to know what these bans
sound like
let's check that out next
all right soloing one of these bands is
really easy
we just need to comment out which buffer
gets added to the input so let's solo
the low pass output by commenting out
the second line
all right we can toggle between hearing
the all pass filter and the low pass
filter using our check box let's run
this
oh you know what we can adjust this
there it goes
i was wondering why i wasn't doing
anything because i had this this cutoff
way up high
[Music]
all right so right now we're listening
to the low filter uh the low pass band
now we're listening to the all pass
all right
cool
save that quit
all right let's do it again and switch
to the high pass okay so uncomment this
one
all right sorry comment the first one
out and then uncomment the second one
let's run and test
all right we'll drag the same crossover
slider again so we can change how much
bottom end is actually cut out of the
signal
[Music]
[Music]
all right
all right so there you go so that is how
soloing and the muting of the bands
works okay it's all about figuring out
which buffer you want to copy to the
input
all right so we're going to do one more
little test with these audio filters
next
okay the final test that we will do is
to sum the inverse of the all pass
filter with the
output of the low pass and high pass
filter the purpose of this is to show
how the two outputs sum to zero or
silence
again we will be using the bypass switch
to toggle
between this behavior versus hearing the
output of the low pass and high pass
filters so let's comment out
this code actually let's copy this first
because we're gonna need this let's copy
this now we can comment this out
all right now paste this here okay we
are going to always copy the output of
the filters into our m into those buffer
that we were given by the audio
audio
system
okay now if the bypass switch is turned
on we will invert the all pass filter
buffer and add that to the output
we can do that by going if compressor
dot bypassed
get
if the switch is toggled on
then we need to invert every channel in
our all pass buffer
and then add that to the filter band so
let's let's set up the add band first
add filter band
buffer we're copying from the all pass
buffer
okay
and now we just need to invert so let's
do this for every channel and we can do
this using float vector operations so
four auto ch equals zero ch is less than
num channels
plus plus ch
now we can do juice
float vector operations and there's a
there's a way that we can multiply a
fixed value against every sample in a
particular channel so we're going to use
that multiply and we want the one that
takes a multiplier
okay our destination is going to be
a right pointer to one of the channels
in the ap buffer so ap buffer dot get
right pointer because we want to be able
to modify this buffer that's why
um our channel number is ch our
multiplier will be negative one
to flip it upside down and we're going
to do this for every sample so num
samples
all right now that they are inverted um
we already we're already adding them
over okay so now the next thing to do
and this is actually something we forgot
to do earlier um is to go up to where we
are setting our cutoffs and we need to
set the all pass filter to that have the
same cutoff
as the other filters
we forgot to do this earlier so when we
were dragging the slider back and forth
yeah just a fluke that um
it didn't sound audibly different to me
let's go to the last step we can test
this out now and if it works as expected
we will hear silence when we toggle the
bypass switch let's check it out
all right
[Music]
silence there we go and if we adjust the
frequency
[Music]
silence
all right awesome
so that is doing what it is supposed to
do
okay let's learn a little bit more
theory about this whole lp plus hp
versus the all pass filtering and how we
can use this to make three separate
audio bands that some to produce a
signal with no audible artifacts
once we have this knowledge we will
implement it and check off item one in
the dsp roadmap
let's make a commit of our progress from
uh working on this filter stuff before
we start diving into
filter band theory
all right what did we do oh we have to
fill the graph okay we um
uh tested
using
all paths filter that's basically what
we did we got our filter here and our
filter buffer here's where we set up the
filter type here's where we prepared it
here's where we set the cut off here's
where we did our processing
and then here's where we did the
inversion to
basically cancel out the regular
filtering
that's what's going on there all right
all right let's talk about filter band
theory
all right let's discuss some theory
behind these filters before we create
the three band splitter
filters work by delaying part of the
signal let me get this more on camera
we've got a pair of filters here a pair
of linguists riley filters we got low
pass one and high pass one
okay every time we filter the signal we
introduce a delay now i don't know how
the math of this delay actually works
and that's beyond the scope of this
video
that's what they end up doing in the
math is they apply delays to certain
frequencies in the spectrum and that's
how you end up getting that stuff to be
muted
so when we split the signal into low
pass and high pass bands we are
introducing the same delay
so to speak to both parts and then when
we run the signal through an all passed
filter the same delay is produced of
course that's assuming the all pass
filter the low pass and the high pass
all have the same cutoff frequency
so that means that we can use an
all-pass filter to equate this same
delay okay
so whenever we have a pair of these we
can replicate that same delay by using
an all-pass filter okay now we can use
this to our benefit we can split our
signal into two bands like we're
currently doing
and this split will just add one delay
to the signal you know delay so to speak
okay
if we then split one of these bands into
another delay
we will end up with three bands let me
show you what i mean all right so check
it out we've got our three bands here
this band this band and this band
okay that's what we're trying to
accomplish three bands however the
problem is that
lp1's output the signal that runs
through this chain only has one delay
whereas the signal that is split from
high pass one this guy and this guy
there are two delays and that means that
our signals will not sum
correctly okay
now as we learned earlier the all pass
filter introduces the same delay as this
so all we need to do is replace this
line
you just we just need to add an all pass
filter here
set to the same cutoff frequency
as these two filters
and we will have
a um
we'll have our solution
so this is the solution that we need to
use okay we just run lp1 through an all
pass filter and that gives us
an output that has the same number of
delays as the other
uh signals over here okay
so the low pass one to
all pass two
contains all of the audio be low filter
cut off zero
and then the uh high pass one to low
pass two contains all of the audio
between filter cutoff 1 and filter
cutoff
0
this range right here
and then
high pass 1 into high pass 2 contains
all of the audio at filter cut off 1.
all right so there we go three bands
that sum to a flat filter response okay
and we can prove that this null's out by
creating two more all pass filters set
to filter cut off zero and filter cut
off one
and inverting their output and then
summing it with the output of these
three bands okay all right in project 12
you will learn how to dynamically create
uh n number of bands you'll learn how to
figure out okay if i have seven bands
how many all-pass filters do i need how
many low-pass filters do i need how many
high-pass filters do i need and um how
do i structure them so that way it can
all sum together and can all
do everything that it's supposed to do
my computer can handle about eight
filter bands when i'm in debug mode
maybe yours can handle more than that
but it's a really really interesting
problem to solve and is very cool
so let's code that up next and
begin filtering
let's restructure our filtering i find
that it helps to declare them visually
in the same way that they will be
structured i'm also going to write the
name of the cutoff parameter that will
control that particular
group of filters
above that filter itself
so let's get rid of our old filters and
the buffers and stuff and start writing
this first all right here we go so
filter
uh we've got an lp1
and an ap2
all right that's part one we've got hp1
and that feeds into lp2 and then we've
got our hp2 on the bottom
so that guy let's add these cutoffs next
here we've got our fc0 filter cutoff 0
and filter cutoff 1.
let's rename this crossover
and add another one for the mid high
right click refactor rename
i'm going to call this the low mid
crossover
all right let's duplicate this
this is going to be the mid-high
crossover
mid
high crossover
finally we can give ourselves a third
filter buffer because we have three
bands
let's add another parameter for the
mid-high crossover then we will set our
filter types and then prepare our
filters and then use our filters
head over to
pluginprocessor.cpp go down to create
parameter layout go all the way to the
end where we create the low mid
crossover
copy and paste it
and change this to the mid high
crossover frequency
all right now while we are here i'm
going to change the range of the
crossovers so they do not overlap
so this first one is going to go from 20
hertz to 999 hertz
i'm going to change the default to
400
and then for the second one it's going
to have a range of 1000 to 20 000 hertz
and the default value will be
2 000 hertz
all right let us set our filter types
next and then initialize our cached
crossover variables
head up to the constructor
all right let's go to
let's do our cached value first
so float helper we're doing the mid high
crossover names
mid high
now let's tackle these errors we just
need to rename these types so it's lp1
now and hp1 and then it's ap2
and then this just needs to be
duplicated
for lp2 and hp2
alright cool let us go prepare these
next head over to prepare to play
again renaming the old filters this is
lp1 this is hp1 and this is ap2
and just copy these and rename
we've got lp2 and hp2
all right we don't have an all pass
buffer anymore so this line gets removed
all right let's configure some 3-band
filtering
next over to process block
the first thing to do is to configure
the filter cutoffs so the low mid cutoff
is applied to lp1
and hp1 all right let's rename this
parameter as well refactor rename
and this is low
mid
cutoff
the mid high cutoff is applied to lp2
hp2 and ap2 so let's get that value next
auto mid
high cutoff freq equals
mid high crossover get
and then this is ap2 ap2 gets the mid
high cutoff
and then let's copy these guys
and this is lp2 hp2 and they also get
the mid-high cutoff
the next thing to do is to create audio
blocks and contexts for each filter
buffer now there is a dry way to do this
but if you want to know how to do that
you need to take project 12 because
project 12 covers
all that in this video we are going to
hard code it
so the first thing we need to do is
let's add a block for our third
filter buffer
so copy and paste this
fb2 block goes to filter buffers2
let's add a context for it
copy this line
fb2 context
goes to fb2 block
and now we need to run the appropriate
context through the appropriate filters
lp1 and ap2 get the first filter buffer
ap2.process
fb0 context
next
hp1 and lp2 get the second buffer but
here's the thing we need to know
let's come back to my chart here
okay the thing to know and i've written
the names of like which filters go with
which brands the thing to know about
this is that
hp2 needs the result of hp1 so we have
to filter this first
we have to filter hp1 first
and then copy it to the second filter
buffer before we can run it through hp2
okay that's the only gotcha that's going
on here all right
it's okay so currently in our code we've
got lp1 and ap2 processing the first
filter buffer that's this line right
here
okay now what we need to do is
process hp1
into filter buffer one
and then
we can copy it to filter buffer two and
run it through here
and then run lp 2 through filter buffer
one so we've got filter buffer 0 filter
buffer 1 filter buffer 2. alright let's
do that let's turn that concept into
code
all right let's see hp1 processes filter
buffer context 1.
then
we copy the output of filter buffer 1
into filter buffer 2.
filter buffers
2 equals filter buffers
1.
all right now we can process lp2
that gets fb1 context
and then
hp2
can process filter buffer 2.
filter buffer two
okay this is very important now our
audio has been filtered into three bands
and now we need to sum it back let's get
rid of this um code right here the ap
buffer stuff because we don't have that
anymore
and let's get rid of this stuff here as
well let's just clean this up
now i want to make the bypass act as a
toggle like we did earlier so we will
just exit
before we clear
we'll go like that
okay i am going to comment out all of
this all pass invert code
because i do want to come back to it in
a little bit
but for now
we just need to add the third band
and i am not going to use a loop for
this even though this is pretty
repetitive
and that is because i eventually want to
have the ability to mute and solo and
bypass individual bands and that is
accomplished by not adding a filter
buffer
to the input buffer
and writing a loop right now would make
that you know we'd have to revise it
later which is annoying so for now we'll
just leave it
uh we'll just manually add each one like
that okay
let us go test this out
we're gonna toggle the bypass we're
gonna drag the sliders all that good
stuff
all right let's test this out
adjust the sliders
toggle the bypass
that sounds good to me i'm not hearing
any of that phasing
that's fantastic
all right now we can confirm that this
is working by toggling the bypass
checkbox
and then adding a breakpoint anywhere
after that bypass param check so i'm
going to add it on buffer.clear
and let's push play and then once we
unbypass our breakpoint will be hit
[Music]
yep
all right so it works as expected
okay the last test i want to do is the
null test with the inverted all pass
filters we will do that next
all right
let's close this guy
save quit
go to pluginprocessor.h
okay i showed earlier how a single
inverted all-pass filter will know the
output of a pair of low-pass high-pass
filters when they are all tuned to the
same cutoff frequency and you multiply
the output of the all pass filter by
negative one
i'm going to show that the same thing is
true here with these three bands each
stage in the filtering acts as a delay
that's this stuff right here the lp1 and
the hp1 that's stage one
and each delay can be nulled out with an
all-pass filter set to the same cutoff
of that stage
so we've got two stages so we need two
all-pass filters let's add them here
filter inv ap1 i inv ap2
all right now we are going to need one
buffer for the all pass filtering since
they are processed in series
juice
audio buffer
float
in ap buffer
next we need to set their types then we
need to prepare them and then we need to
process audio with them
head to the constructor in
pluginprocessor.cpp
let's go down here let's do this at the
bottom
all right let's just copy uh copy this
all past two dot set type
let's put this at the bottom
all right we're gonna call this
inv ab2
and invap1
go to prepare to play
and prepare them as well as the buffer
let's just copy this
paste paste
inv
all right and let's prepare the buffer
in ap buffer
dot set size
spec.num channels samples per block
let's filter and invert some audio next
go to process block
all right we're going to do this after
we do our initial set of copying first
we will copy the input buffer into the
buffer that we will be processing in ap
buffer equals buffer
next we'll set the first inverted all
pass filter to have the same cutoff as
lp1 and hp1
then we will set the second all pass
filter to have the same cutoff as the
second stage
now we need to make our block and
context to filter our all pass buffer
with our filters
i'm just going to
copy this
and duplicate that let me do that
after we process this guy i'll put that
right here
this is in ap block
and we will use
in ap buffer
and then here's
in ap context
ctx
and this is fed by end ap block
all right now we just need to process it
in ap
one dot process
apctx
and then in ap2 dot process
abctx
let's get rid of this bypass
functionality for just a moment
if the bypass button is not ticked let's
see let's comment this out let's talk
about what we're going to do
if the bypass button is not ticked we
will be hearing the audio running
through our three filters
if the bypass button is ticked we will
be hearing the sum of the three filter
bands added with the inverted all pass
filters that's what we're going to
implement next all right let's re-enable
this chunk right here
and then let's change the names so it
compiles this is
in ap buffer
and then that's it that's all we need to
do all right so we're always adding
these guys
um and if our bypass button is turned on
then we're adding the output of the
inverted all pass buffer after it's been
multiplied by negative one
okay
so clicking the bypass button should
produce silence when we test this out
here we go
all right let's press play
again if we click this button we should
get silence
all right and drag in the sliders
perfect
all right awesome so this wraps up the
theory side of things we can start
compressing our separate bands once we
remove this inverted all pass filter
stuff
all right let's remove the all pass
filter stuff the inverted all pass
filter stuff we're not going to be using
it anymore in this project we are done
with all of that so
let's head on over to pluginprocessor.h
and we can get rid of this inverted all
pass filter we can get rid of the buffer
we can
get rid of
the stuff in the
constructor stuff down here get rid of
these two guys
go to prepare to play basically
everywhere if we were to build this now
everywhere that we have errors is where
we need to comment this stuff out
okay we don't have these three anymore
so i'll get rid of those and then in a
process block
that's going to be right here
that's going to be here and right there
that's going to be all of this code
right here
actual block context and filtering
we don't need that let's turn this
bypassing back on
and then we can get rid of all of this
code that inverted the samples
you can get rid of this stuff right here
let's build and test
bypassing should not produce any audible
differences that's what we're aiming for
when we use the bypass button
versus if we
drag the sliders and whatnot all right
let's try it out
no phasing
no audible difference here either
awesome
all right
we can check off the first item in our
dsp roadmap
figure out how to split audio into three
bands
done
cool
let's make a commit of that
figured out how to split audio into
three bands
here's our buffers and whatnot
fill the graph yes all right here's
where we set our types
here's where we prepared our filtering
here's where we set our cutoffs here's
where we did our processing
um and then this is just here's our
parameter and then this is just where we
are adding our third filter band
all right
awesome
let's create audio parameters for the
compressors that we will be adding we
can also remove two other items from the
roadmap since we completed them as well
goodbye number two
and goodbye number three all right so we
are on number four now all right let's
head over to create parameter layout in
pluginprocessor.cpp
all right we already created param names
for these extra compressors so we just
need to create the parameters for it
since they all are going to have the
same settings and range of settings we
can literally just duplicate most of
this code that creates the current set
and just change the names
so let's copy let's do the threshold
first copy this paste it twice
and then hold down
option shift
to select multiple lines and then change
this to mid
same thing for this one here change that
to high done
couldn't be easier
let's do the attack param
select this
paste paste
option
drag
mid option drag
high
boom
okay let's do the release param
copy this
and option drag mid
option drag
hi
perfect
all right let's do the ratio parameter
next
copy paste paste
option drag
mid
option drag
hi
and then the bypass parameter is next
option drag
mid
option drag hi
all right cool let's run it
all right look at all the parameters
that we have
access to now
all right that was super easy all right
let's close this
now in project 12 i teach a much more
optimized solution for creating the
parameters and looking them up versus
using this params get paramed
dot at thing that we're using here all
right let's go on to the next item in
the road map
since we are up here let's see
we're done with this done
so now we need to reinstate our
compressors and add two new ones let's
do that next
let's go to pluginprocessor.h
we'll go down to where we are declaring
everything go to our private member
variable section the first thing i'm
going to do is create an array of
compressor band instances and then i'm
going to create aliases to each one
now the reason is so that i want to have
the option to be able to loop through
and i also want to have the option of
being able to target each one
individually without having to use array
indexing so check that out let's do std
array
compressor band
three
there's my compressors we're going to
change this to be plural and now we're
going to do compressor
let's see i'm going to do this on three
lines so
let me write this three times
compressor band
band comp uh let's see capital b
band comp
equals compressors
like that all right let's just fill it
in
all right first this is going to be
the low band this is going to be the
mid band and this is going to be the
high band
this will be the first one this will be
the second one and this will be the
third one
boom that was easy
all right now we need to initialize all
of the parameters
for all of our compressors so go to
pluginprocessor.cpp go to the
constructor
all right i'm going to rename the very
first one
and then i can just copy and paste the
three lines
to initialize the other two compressors
all right so let's rename this right
here
this is gonna be low band comp
like that now i can copy and paste it
and rename accordingly
all right i'll change this
mid band
and then this one is
high
band all right do the same thing for the
bypass
and the ratio
so first rename this
low band comp ratio
and then copy and
paste this two times
and this is the mid band
and the high band
um oh you know what i forgot to do all
of these need to be um let's see this is
low so these need to be
let's get let's line these up
that could have been problematic
let's see
um all right go to the end
arrow over one two three
mid
same thing here
high like that awesome okay do the same
thing here this needs to be mid with a
capital m
and then
high with a capital h
it could have been a disaster all right
let's do this let's see this is low band
comp bypassed
copy and paste this
and let's see this needs to be low
this is mid
this is
high
all right and then this is going to be
the mid band
and this will be the
high band
perfect all right the compressor
parameters are initialized now we can
prepare our compressors all right so
when you're doing this step be very
careful to make sure you're initializing
the low band compressor with the low
band parameters
all right
you know mid band with mid params high
band with high params okay just be
careful be very careful when you're
doing this on your side
go to prepare to play
all right remember what i had said about
the ability to loop through these we can
just do four
auto comp
compressors
comp
boom done onward to process block
first we need to update
all of the compressors settings again
looping for the win for auto compressor
compressors
let's turn that on
now we can't actually compress any audio
until after it has been filtered so we
need to move this line this compressor
dot process
until after all of the filtering has
been completed
so let's go do that
all right that happens down here
okay now one of the important things to
note was that filter buffers zero
this guy right here
this holds the low pass audio and that
same index zero
is the same index of the compressor that
is set up for low band processing
so isn't that convenient
that means that it makes it really easy
for us to run the correct buffer through
the correct compressor so it would be a
problem if it wasn't done this way
imagine if we had to remember that
filter buffers2 was
the
buffer to use for compressor zero all
right anyway it's very easy to do this
we just need to use an index based loop
instead of a range based loop
for size t
i zero i is less than filter buffers dot
size
plus plus i
now we can do compressors
i dot process
filter buffers
i
wasn't that easy
how simple is that
all right
let's get rid of this uh bypass stuff
let's clean this stuff up too we don't
need that
all right
let's get rid of this bypass stuff we
can delete it for good
and
uh that's it all right we can get rid of
this stuff as well
all right let's test it out
our compressors should be able to be
tested separately so grab your
headphones and
mess around with it
here we go
let's put this on screen so we can see
more of the parameters and let's um
let's see let's make the output of our
compressor feed project 12 so we can
actually see
the result
let's just turn off all processing first
okay if uh we're gonna run some audio
and then we're going to um
you know adjust and
adjust each individual band and just
kind of mess with them all right so we
got our low band we're going to hear the
way this is set up now we're not going
to hear a lot of low band
you can really see this as we clamp it
down we can see that a lot of the low
band is gone
let's go down here let's
see that that low end is
really chopped
[Music]
and then we turn it back we bypass it we
can see that
uh that happened all right let's let's
uh chomp down the mid band
[Music]
wow it's really getting chopped
all right let's adjust our mid band so
it's tighter
and let's change that ratio
[Music]
you can see this dip that's happening
right here
uh between 1k between as we show here
761 and 2300
it's kind of a dip right here between
1k and 2k let's change this to be
closer to
300s that's right around where this line
is you can see this dip right here so if
i bypass the mid band
see a little bit of a boost here
change this ratio to be like really
dramatic
and really slam it
all right we can see a big dip right
there okay all right so that's a pretty
good test
next let's add the ability to solo and
mute the individual compressors because
that's a very cool feature
let's save this
and quit this
let's um make a commit
let's see what did we do we um
reinstated
all three compressors
all right here's where we did that
and fill the graph
and here's where we set up our
parameters
here's where we set up our ratio param
our bypass param here's where we
prepared them here's where we did our
settings updating here's where we
actually processed audio
and we got rid of some code there here's
where we created our params params
params params params
good times commit all right solo bypass
mute next
let's check off road map item number
five
add two remaining compressors done
number six add the ability to mute solo
bypass individual compressors
all right we can already bypass an
individual band
we just need to be able to solo and mute
them so let's duplicate
the bypass enum entries and rename them
go to the params
copy this
paste paste
and we just need to rename so
option shift
mute
and sorry not shift just option drag to
select and then
solo
i don't know if that's a thing on
windows but on mac it is in xcode it's
very handy
all right we just need to add them to
our map
below let's go down here again copy
paste rename
one two
let's get that back on screen
all right first things first this is um
let's see we'll do mute first
copy paste copy paste copy paste all
right and then solo will be the second
set
solo
solo
copy paste paste
alright awesome
now we need to add solo and mute
parameters to our compressor
let's go to the compressor band and
declare two more boolean audio
parameters named mute and solo so
duplicate this copy paste paste
it says mute
and this is solo
now these aren't going to be used in the
compressor class at all they will be
used in process block
we still need to create the parameters
in parameter layout before we can
initialize them in the constructor so
let's do that next head over to
pluginprocessor.cpp
and create parameter layout
all right go to the bypass parameter
where is that that's down here at the
end
all right
copy paste rename do this for mute and
solo
all right
change this to be
the mute
and mute
again option drag
mute and then we'll do solo here at the
end
solo
whoops
solo
solo
all right awesome let's go initialize
the parameters and our compressors next
go to the constructor
all right copy and paste the boolean
helper code for the bypassed param
and then rename accordingly
whoops let me add extra line okay this
should be
mute let's do all three of these
and let's see
i can't because their line lengths are
different
i can copy and paste
this is solo
copy and paste all right now for these i
can do it
at the end so this is
all right no because high is too long
all right gotta do them individually all
right this is mute
and then
uh solo
and solo okay excellent all right let's
go solo or mute our separate bands next
in
process block
all right this happens after buffer dot
clear
right here okay the logic is
surprisingly simple if any of the bands
are soloed we copy only the solo band's
buffer to the output
otherwise if a band is not muted we copy
that band's buffer to the output so
first we need to figure out if any band
is soloed this is pretty easy to do
we start with a boolean flag
and then we loop through the compressors
and just check their solo param if it's
true then we have at least one band that
is soloed and we stop checking once we
have at least one
that looks like this
again we start with a flag we loop
through every compressor if the solo
parameter is true
then we have at least one that is soloed
so we don't need to check anymore
let's comment out the old way of looping
of adding the filters
all right now we just need to check if
bands are soloed or not all right if
bands are soloed
else
if any of the bands are soloed copy only
the solo band's buffer to the output now
we cannot use a range-based loop here
because our filter buffers don't live
with compressors so we have to use an
indexed loop instead but that's okay
that's easy to use for
size t
i equals
zero i is less than compressors dot size
plus plus i
again uh let's get a compressor auto
comp equals compressors
if
comp dot solo
if it's soloed
then add filter band
add the buffer and this one we want
filter bands
uh filter buffers we want if index i
apostrophe th all right cool that's very
simple to understand
all right again if a band is soloed loop
through all of the bands and if a band's
solo parameter is on
then we add the associated
filter buffer that that particular band
is using
all right let's implement
what happens when nothing is soloed next
go to the else block if nothing is
soloed then copy only the buffers that
are not muted
let's use the same loop again
and we need this uh compressor part as
well
oops
all right
if comp dot mute
get
all right
if it is not muted it's very important
to include that exclamation part
if it is not muted
then we can add
that filter band
okay that's it that is solo mute and
bypass let's test it out let's mess with
the solo buttons and the mute buttons
grab your headphones
all right here we go
all right this is bypass
let's mute let's solo the mid band
all right we can adjust this
just this range
we can see how we we can make this mid
band really narrow
like that
all right and we can bypass it as well
so we can see what our mid band actually
is like and what it actually sounds like
what that means is that we can go up
here and dial in
all this stuff like say i want
real slow attack time
i want to let all of that you know snare
information through
i don't want that to get clamped down
so i can adjust all that stuff
it's just ratio
all right let me stop
you stop soloing it
you know it's funny about that i was
adjusting all those parameters
and it was bypassed so i wasn't even
hearing it
so that's a whole that's a whole thing
like you shouldn't be able to adjust
these sliders
um if it's bypassed
but that's something we implement later
all right so we can mess with this mid
band
see what it actually sounds like and use
the bypass to um
[Music]
uh you know adjust this stuff let's
change this ratio so it's real dramatic
[Music]
here there's a lot of information that's
being uh
is it in the high band
well the high band is real wide
all right so we can dial in a lot of the
snare stuff that's going on here anyway
that's solo mute and bypass
actually
mute the mid band we can see it gets
dipped out there let's mute the high
band
stuff gets kind of dull if you need the
low band it'll sound like a telephone
and we can like you know tweak all this
stuff early
okay
all right
that is solo and mute and bypass
of three separate bands with our
filtering so we can check another item
off of our roadmap let's solo this i'm
not solo let's save this quit
go to our roadmap turn off the ability
to
uh let's mark it as done that's awesome
and then uh let's see we're gonna add
input and output gain to compensate for
level changes and then we're gonna clean
it up and that will be the dsp side of
things
let's make a commit
all right
added
mute solo
functionality
and bypass
bypass functionality
all right here's where we set up the uh
mute and solo params here's where we
implemented the actual dsp
here's where we created the params
uh marked it off list here's our enum
here's our param names
and here's our parameters
on the compressor band
excellent done all right
input and output gain next and then
clean up and that will conclude the dsp
side of this plug-in
awesome
all right now it is time to add input
and output gain because compressors
lower the output level of the signal the
input gain is mainly if the incoming
signal is not high enough or if it's too
high and we need to turn it down
first we need to add some entries in our
enumeration that will point to the
parameter names let's put these at the
bottom
next we need to add two entries so copy
these
stick these at the bottom
number four all right we need to declare
some gain processors and cached
parameters go to plugin
pluginprocessor.h
way down at the bottom
where we are declaring all of our stuff
let's put this after our filter buffers
uh let's see juice
dsp
gain float we got input gain output gain
all right then we need two parameters
these are going to be audio parameter
float as well
okay
we need to create some actual parameters
that represent our input and output gain
so let's go to plug-in
pluginprocessor.cpp create parameter
layout so we're going to put these at
the top
so i'm going to define a range of
negative 24 to plus 24 with a step size
of 0.5 this means we can boost or cut
our incoming signal with a range of
uh not in with a range but with steps of
like 0.5 such as you know 1.5 db of gain
2 db again 2.5 db of gain same will go
for the output gain levels all right so
let's define that first auto gain range
equals
juice
normalizable range actually i didn't
need to type juice just type
normalizable range
range start is negative 24.f whoops
that's float in the wrong place holder
here we go range start negative 24.f
range end positive 24
interval value 0.5 f and our skew will
be one
okay that's our gain range now we can
define our parameter
all right let's just copy this
paste paste
let's change this name to be gain in
and we'll change this to use our gain
range
all right
and let's just duplicate this
copy paste replace that right now this
can be gained out
all right now that we have created the
parameters we need to initialize our
cached parameters in the constructor
all right let's uh
let's do this after our
crossovers where's that that's right
here
okay float helper
input gain param
as with every other dsp processor we
need to prepare our gain processors
before we can use them let's go to
prepare to play
all right we also need to specify the
ramp duration for these processors now
this function
the ramp duration it controls how long
it takes to transition from one gain
level to another
whenever the gain level is changed so
anything quicker than 5 or 10
milliseconds is pretty audible and it
sounds it produces like clicks and pops
so i'm gonna go with 50 milliseconds
we'll go input gain
gain dot prepare
what do you want srb come say hi to
everybody oh
yes everybody say hi
to srabby she's very whiny can you whine
you gonna wind everybody all right down
you go
spec
all right output gain dot prepare spec
let's set those ramp times input gain
dot
set ramp duration in seconds 0.05
because there's a thousand
milliseconds in one second so 0.5
seconds is 50 milliseconds all right do
the same thing for the output
copy paste
copy paste okay now that this is all set
up let us start processing our audio
with our gain processors
all right um let's see go to process
block
and before we start applying gain to our
input buffer we need to update our
processors with the most recent gain
parameter values so input gain
dot set gain in decibels because we're
storing our parameter in decimals input
gain program
get
do the same for the output all right we
must apply input gain b4 processing
audio through the bands so i'm going to
call an imaginary function that i
haven't written yet that applies the
gain
and then we'll implement that imaginary
function next
but first we'll do that here
and call apply gain
buffer and our input gain
i'm doing this because i'm going to be
applying gain
i just don't want to have to write the
code that actually applies the gain
twice let's implement this imaginary
function next head over to the header
file plug in processor.h down at the
bottom
all right i'm going to declare a helper
function that will apply the gain
we are very familiar with creating the
context for a particular buffer so i'm
trying to type in that code so i'm going
to write this helper function and i'm
going to use templates because i'm too
lazy to figure out the type that each of
the arguments should have
so you know why should i have to think
about that stuff when the compiler can
figure it out for me you know all right
so here we go template type name t
type name u
void apply
gain
passing in
a buffer
and passing in
again
all right let's make our block auto
block equals juice dsp
audio block
float
out of the buffer make it out of the
buffer let's make our context auto ct x
equals juice dsp
process context replacing float this is
out of the block and then we can do gain
dot process ctx
all right head back over to process
block so we can apply output gain next
all right now finally we apply output
gain after processing all of the audio
that way at the end
after all of this stuff
apply
gain
buffer
output gain
all right cool let's test this out the
gain sliders should change the volume
headphones
all right cool gaining at the top gain
out at the top as well let's mess with
this we'll adjust our levels let's just
bypass um
let's bypass our compression for right
now
turn down the input
that works as expected
all right cool that is awesome that
works as expected all right so here's an
interesting test
um let's turn down the input gain to
like negative 12
negative 12 and then let's turn up the
output
to positive 12.
all right let's run some audio through
it
[Music]
all right now if we toggle the bypass of
plug-in
oh wait hold on i need to un-bypass this
stuff
[Music]
okay
oh let's see
[Music]
all right if we bypass this
the audio will sound the same okay so
you would think that we would hear some
type of compression especially if the
compressors have a pretty low threshold
prior to modifying the input and up
again
but
when we do this we don't actually hear
any compression
all right so the reason is because we
turned down the input gain level which
means the low threshold that we had and
the compressors is no longer low
relative to the signal level
so we need to lower these thresholds by
12 db in order for them to actually do
anything
right so for example if let's see um
i'm gonna do it to just the low band for
now
turn the mid band back up
okay i'm going to set this to negative
20.
all right all right let me just solo
this real quick
oh look at me tweaking stuff all right
here's our solo low band
all right now because this is applying
negative 12 to the input
um
our signal may not be hot enough to
actually trick to actually trip the
compressor so what we need to do is
lower this by 12.
so put this to 32.
there we go now we now we're starting to
hear it smash
you can hear it on the base boom boom
boom boom boom
[Music]
[Music]
open that up a bit
if we bypass
[Music]
okay
all right
so that's the interesting test do that
now it'll really be it'll be really big
it will really compress it and if we put
this back 20 negative 20
we'll hear the same results that we
heard a moment ago
okay
okay so that marks another item on our
dsp roadmap let's save and quit this
let's go up to our roadmap uh where's
that plugin processor.h way at the top
add input and output gain
done
okay so now the next thing to do is to
clean this up let's do that next
okay uh head on over to create pro
create parameter layout all of these
thresholds use the same um normalizable
range so let's dri that dry that auto
threshold range equals this thing
cut
paste semicolon
replace
the next thing to do is to move all of
the code that updates the dsp processors
into a function
process block always operates in this
order let's go to processblock see let's
actually just see what i'm talking about
processblock always operates in this
order first thing we do is update dsp
processors with the latest parameter
values and then we process the audio so
again dsp processing is entirely
state-based
and the parameters represent the state
so we update the stuff that does all the
math with the latest dsp state before
any math
computations are actually performed so
i'm going to call an imaginary function
first i'm going to call that right here
update state
and then we just need to move all of
this code that happens here all of this
stuff
she need to move that to that function
okay so let's do that next
first we go declare it plug in
processor.h way down at the bottom
void update state
now we can go implement it i'm going to
put this right above a plug-in i'm going
to put it right above process block put
that right here
simple mb comp audio processor
update state
let's update our compressor settings
all right we need to update the uh
filters let's grab all this stuff
and then we need to update the gain
processors let's grab these as well
let's clean this up as well
get rid of that stuff
and get rid of that
and get rid of that
all right cool and now process block is
much simpler
okay we update our state then we apply
our gain
the next thing that happens is we split
the audio into separate bands so let's
do the same thing we will
call another imaginary function
we'll call that right here split bands
and we'll pass our buffer to it let's go
declare it go to plug-in processor down
to the end
okay go back to plug-in processor
and let's just move the relevant code
again um above process block void simple
i mean comp audio processor
split bands
okay so this is where we make this copy
first
and we do our contexts and this needs to
say input buffer
we do our contexts and our processing
right cool so again we are making
process block just that much simpler and
easier to understand right we update our
state we apply our gain then we split
our bands and then we're doing
compression
all right now i'm just thinking out loud
here but because the apply gain function
is set up for a generic processor we
technically we could use it
i mean we could use it here for all of
these
but
there are five processors being used
which means that
we would be creating five blocks and
five contexts
and right now we're only creating three
blocks and three contacts so
i'm gonna stick with what we have
because it's um even though it would
simplify this function a lot
what we have now is um a light it is
less cpu intensive because it has less
objects being created
okay everything else that happens is
already pretty simple we do our
compression
um we do our
solo check then we do our
um
if it's soloed here's which buffers get
added otherwise these are the buffers
that get added
um let's clean that up so we could
refactor it but we're not going to
really gain anything here instead
single line comments can be used to
explain what is happening
in case it isn't readable what's going
on but in my opinion this is very
readable right we're clearing the buffer
we're figuring out if a band is soloed
and then we're
using whether or not a band is soloed to
add stuff to um our input buffer okay so
let's just run and test this to make
sure
and it should be all good but let's just
make sure
okay
[Music]
that still works
it still works
it still works
all right cool and
solo still works
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
sounds good to me
this concludes the
dsp portion of
this uh simple multi-band compressor um
in project 12 we tackle how to
dynamically change the number of bands
so you can have six bands two brands
three bands up to eight bands if you're
if you need that much
along with uh how to do a bunch of other
stuff like a draggable gui for adjusting
the crossovers and adjusting the
thresholds and whatnot
okay so we can move on to developing the
gui and making it as simple and as
intuitive to use because this
will never fly in front of the customers
customers will look at this and say
i don't know what i don't know how to
use this i don't know
yeah this is
i will not give you my hard-earned cash
if this is the gui that i'm working with
all right let's work on that next
good times save
quit
let's make a commit
added io gain cleaned up dsp
here's where we um let's see
checked out these things here's where we
added our input gain
uh strings
here's where we added helper functions
and parameters
here's where we set up our parameters
here's where we prepared our dsp
processors here's where we did some
cleanup
here's more cleanup here
more cleanup there
and more cleanup here
and here's where we added those
parameters let's see that goes there
here's where we added the parameters and
here's where we refactored um
the threshold parameter
okay
excellent onward to the gui
all right the dsp is done let's get rid
of the old road map
let's sketch out the road map for the
gui
all right first thing that we're going
to do is the global so let's add this in
here globe gui road map
all right number one
global controls
these are the x over
x over sliders and the gain sliders okay
these are going to go in the middle of
the display
input gain on the left output gain on
the right crossover controls in the
middle
okay next
we're going to have the main band
controls
these are going to be the attack release
threshold ratio sliders
all right these are going to go below
the global controls
and these controls will be assigned to
the mid band first
all right
next
we're going to add solo mute
bypass buttons
again these are going to be assigned to
the mid band first and these are going
to be on the right side of the main band
controls component
okay number four
band select functionality this is also
known as resettable parameter
attachments
this band selects functionality will
allow us to have one set of controls for
all of the bands
and it will also give us some buttons to
switch which band is currently being
controlled by the sliders and the solo
mute bypass buttons okay we will be
using the band controls so we will need
to have a mechanism to change which
parameter a control is assigned to
it's a pretty cool system to implement
um it's not not the simplest thing but
it's it's a very it's a very interesting
problem to solve
okay next five band select buttons
reflect the solo mute bypass state when
we switch the bands now this is to give
us some visual feedback when we click
any of these
you know low band mid band high band
buttons okay we also need to implement
the logic that
prevents you from having both uh the
mute button and the solo button set at
the same time for example because it
doesn't make sense to be able to
be muted and soloed at the same time all
right so we're going to deal with that
all right next number six
custom look and feel for the rotary
sliders and the toggle buttons all right
so custom
look
and feel
for sliders and toggle buttons we will
be modifying the look and feel that we
developed from the simple eq tutorial so
if you don't have
um if you did if you didn't do simple eq
um you know pause right now and go
through that and then come back here so
that way you have those files i will
also be including links to
the simple eq repository so if you don't
want to go through it you can just
copy that code and um
you know paste what you need you know
copy the parts you need and paste it
into this project let's see number seven
spectrum analyzer overview
spectrum
analyzer overview
okay the spectrum analyzer in this
project is slightly different than the
one in simple eq so i'm going to go into
detail about what is actually different
number eight
data
structures
for spectrum
analyzer all right we're going to grab
these from the simple eq tutorial
and then we're going to you know modify
them at some point number nine
we're going to
let's see what are we doing here we are
going to do fifo usage in
uh plugin processor
process block
oh i got weird capitalization going on
number ten
uh well sorry before we do that okay so
for the fifo usage
in process block um we need to do a
little bit of dsp modification to make
this happen correctly
all right and then let's see number 10
is okay implementation of the analyzer
rendering pre-computed paths again this
is going to be taken from simple eq the
simple eq analyzer took a decent chunk
of time to develop in that course so
there's nothing gained if i duplicate
that same chunk of video
in this video other than to make this
video an hour and a half longer so
i'm not going to do that i'm going to
include links to the relevant code and
we will be copying what we need and
reusing it
okay number 11
drawing crossovers on top of the
analyzer plot okay this is where we're
going to customize the spectrum analyzer
number 12 okay drawing gain reduction on
top of the analyzer drawing gain
reduction
on top of the analyzer
again this is the final customization
and we will need to write a little bit
of dsp code to make this happen so we
will be doing a little bit of work in
plug-in processor
and then let's see the last one uh let's
see analyze or bypass analyze the bypass
um we're going to use the same code that
we used from simple eq
and then number 14.
let's see we have a global bypass button
global bypass
button all right and this is just
something that every plug-in should have
because
um it's it just makes it really easy to
compare
what your plug-in is doing with um if
it's not processing anything
okay that is wrapping up the gui we have
our roadmap so let's start coding up the
very first item
global controls
if you get stuck or run into trouble
while coding this or simple eq just grab
one of my free products from
programming4musicians.com
and you can message me directly in the
slack workspace and i will help you
directly now that we are tackling the
editor we can disable the generic editor
and use our customized editor plugin
processor.cpp
create editor
comment out this line
and
there we go
all right we want to return our
customized editor
go to plugineditor.h
alright the first thing we are going to
do in the roadmap is tackle the global
controls
i'm not sure what size i want
my different gui components to have
right now so i'm going to use
placeholder components that will show me
the sizes i've set
these are going to be empty components
that only draw a single color so the
good thing about this approach is that
once i've dialed in the placeholder
positioning
when i finish developing the real
component the screen position is already
locked in and i won't have to mess
around with the positioning
of the component itself
let's declare a placeholder component
we'll put this here at the top
this component is going to draw a single
color
and that single color is going to be
defined when the component is
constructed
and this compo this color is going to be
randomly generated but it will never
change once it's configured so here we
go struct
placeholder
let's define our paint function first
and we're going to fill the whole thing
with this custom color
and then the next thing we will do after
this is to declare our custom color now
that we have used it
okay let's declare our custom color next
and we will initialize it in the
constructor next
first we need to declare a constructor
and because the autocomplete is not
responding as quickly as i would like in
this header file
i'm going to define this constructor in
the cpp file so let's go over to plugin
editor dot cpp next all right let's put
this at the top
all right let's start
place holder
i'm going to use the juice random class
to generate some integers that will
populate the rgb values of our custom
color
okay cool
let's give ourselves some placeholder
components and position them on the
screen next
head over to the editor class
declaration and add some placeholders
plug in editor.h
down here at the bottom
the editor will be split into four
sections
at the very top will feature the
analyzer bypass buttons and the global
band bypass button
below that will be the spectrum analyzer
with the part that shows the threshold
as well as the gain reduction then below
that are the global controls and then
finally we will have the actual
compressor band controls at the bottom
so let's declare four instances of the
placeholder and give them appropriate
names
all right let's add these to our display
in our editor's constructor so head on
over to plugin editor.cpp next
we need to add and make our child
components visible if we want to be able
to see them
let's give ourselves a little bit more
room and make our editor a little bit
wider and a fair bit taller i'm going to
go with 600 by 500.
all right let's go to resized
for the control bar at the top i want to
have the analyzer power button on the
left and the compressor
global bypass button on the right so i'm
going to make these sit within a
bounding box that is
32 units tall so first let me get the
local bounce
and now i can get a 32 pixel tall
rectangle that will form the bounds of
our control bar by calling the rectangle
remove from top function
this member function will remove a chunk
from the top of the rectangle and give
us that chunk that was removed as a
separate rectangle so i'm going to use
that here to give the control bar a
bounds that is 32 pixels tall
and the same width as our editor and is
positioned at the top of the screen
next let's position the actual
compressor band controls at the bottom
of the screen and i think i need
something between 130 and 140
units in terms of height so let me try
135 first and just like remove from top
i am going to use the
rectangle remove from bottom function
here which behaves just like the remove
from top except the chunk is taken from
the bottom of the rectangle
let's dial in the analyzer bounds next i
know i want this to be taller than the
band controls and the global controls in
the center
so let me choose something between 200
and 250 all right let's go right down
the middle and use 225 and remove that
from the top of the bounding box again
we're just removing chunks from the get
local bounce rectangle and using those
chunks as the bounding boxes for our
child components
okay we removed a small sliver from the
top which was for the control bar then
we removed the chunk from the bottom
for the actual compressor band controls
and then we removed a large chunk from
the analyzer and that leaves us with a
rectangle that will be used for the
actual global controls
let's run and test this i'm going to
switch to the standalone editor
and we can find we can fine tune these
values
after we see what it looks like this
very first time
all right this looks okay to me this is
um this rectangle right here is going to
be the control bar at the top
uh this is going to be the band controls
here's our global controls in the middle
and then this rectangle right here
this is the analyzer okay i'm happy with
these placements we have created
placeholders
for the main parts of this gui so now we
can dial in custom components for the
global controls
let's make a quick commit
added placeholder components
also added gui road map
all right here's our road map
the graph here's where we change to the
custom editor
here's our placeholder and the usage
and here's our placeholder constructor
adding all of our child components and
positioning them
all right let's declare a global control
component plugin editor.h let's put this
after the placeholder i'm going to start
dialing in the graphics before i add
sliders to it and the reason is because
i want to reuse the sliders that were
used in simple eq and migrating those
files over to this project
will require a bit of code surgery and i
want to do this simple task first so
let's declare the class first
and we just need to add a paint function
for now
okay now we can replace our placeholder
with an instance of this global controls
let's flush out the paint function this
one that we've got right here head to
the cpp file let's put this after our
placeholder paint function
let's put this after our placeholder
constructor
okay let's flush this out i want to draw
a border around the component but i also
want to have a gap between this
component and the others so i'm going to
use the draw order to handle this since
i don't want to have to mess with the
component bounds again in the editor's
resize function so the first things
first let's fill the component with our
border color
i'm going to be using the juice
namespace in here a lot so let me just
do the using namespace trick
we're going to fill our component bounds
let's get them first all right and i'm
going to use a blue violet color for
right now
next let's reduce our bounding box a
little bit and fill a rounded rectangle
with all black
there we go we reduced we set the color
to black and then we filled a rounded
rectangle let's take a look at this just
run it
quick let's see what this looks like
it's kind of hard to tell because this
is
a similar color
okay to make this easier let's hide some
of our placeholders go to plugin
editor.cpp go to the
editor constructor and let's just see
the
global controls comment out the control
bar the analyzer and the band controls
all right let's run it again all right
let's get rid of this and we'll fill it
with all black
go down to this paint function
so we will comment all of this out and
do g dot fill all fill it with all black
now let's run it again
okay great let's add this little gap
that i was talking about next i wanted
to have a little bit of a gap between
each of these widgets and go back to
global controls paint
okay so i want to draw a black border
around the entire bounds of this
component and since i'm reducing bounds
here i need to make a copy of this
before i reduce it
i need to do this before i do the
reduction right now i can reduce like
i'm doing here
now i can draw this black border so i
will give myself a small gap between
this component and the surrounding ones
without messing with the resized
function now for what it's worth i could
have accomplished a similar result if i
do g dot draw rect
i could have achieved a similar result
by using the juice path and adding a
rounded rectangle to it and then calling
g dot stroke path but that would have
given me rounded corners on the outside
in addition to the inside so this way i
end up with a square
i end up with square outer corners and
rounded inner corners and i like the way
this looks a little bit better
personally speaking
let's take a look
all right so you can see there's a
little bit of a gap between this and the
right edge of the component and
between the purple line and the left
edge i think this looks really clean you
know this nice little gap and there's
going to be a little bit of a gap
between each of the components
i want to use this border effect in the
compressor band controls and with the
spectrum analyzer but i'm going to wait
to refactor this paint stuff until it's
actually time for that the next step is
to grab the look and feel and rotary
sliders from simple eq and get our
global controls functioning so let's
just we'll close this for now and we'll
figure out how to do that stuff next
let's make a commit
added global control
graphics
okay
i want to reuse the rotary sliders from
simple eq in this project these sliders
depend on the custom look and feel class
that we developed in the simple eq
project and the easiest thing to do is
to copy the classes from that project
and just add them here now if you did
not complete simple eq
visit the repository linked below the
classes will be in the plugin editor dot
h and cpp
so we're going to copy the declarations
for the look and feel class and the
rotary slider
with labels class let's paste them above
our placeholder components so let's go
grab simple eq
we can grab it from here matcap music
simple eq we can go to our source plugin
editor.h
and we are looking for
look and feel
all right here's our look and feel so we
need the look and feel as well as the
rotary slider with labels class
this guy right here
and this guy right here copy these guys
and you can clone it if you want and
grab it that way um go to your plugin
editor and put it below no put it above
our placeholder components
okay now we need to grab the relevant
implementations draw rotary slider draw
toggle button all of this stuff
so go back to
the um
source on github
go to the cpp file plugin editor and we
are looking for the
look and feel draw rotary slider
the next look and feel class
and then rotary slider with labels paint
and any other rotary slider with label
functions all right there's a few of
them
plug-in editor.cpp let's put these at
the top
put those right there
i'm going to put this line between
myself and between these classes and the
placeholder just so i can tell them
apart
all right once it is pasted we have a
few error messages to deal with let's
find out where those are do a quick
build and it should show them to us
unknown type name power button
all right let's deal with these two type
errors
i want to have a global bypass button in
this project and i want to use the power
button graphics from simple eq for it
so the easy thing to do is to grab the
power button class from simple eq and
that is found in the
editor.h
so go back to the source code on github
or if you have the project grab it from
there plugin
h and look for power button
all right paste that grab the power
button
and paste that before the placeholder
before the placeholder after the rotary
slider with labels class plugin editor.h
after rotary slider with labels
before placeholder
what's the next error
analyzer button and i want to use that
same button that we used in simple eq to
toggle the spectrum analyzer on and off
so again just copy the code for this
class from the simple eq project and
we'll paste it after the power button
class so go over here
here it is right here right below power
button analyzer button
copy that and put this in plugin editor
after power button and before
placeholder
all right now try to build it
alright build succeeded so with these
errors out of the way we can now add our
global controls to the gui now
all right here is the plan for the
global controls
number one add generic juice sliders
and then
do some refactoring because i'm pretty
sure we're to reuse some code between
the paint function and the resize
function for determining the bounding
box our sliders will sit inside
then we will add parameter attachments
then we will replace the sliders with
our rotary slider with labels classes on
the heap and start using look and feel
then we're going to dial in the colors
for the sliders and the borders a bit
then we're going to add the range labels
to the sliders we're going to add a
title that's the plan okay so let's dive
in and add some generic sliders we're
going to need a constructor for adding
them as child component where's our
global controls class where is that
global controls okay down here all right
constructor first
we're going to need a resized function
for positioning them and then we will
need some private slider instances
we have our input gain slider our low
mid crossover slider our mid to high
crossover slider and then our output
gain slider all right let's head to the
cpp file next and then add them as child
components plugin editor.cpp let's go
after our
placeholder constructor
let's add some child components
all right let's position them
add a resized function after paint
i'm going to use flexbox for this so
first let's get our
bounding box then let's make a setup for
row positioning because we're arranging
these in a row i don't want to write
juice all over the place so i'm going to
use my using namespace juice let's move
this up
all right here we go flexbox all right
i've declared my flexbox it's going to
be a row flexbox and i don't want
anything to wrap around
now we just need to add every slider
with the same amount of flex
and then finally we just perform the
layout
all right let's see what we get let's
run this
okay those are not rotary sliders we
need to customize the type to be rotary
all right instead of doing this for
every single
slider
let's declare a rotary slider class and
make it inherit from slider and then
we'll just set it up so that way it is
it has the rotary style with no text box
all right let's do this after let's do
this right up here app right before our
global controls all right let's
initialize the base class
rotary slider inherits from juice slider
and it uses the rotary horizontal
vertical drag slider with no text box
let's change the type from juice slider
here to rotary slider
all right and let's test it out go ahead
and run it see what we get
all right much better okay let's add
attachments next and then we will
replace these with our
rotary slider with labels that we
created from simple eq
all right let's declare one attachment
per slider let's see where am i right
now global controls we're down here all
right i'm going to allocate these on the
heap so that way i can optimize a bit in
the constructor i will explain when we
get to that stage for now let's just
declare a unique pointer to the
attachment and create one attachment per
slider
okay one attachment per slider
now if we are using attachments
we need the ap vts to look up the
parameters so let's modify this
constructor
and let's change now how we initialize
our global controls
we need the audio processor
dot apbts
that's why we made that thing public
that's why it's a public member variable
way down here
all right
let's change our constructor plugin
editor.cpp go to the global controls go
up to this constructor choose ap
processor valley true state apv ts
okay now all of these attachments are
unique pointer which means we have to
call std make unique to create them now
the slider attachment constructor wants
three different parameters number one
the ap vts number two the parameter name
and number three
the slider to attach to the first thing
that we need is our parameter map so we
can look up the names
so let's do that before we start adding
these things as child components the
next thing that we will be writing a lot
is attachment equals make unique
attachment and then the three things and
that sure seems like an opportunity for
not repeating myself
by writing a free function now i'm too
lazy to look up the type names so i'm
going to use the templated function
instead and let the compiler figure out
the type names so let's head over to the
header file
we're going to write a function called
make attachment we're going to put this
after our rotary slider
it's going to go right here
okay let's start by writing a function
with no parameters now in the body we
will call the actual make unique call
using generic names in our parameter map
so let's do void make attachment
and here we're going to do attachment
equals std make unique it's going to be
an attachment
and let's see what do we say the first
argument that is needed is the apbts
second argument is the parameter name
which we get from our map
and then the third argument is the
slider itself
okay
now that we've got this we can dial in
the um parameter list and then we can
use template parameters for the five
variables that are used in this function
this is variable one two three four and
five and then there's this thing right
here
so the first argument is
the unique pointer itself std unique
pointer
of type attachment
all right next we have the parameter
name
let's see well i guess next is actually
the ap vts but
um we'll just do these in this order
yeah we'll do ap vts next ap vts
all right then we've got our parameters
map that's this thing here
so params
then we've got the name param name name
let's make those guys const and then
finally we've got our slider
slider type
slider
okay now we can just add um template
parameters for each of these templates
like that and now we can do type name
and attachment
type name apbts type name params
type
name
param name
and then type name slider type
okay great
so again what we did here to figure this
out was we just made an empty function
with no arguments we implemented what we
were going to call and then we said all
right what gets used let's add
parameters for all of that stuff that
gets used and then
let's just you know use template
parameters for that and then we can use
um the compiler
feature
template type name deduction
when we call this function we'll just
you know pass in all the stuff it needs
and the compiler will figure out all the
types and
it should all just work just like magic
with this helper function in place let's
go back to our cpp file
and now we can write a lambda that lets
us dry calling that make attachment
stuff with five parameters instead we
can just call it with three parameters
so that's dry for the win
all right here we go
auto make attachment helper equals
lambda lambda lambda
i always need to call make attachments
all right so we just need to pass in our
attachment
we need to pass in the uh let's see
we're going to be using the params so we
need to capture those let's capture
those by reference
we're going to capture the ap vts
and then everything else is
passed by
passed as constructor arguments okay so
here's our mpvts
here's our params
our program name is something we can
pass in here and we also need to pass in
our slido so let's do
auto attachment
this should be lower case
and then let's do um
const auto name and
let's see auto slider
alright so we can just do name
then slider
so this is a very similar idea to what
we did in
the constructor for the audio processor
or we made a lambda to
basically dry a bunch of
code that initialized parameters
okay next step is to call our attachment
helper for each of those three um each
of the attachments for the sliders so
make attachment
helper our first attachment is the in
gain slider attachment and for this we
want names gain in
and we're attaching this to the in gain
slider
all right let's do it again for the low
mid crossover
low mid attachment
names low mid crossover and then the low
mid
slider make attachment we're doing mid
high now mid high attachment
whoops not make attachment
attachment helper that's what we want
all right so mid high attachment
names mid high
and then the mid high slider
last one is the output slider make
attachment helper
this is the out gain attachment
names out gain and then name um let's
see this is the out gain slider
all right cool let's build and test
now if we run
and tweak some knobs then quit and
re-run the sliders should return
to the same position that we left them
in
all right so
this is input gain so i'm going to turn
this all the way down
and we will quit
and rerun
perfect all right
double click to reset
okay our compressors are not connected
to any gui controls but the input gain
and output gain parameters are so let's
switch to testing with the aph to make
sure the gain controls actually adjust
audio levels
which they should since you know we just
saw it be attached to the parameters but
there's nothing wrong with testing okay
switch to the vst audio plug-in host
and let's run this all right let's run
some audio
grab your headphones
turn down that input
[Music]
all right
perfect
okay we can switch these sliders out
with our rotary slider with labels next
so let's go over here let's make a quick
commit as well save quit
commit and we want to say that we added
not simply q we want to say that we
connected up
what do we do we have connected let's
see let's do two commits here so first
number one is added
lnf and
rotary slider with labels from simple eq
that's this stuff here
stage this stage this
and that's these guys
and then that's also this stuff here
here's our look and feel
that's the look and feel stuff
this is all rotary slider with labels
stage u okay cool so that's adding the
look and feel and rotary slider with
labels from simple eq
now what did we do next next we did
let's see we
added um
sliders to
global controls
and then we also wired up the
attachments
there's our global control
there's where we laid them all out with
flexbox
okay great
next let's connect them to the rotary
slider with labels
all right go to plugin editor.h
let's switch these sliders out the
rotary sliders
with our rotary slider with labels class
now this rswl class has constructor
parameters specifically and wants an
audio parameter first now we have this
parameter names map right here
in our constructor with the attachments
so i'm going to put these sliders on the
heap
and this is going to let this will allow
me to initialize them
inside this constructor so i can reuse
this map okay if i didn't do that then i
would have to use
this params
dot get params at
for each of these
sliders and that would be super annoying
it would also be really verbose okay so
that's why i'm not gonna do that so
let's put these on the heap
let's get rid of these guys right here
let's change this to be std unique
pointer
rswl
and do using r swl equals rotary slider
with labels
all right even though we're not using
this anymore i'm just going to leave it
leave it as is
okay let's build this real quick and
tackle some of these errors that are
going to appear
all right number one
these need to be dereferenced because
they are all a pointer so hold down
option drag to select all the lines and
add the star 2d reference let's do the
same thing in resized okay now we can
initialize these so let's do in gain
slider equals
std make unique
rs oh that's not going to show us the
full name so show me the full name
rotary slider with labels
all right
okay we can fill in our suffix before we
start dealing with our the thing that
gets the ranged audio parameter so let's
see for the uh in gain we want to use
decibels so we need to look up a
parameter from the ap vts so let's write
another helper function that's templated
that'll do that for us let's do the same
thing go over to the header file we'll
do the same thing that we did like we
did with make attachment we'll just do
it with um you know get the parameter so
we'll start by calling functions on the
objects that we haven't declared so
let's first get a function we'll just do
void
get param
like this and then what we need to do is
get our parameter from the apvcs using
our map autopram equals
apvts.getparameter
params.at
name or position we'll do name
this function returns a pointer so let's
make sure it's not null j assert param
is not null pointer
okay now the let's see what what does
this want here this wants a reference
let's dereference the parameter that we
looked up
so let's go return
param
okay this jsert right here will fire if
our parameter is not found but that
should never happen because we are using
our map
to provide the names and also to create
the parameters all right now we can
start filling in function parameters
we need our map we need our ap vts and
we need our name okay so let's do um
let's see
apv ts ap vts
we need our params so params params and
then our name so
name
name and this should be const reference
and this should also be cost reference
now we just need to template it template
type name apbts type name params type
name
name all right
now we can call it
plugineditor.cpp
all right and let's add a helper
function just like we did here
our make
our getparams function needs three
parameters and three of those parameters
are sorry two of those parameters
are the params map and our ap vts yeah
we can use a helper lambda to
make it so we only need to pass in the
name
so let's do that
auto get param helper equals lambda
lambda lambda
and let's grab our params and our ap vts
by reference and now we just need our
name const auto name we need to
explicitly specify that this thing is
going to return by reference so let's do
that
and now we can call our function
super simple all right cool now we can
fill in this placeholder with our lambda
get param helper
and here we want names
in gain
gain in and then finally we can replace
our alias
our rotary slider with labels with our
alias r s w l
cool that's clean
all right now we just need to initialize
these let's do the rest of them
in-game slider let's see there's the
in-game slider
all right this is going to be the low
mid crossover slider
this is the mid-high crossover slider
and this is the out gain slider
all right this was low mid
this was mid high
and this was
uh gain out and let's see this is in
hertz
and in hertz
let's build that
figure out if it's going to continue to
give us errors or not
oh you know what of course i forgot to
change this return type here void return
void
function get param should not return
value but it is returning a juice
ranged audio parameter reference
all right that's important i could have
bogged this up for a while all right
let's try it again
build that should solve all the errors
all right what's wrong with this one
here
oh you know what it's because these need
to be dereferenced because this is a
unique pointer now so to reference that
because it wants the actual object
like that all right
let's try building it again
voila magic all right let's run this
and see what we get all right awesome
those look nice and clean
they display the value good times
i'm very happy with that
okay the problem is that they are
smashed up to the top of this component
so let's dial in this positioning next
and we can also switch to using the
standalone
okay go to the resized function
now let's shrink our bounding box a
little bit just just enough i'm gonna go
with five dot reduced five
all right i want to add some spacers
between the sliders and also at either
end of the row so let's make some
instances of the
flex item class that will do that for us
all right spacers are going to go in
between the sliders and then end caps
will go on the very ends this is just to
kind of nudge everything in towards the
center of it
let's make the end cap a little bit
bigger
okay we need an end cap at the beginning
and the end of the items array and then
spacers in between each item
all right here's my end cap
and then a spacer between each item
let's test it out
all right cool so there's a bit more of
a gap here a bit more of a gap here and
then the gap in between is also a bit
it has made these a little bit smaller
and notice there's a little bit of a gap
at the top too which is great all right
let's tweak these colors next
all right actually i want to add labels
to the sliders next and i want to revise
how this was accomplished in simple eq
so let's take a quick look at what was
done in that project
so if i go to the simple eq constructor
um let's see
which class
i can go to any of these classes i'll
just look for dot labels okay
here we go in simple eq i was hard
coding these ranges
okay now what i would like to do is
actually extract them from the audio
parameter for this project
in this one i only care about the
minimum and the maximum value of the
parameter so let's write a helper
function that can populate the labels
array of our sliders and all we need to
do is just give it the parameter
for the range and the suffix so it's
time for some more template magic
let's declare a function and pass in our
labels the parameter and the suffix
and
um we'll get it's just it's going to
populate this labels array with the good
stuff from the parameter
let's go to our header file plugin
editor.h let's go after get param
now let's see we're going to modify the
labels object and
we're going to modify labels but
everything else can be const to
reference
all right the first thing we want to do
is
first declare this function void add
label pairs
labels this is what our labels are
all right everything else is constantly
we've got our
program
type param and then we have our suffix
type
okay so the first thing we want to do is
clear whatever labels are in the array
so labels.clear
all right so let's just add the first
thing labels dot add
um let's take a quick look at what was
done here all right it was a we used
curly brace because it's this position
object
we can take a look over here let's see
it's in the middle of this class
all right first object is position
second object is a string all right
labels.add
curly brace first object is a string no
first object is the percentage 0.f
the second object is
um the string okay
um and actually let's add some template
parameters for now
we just need three
let's just copy and paste this
and do labels
param type
suffix type
perfect
all right we know that we need to return
a string right here
so let's create a function called getval
string
and it's going to return juice string
get val string
okay we know we need to pull our value
to display from the parameter so let's
make that a function argument
one of these things
next we're going to only display the
minimum and maximum values so let's add
a boolean flag to the parameter list and
this flag will indicate if we should use
the low end of the parameter range or
the high end of the parameter range
bool
gets low
the thought behind this comes from where
we declared all of our parameters create
parameter layout
we always declared you know minimum the
range start and the range end and then
it was always
step size and skew
but
you know this is like the low end of the
range and this is the high end of the
range and that applied for every
normalizable range that we created
negative 60 positive 12
5 and 500
um was there any others no there's not
okay so that's where that comes from
all right plugin editor dot h that's
where this get low flag is coming from
the idea behind that okay
finally we need to append our suffix
so let's make that be the last function
parameter
now if this was a templated function we
could define it here but we know all the
types so let's
just declare it here and define it in
the cpv file
top
uh well we'll define it in just a second
let's use it first though
all right go down here and then replace
this quoted stuff with a call to it
getval string
all right now we can pass an hour param
we can pass in our suffix yes we want to
do true because we want the low
parameter at the zero percent
and then we can repeat for the 100
position
one dot f
and this should be
false we do not want the low
we do not want the low param
we want the um
yeah we want the end per value
okay
let's go implement this get val string
next go to plugin editor.cpp
way up at the top let's put this up here
all right
juice string
get val string
are you going to auto complete for me no
all right let's copy it over from the
header file
copy
paste remove that semicolon add curly
braces all right we need our string
juice string str
let's return it next return str
all right let's get our parameters
minimum and maximum value
from the parameters range autoval equals
get low
param dot get normalizable range
dot start
or param dot get normalizable range
end
okay that's part of the puzzle let's add
our suffix str
suffix now something that i really liked
from the
rotary slider with labels class was that
um the k the gods appended to
the little the letter k that is appended
um to the suffix whenever a parameters
value was 1000 or higher so let's
refactor that into a function that we
can use here and in rotary slider with
labels and in look and feel
all right so i'm gonna let's see where
does that happen
let's take a look at that logic real
quick
that's right here if the value is over
999
divided by a thousand and then we're
going to add the k
and then it's like
if we have to add k then um
we just stick a key on there before we
add this suffix
very simple all right so i'm going to
just add a function at the top i'm going
to call it
truncate kilo value
let's see um let's do void for right now
truncate
kilo
kilo jeez louise
value
and let's i'm not sure what type i'm
going to use so i'm going to do that
let's template this
i'm declaring it here in the cpp file
because this is the only place that will
get used currently
all right here's the logic if the value
is over 9.99
divided by 1 000. okay we're passing in
by reference because we're going to
actually modify this thing
and then let's see if we did perform a
truncation let's return true
and if we didn't let's return false so
if value is greater than
999 let's cast this 999 to whatever type
t is all right if it's over 9.99
value
equals static cast
t
1 000
return true
return false
all right so if it's over
9.99
divided by a thousand
and return true meaning yes we did
perform a truncation
all right let's go use it
all right so we can do bool use
k equals truncate
truncate
kilo value kilo value
value
all right
and then um
let's see don't forget this function is
going to modify this if we used if it
performs truncation
so we can add our string now str
val
if we should use kilos append it as well
if
use k
str
the letter k
we can make use of this in that get
display string function
over here get display string it's a
float param
now just looking at the rest of this
function here
we could probably revise it to use our
get valve string function too but that's
not something that i want to do i just
want to replace
this
with our code so i'm just going to
comment this out
and do
add k equals truncate
kilo value all right a little bit of a
code surgery
all right um let's see let's go back to
where we are creating our
sliders because once we once we've made
our let's go back to where we are making
our attachments
it's under global controls constructor
because after we make our attachments
we're going to
add our labels but let's do a quick
build to make sure we don't have any
template errors first make sure our
truncate function works
all right cool
all right let's use our helper function
let's do this right here
add label pairs so the first label is
going to be the
let's see i'm going to do the in gain
slider
labels
and the param is going to be get param
helper
let's see names
in
and the suffix type is going to be
decibels
right let's do it for the next one
let's put these on there online
add label pairs let's see we got the low
mid
crossover slider labels
pram is get param helper
names low mid
this is hertz
again
add label pairs
mid high
get program helper
names
mid high
also hurts
all right last one is the output gain
slider add label pairs
out gain slider labels
get program helper
names output gain
whoops
put that on the next line and decibels
okay let's run this
and we should see some labels next to
our sliders
let's see what we got oh build failed
what happened no matching call forget
val string
what did i do wrong oh
my get param helper let's see
what's the problem candidate function
you want a reference parameter what is
being passed
i'm passing a const reference oh that's
why this should be const
and that's because
that's because it's const right here
okay
am i going to run into a bunch of const
issues
let's see undefined symbol yes because i
made one const and the other not
constant okay this needs to be const up
here
get val string this should be const
build completed build succeeded boom all
right we've got our labels negative 24
positive 24 20 hertz to 989 one
kilohertz to 20 kilohertz perfect
and this shows 1k
awesome that's fantastic all right cool
let's commit that
very happy with that
make our commit
let's see added
label pairs two sliders is that what we
did
um oh no we did uh switched to
rswl
and added label pairs to sliders perfect
all right that was a lot
it's not a lot of code here in this
commit
but in terms of like what we actually
implemented that's a lot of
functionality
okay
okay let's look at this constructor real
quick we are calling get pram helper
twice we're doing it right here when we
make our slider
and then we're doing it here again when
we make our label pairs so let's fix
that let's cache our parameters here and
then replace accordingly that right here
so auto gain in param
equals
okay
let's replace accordingly
all right and these ones down here
all right cool let's build and test to
make sure everything is cool
all right i'm gonna change that to
negative six brings you to negative six
quit rerun
all right awesome
that works as expected
all right let's add titles to our
sliders so we're gonna add a third
constructor parameter and give it a
value of no title
so let's go up to our
rotary slider with labels class plug an
editor get rid of this build target
thing
plugin editor go to the
ranged no not range rotary slider with
labels
um we're going to add a third
constructor parameter to this
let's see where is that that's right
here
we're going to put this on its own line
and we're going to give it a default
value so everything still constructs um
still builds without any errors const
juice string
title equals no title
all right
that's the first part we will display
the component's name
in the paint function so we'll call set
name
title
now let's go to the paint function plug
in editor
rotor slider with labels paint
wait why does this say just oh that's
this should that should say juice
all right
uh paint function right below where we
get the slider bounds let's see i want
to draw this title at the top of the
slider so we need to modify the get
slider bounds function to account for
this so let's draw our title first and
then
adjust the slider bounds next
first let's get the local bounds auto
bounds equals get local bounce
next let's set a color and draw some
fitted text i'm going to go with blue
violet
and let's draw some fitted text g draw
fitted text
all right i'm going to use the rectangle
remove from top function to create the
bounding box that the title text will be
placed in
and i'm going to use the get text height
function plus a little bit more for this
bounding box first things first the text
we will display is the name
get name
the area let's see we're going to be
centered
justification
centered
do centered bottom and we're on one line
all right
let me put these on separate lines
uh let's see we're gonna do bounds dot
remove from top
and the amount to remove is our text
type plus a little bit all right let's
see
how that looks
let's comment out this draw rotary
slider stuff to begin with
all right cool no title excellent
all right let's uncomment to this
okay so we need to dial in these slider
bounds next
all right go down to get slider bounds
now we need to remove some space from
the top of the local bounds so let's do
text height
minus 1.5 and see how that looks
let's see what are we doing right now
auto bounds is get local downs and let's
trim off the top bounds dot remove from
top let's do get text height
times 1.5
let's see how that looks
all right that's very small and it's
still colliding with the title
so
shrinking
let's see
so let's change the y position of this
rectangle to be the y position of our
bounds
let's do let's comment this out and do r
dot set y
bounds dot get y instead
okay cool so
it's not covering up the title now
that's good that's progress all right
let's adjust the s the slider size by
adjusting the size of this rectangle
here this thing right here
now shrinking the size by
twice the text height is too much so
let's change this to be 1.5
and see what it looks like
now that's much better okay this is a
much more reasonable size
let's remove the default parameter next
go back to plugineditor.h
let's get rid of this default parameter
and
let's
build and add our titles where the error
messages appear
okay
in-game slider
you are going to say
input trim
in all caps
low mid is going to be
let's see low
mid
x
over
like that
let's do this one this will be
mid
hi
no gh x
over
and then this will be output trim
output trim
all right let's take a look at this now
that we've got our titles in here
okay that's fantastic now i don't like
this black square in the middle that's
surrounding the numbers
but we'll fix all of these colors later
alright for now
that wraps up the global control so
that's fantastic let's take a look at
that one more time
all right awesome very cool
let's make a commit of that
added titles
to
our swl
bang boom all right
so we adjusted that
just that part is just that part here's
where we actually added the titles
we can start working on the actual
compressor band controls next
let's create the compressor band
controls next here's the road map for
this component
this guy way down here compressor band
controls
number one we're going to add sliders
for the main compressor controls once
that's done we will add the solo mute
and bypass buttons then we will add band
selection functionality meaning we're
going to change the parameters that the
sliders are connected to uh whenever we
click those buttons then we will dial in
the colors before we add in the spectrum
analyzer and drawing the thresholds and
gain reduction all right let's dive in
all right we are going to reuse our uh
where is that class we're gonna reuse
this rotary slider class for right now
okay let's put this um
yeah we're gonna put this after rotary
slider oh let's put it after these
functions let's put it above global
controls okay here we go
all right we need four instances of um
the rotary slider class for our four
compressor controls
okay attack slider release slider
threshold slider and ratio slider
you know what comes next a constructor
and a resized function
let's implement those next head to the
cpp file
let's do this above our global controls
uh constructor
compressor band controls
compressor band controls
let's add all of these sliders as
children
is there anything in here that i can
copy
yeah i'm gonna copy this
we have four sliders
those are four sliders being added
all right let's just delete this
all right now we can add our sliders and
let's see they all end in the word
slider so i'm going to add that and now
i can fill them in tack slider
release slider
threshold slider
ratio slider
now i am going to copy the global
controls
resized code to position these i'm going
to move them later when we add the
buttons but this is just to get them on
screen so go to the compressor brand
sorry go to the global controls resize
function and we're just going to copy
the whole thing
and then we're going to paste it
now we just need to change these names
here
attack slider
oh sorry we need to change this name
first to be uh compressor band controls
all right now we can do attack slider
release slider
threshold slider
and ratio slide it's very convenient
all right let's change our band controls
in the editor to use our compressor band
controls class next select this and copy
it let's go back to the header file
let's get rid of our placeholder in our
editor get rid of band controls here
oops that's the wrong key command
get rid of band controls and get rid of
this comma
and now add an instance here
band controls
all right now we just need to make it
visible again so go to plugineditor.cpp
go to the plugin
uh go to the editor constructor
and we're going to make our band
controls visible let's test it out make
sure you're doing the standalone version
let's see what we get all right awesome
our four sliders very cool so we'll turn
them into these um sliders with the
labels and stuff in a little bit
all right i want to add the same border
that the global controls has to this
compressor
band controls components so let's add a
paint function i'm just going to copy
this declaration put it right below
resized
now we can literally just copy the
global controls paint function and just
rename the class and we'll get that so
go to plugin editor go to global
controls paint literally copy this
paste it after the compressor band
controls resize function and just click
change the class name compressor band
controls change it to
like that all right
let's run it
and see what we get
all right i'm very happy with that
remember i had said i wanted to have a
border with a bit of a gap between
the um between these modules
all right so that's very clean let's
refactor it next because we are
literally repeating the exact same code
in those two paint functions
let's refactor this module background
paint code so we aren't repeating
ourselves i would like to declare a free
function and it's going to be identical
to what we are doing in paint except for
the call to get local bounds that's this
thing right here instead this rectangle
bounds will be one of our parameters so
i'm going to just put that um where
should i put that
i'm going to put that um i'm going to
put that right above this paint function
for right now we'll move it later void
draw module background add an empty
argument list
now we're going to copy these guts over
grab this copy copy and paste this and
let's see all right first things first
we need a graphics context to draw into
then we need that rectangle
bounce all right now that can let us
remove this line there we go okay that
takes care of that
now we just need to comment out this old
code here in our let's see let's do
global controls first let's comment it
out down here let's get rid of this
and let's see i am going to need
uh the bounding box so we'll do
uncomment that line and now do draw
module background bounds
oh we also need your graphics context
okay
let's just uh verify that this works
let's run this real quick
all right global controls is still cool
awesome let's do the exact same thing in
global
in compressor band controls copy that
line scroll on up here comment all of
this out and replace it like that
all right perfect looks good to me let's
get our sliders connected to the
parameters next we will create
attachments first and then we will
change to rotary slider with labels all
right let's clean this up we don't need
that
and we don't need this stuff let's get
rid of this code okay fantastic all
right head over to your plugin editor
dot h go to the global controls
and now copy these attachments from
global controls we're going to copy them
we are going to paste them in our
compressor band controls and rename them
put them right below our sliders
now we're going to do attack slider
attachments
release slider attachment threshold
slider attachment
ratio slider attachment let me line
these back up
let's update this constructor next all
right go to plugineditor.cpp
go to compressor band controls the
constructor
and let's see what can we borrow all
right we're going to do the same
parameter initialization stuff that we
did in
uh compressor band in global band
control so we can grab these things
copy this stuff and we'll fix these
incorrect names in just a moment all
right go up here to the constructor and
paste all this stuff let's copy all of
that code that initialized those
attachments from uh global controls so
go down to global controls grab all of
this stuff the make attachment helper
we're going to need that stuff too
grab this code paste it here all right
now we need to change all of these names
but we'll fix that in just a moment
we need to copy the params declaration
and update the constructor to receive an
ap bts so let's copy that stuff from the
global controls constructor as well
grab this thing right here
all right and paste that here as a
constructor argument
now let's update the declaration next
copy this stuff right here
go to plugineditor.h
and modify this constructor
oops uh this has an extra set of
parentheses
there we go
now we need to revise how our class gets
constructed in our editor so go down
here
and just copy these um copy how the
global controls are initialized and just
paste it here
now we can fix all of these errors in
our um
constructor here all right so first
things first we are doing the um attack
attachment slider attachment and this is
the attack slider and this name needs to
be the attack let's do the um i think we
said we were doing the mid band let's
see what we did uh yeah we'll do we'll
do the middle band first okay so we'll
change that all right so there's the
attack all right now we need to do
release release slider release slider
attachment and then this is the release
mid band all right now we've got the uh
threshold threshold attachment
threshold slider
and then threshold mid band then finally
we have our ratio so this is ratio
attachment
ratio slider and then ratio mid band all
right when we add band switching
functionality we will be able to
dynamically
switch these attachments which will be a
very cool thing all right let's test it
out we are going to drag a slider quit
and rerun and the slider should display
this updated position let's see what we
get
okay
i'm gonna do the uh i'm gonna do the
attack time i'm gonna
yeah i'll do the attack time i'm just
gonna put it at 12 o'clock quit
rerun the attack slider should be at 12
o'clock all right perfect it is double
click to reset to the default value
awesome
our next task is to change rotary
sliders with labels so that it accepts a
pointer to a parameter instead of a
reference the reason is because we will
be dynamically changing the parameter in
the compressor band controls class
whenever we change which band is
currently being displayed
so the other thing we will do is to move
the look and feel to our editor this way
every child component inherits the look
and feel of the parent class
let's go to rotary slider with labels
in the header file
let's modify this constructor
to take a pointer let's change this
member initialization
let's remove the look and feel member
variable
copy this and comment it out now
by removing the look and feel we no
longer
need
to set it here and we also don't need
this destructor so that's cool now let's
see before we add a look and feel to the
editor let's add a member function which
will allow us to change the parameter
whenever we want let's go put this here
right below get display string
void change param
and we'll go to juice
ranged audio parameter pointer
like that
all right now we can go all the way down
to our editor and add a look and feel
member make sure this is the first
member variable that gets constructed
let's go to our editor's constructor we
want to set our look and feel right here
set look oh let's do it before
uh before we
make these guys visible set look and
feel
lnf
make sure you're taking the address of
it
and now we must remember to set it to
null pointer when our component is
destroyed we go set look and feel
null pointer oops
null pointer
okay now we can adjust where every rswl
is created since the constructor wants a
pointer
not a reference so let's build it and
start fixing all of those errors
command b to build
all right
where does this happen
okay so the only spot where we created
these sliders is in the global controls
function so we just need to pass
pointers instead of references so we
just need to
add our ampersand in front of all these
and let's test it out that should clear
all of the errors all right build
succeeded let's test it out let's adjust
the in gain slider and see if it sticks
well look at these guys all right turn
that down and turn that down to 10
quit re-run it should be at 10
10.5 interesting let me do that one more
time
10.
okay there goes all right cool that
looks good to me now
let's see i just want to look at that
one more time now changing the look and
feel um and making the editor
own the instance that all child
components inherit from really messed up
how these compressor band controls
uh end up looking so let's fix that next
all right go to compressor band controls
in the header file
all right this class is going to need
access to the ap vts in order to look up
parameters as needed so let's add a
reference to that we can
just copy this one
right here from our global controls
constructor all right next let's change
all of these sliders here the attack
release threshold and ratio sliders into
rotary slider with labels so grab this
class right here
and paste it there alright we will need
to use the member initializer list to
initialize all of these
next
go to plugin editor dot cpp go to the
compressor brand control constructor
let's initialize all of these members
first things first
let's do the ap vts ap vts
and i'm going to rename this to be apv
now let's do all of our sliders attack
slider alright we're going to start with
nullpointer
and our suffix is milliseconds and our
title is attack let's do the others
release slider same thing null pointer
ms
and
release oops
don't forget the quotes so the other two
all right let's fix this error in the
capture list now we need to do
abbvts
let's see ap bts equals this apbts like
that
all right now we are capturing this
class's instance of the ap ap vts by
reference okay
all right let's test this out oh we need
to um adjust this make params helper
oh you know what i don't know if we
actually need this get param helper yet
so i'm going to comment that out i might
need that in a little bit sure okay
let's test this out we'll see what
happens maybe we will have sliders with
titles
who knows
uh what's going on here
oh this is because it doesn't have a
parameter
all right let's fix that
it's going back here
so it turns out we did need this
we need to get our parameters
and now we can call
change param on all of our sliders let's
do that right here attack slider dot
change param
get pram
helper
let's see this thing returns
a reference so we need to get the
address of it and the name we want is
names
attack mid band all right let's do the
others we got our release slider so i'm
going to just copy this line whoops copy
this line paste
face paste
release slider
threshold slider
ratio slider all right now this is
release mid band
threshold mid band
ratio mid band let's test this out
see what we get
an error
undefined symbol yes we did not
implement this we declared it but did
not implement it so let's do that next
let's go up to where our rotary slider
with labels get display string is we're
going to put this at after it
void
rotary slider with labels
and change param is the one we want
so whatever parameter we pass into this
is
um what we need to give it
um let's see so this becomes param
equals p
and then once we get a new param repaint
let's try this out all right awesome so
these are almost fully functional we
just need to add labels next
all right go back to the constructor we
can use the add label pairs function
that we wrote for
all of our sliders except the ratio
slider and the reason is because the
ratio slider labels need to have a colon
1 at the end so we need to define those
manually so let's start here
add label pairs
our first labels are the attack slider
dot labels
parameter is the get param helper
attack mid band we'll refactor this in a
little bit those need to be cached does
that want to reference it does want a
reference we're giving it that all right
and our suffix is going to be
milliseconds okay do the same thing for
the release paste release slider
release mid band and then threshold
copy
paste threshold slider threshold
mid band and this needs to be decibels
db
so the first label for the ratio slider
the first ratio
is one to one so let's make a label
position element let's add a curly brace
for this for
default initialization all right so at
the zero percent position we want to see
one colon one
all right now the second one should be
the highest ratio
uh defined in the list of choices so
let's get our ratio param
let's see this is a
juice audio parameter
choice
and we want to call get param helper
we want our names ratio mid band
all right now we just need to get the
last entry
from this let's add our line first
um why can't we not why can we not use
cannot convert from this to that um oh
this returns a reference that's right we
should take the address of the reference
return okay so now let's see we want
ratioslider.labels.add
and this is for the 100
position
and now we are going to add um let's see
ratio param
choices and we want the last one how can
we do that we can do get reference
and then ratio param
choices
size
minus one
okay let's see how that looks
so this is displaying 100.0 and we
wanted to say 100 colon 1.
so we need to get the integer value of
this string
and then turn that into a string and
then append the colon one to the end
all right we can do that
we need to change this to be uh choices
get reference i'm gonna put this
down here
all right choices get reference give me
the last one
all right now you're going to give me
the int value
and then
um let's see i need to turn this into a
string
first
put that in parenthesis juice string and
now i can append
colon 1 to it let's see how that looks
there we go 100 to 1. perfect now let's
make the center of the sliders display
the current ratio
next so for this we will need to derive
from the rotary slider with labels and
customize the get display string
function
all right
head over to your header file plugin
editor.h
go to
the
what's the name of this class go to the
rotary slider with labels class all
right we are going to override
this get display string function so we
need to make it virtual first
ritual
and then we need to make these member
variables protected instead of private
so the derived class can access them
let's clean this up too while we are
here
all right let's declare a ratio slider
class below this
now this is a ratio slider which means
we can hard code the title whenever we
are initializing the base class we still
need everything else though
so let's just copy all of this paste it
here change this class name
and fix this indentation
all right so all we need is the suffix
and the rest is for the base class
rotary slider with labels
and put this on its own line
all right we're passing in
our ranged audio parameter our unit
suffix and then
ratio
perfect
curly braces
all right now we can implement the
function that we care about
this guy right here get display string
override
let's implement it next let's go to the
plugin editor.cpp
go to the
uh change param function we're gonna put
it right below that
all right so let's start the
implementation this function returns a
string
okay
what we need to do here is get the name
of the current choice to do that we need
to convert the program into a choice
parameter so that's uh step number one
auto
choice param equals dynamic cast
juice audio parameter choice
param
let's make sure that we can cast it
once we have our choice param we can
just get the current choice name
now if you remember it displayed 100.0
when we used the choice name directly
this is because we declared our choices
as doubles because i wanted 1.5 to be
one of the choices
and everything else is an integer value
basically which means it's gonna end up
with that point zero at the end so if
the choice ends with point zero just
remove that from the string
if current choice dot contains
point zero
get rid of it current choice
equals
currentchoice.substring
our starting index is zero
and our endpoint is the index of that
period because the
end index is not included in the
substring we go from our starting point
up to but not including the end
currentchoice.index of
okay once we've done that just stick the
colon at the end current choice
colon one
all right
there's our display string let's test it
out let's return it return current
choice
see what happens
nothing and that is because we forgot to
change our ratio sliders type
copy this ratio slider go to the header
file
go to the
uh where's this class
go to the constructor go to the
compressor band controls class and
change
the ratio slider
to be that ratio slider
all right let's run this we should see
the ratio in the center nope we uh
what's wrong oh we don't need this third
parameter that's why all right let's fix
that all right third time's the charm
okay cool there we go we're seeing our
ratio in the middle let's cycle through
them see what we get four five six seven
eight nine ten fifteen twenty
100 perfect and what happens when we get
to 1.5 is that a thing
perfect
all right
let's make a commit of that
so implemented
basic
comp band controls
perfect stage stage
let's add the solo mute and bypass
buttons next we will position them and
then connect them to parameters
go to the header file go to our
compressor band controls and let's add
these after our attachments
juice toggle button is the weapon of
choice here
okay bypass button solo button mute
button
let's set the name next go to the plugin
uh go to the constructor compressor band
controls
let's do this after we add our sliders
bypass button
dot set name we're going to draw the
name the name is what will be drawn when
we configure the look and feel
bypass we'll give it an x
solo will have a big
s in it
and mute will have an m
okay let's add them next i'm just going
to copy three of these
paste and now copy paste copy paste copy
paste let's go to our resized function
okay
this component will have band control
buttons on the right and band select
buttons on the left so let's write a
helper function to wrap this vertical
arrangement
of these buttons in a flex box somewhere
since we are using flexbox already for
the sliders so first we will pass in a
vector of
pointers to components that'll look like
this
std vector
component pointer
comps
then we will declare a flexbox
that we will be adding the buttons to
but the column direction we can just
copy this
the column direction
or the direction will be column instead
of row
that's the only change we're going to
make there number six i want a small
spacer between them so i'm going to copy
this
again this is vertical
so we're going to do with height
and
i want it smaller than 4 2 pixels is
fine
all right now we just need to loop
through our components add a spacer
before and then add the component to the
flexbox for autocomp
comps
flexbox.items.add
add the spacer first
then add the
add to the component
add a flex item
with a flex of one
now our item list currently goes spacer
component spacer component spacer
component so we need to add one more
spacer
at the end
now we can return our flexbox
all right so this is going to be used
for the buttons on the right the bypass
mute solo buttons and then the band
select buttons on the left
all right now we can call it
we can call our lambda
like this with our band control buttons
with our uh not banned control buttons
with our um
uh yeah band control buttons that's
right um the bypass mute solo buttons
auto band
button control
correct capitalization auto band button
control box equals create band
band button control box and we need to
provide a vector
of our
a vector with our components we want the
address of the bypass button
address of the solo button
and the address of the mute button
okay next
let's get rid of this end cap for now
and we're going to replace it with a
spacer
and now let's add the band control
button box on the right
flexbox.items.add
band control
button box band button control box and
let's give it a width
uh this needs to be wrapped in flex item
declare a flex item
and let's give it a width
uh let's see 30. i you know i usually
enjoy buttons
and i like gooeys that have buttons
around like the 20 to 30 size so we'll
start with 30.
see what we get
okay we're not seeing them
let's check the look and feel class next
all right let's see go up to the look
and feel draw toggle button
all right if it's power button it's
going to draw something
if it's an analyzer button it's going to
do something else
okay it doesn't do anything if it's
neither of those so let's add an else
clause
it's a pretty silly error okay let's
draw a rounded rectangle with the
component name in the middle all right
if the button is on
we're going to draw a black text on a
white background otherwise draw a white
text on a black background we'll dial in
these colors later first let's get our
bounding box
auto bounds equals toggle button dot
get local bounds
and i'll shrink it a little bit
alright if the button is on
it would be nice to know
all right let's give ourselves a
corner size
because remember we're doing rounded
rectangle
all right let's fill a rounded rectangle
with the background color first g.set
color
if the button is on
we're gonna do white otherwise we're
doing black
and now let's fill our rectangle
and then invert the colors and draw a
rounded rect followed by the text so g
dot let's just copy this line
invert the colors so if it's we're gonna
do black first
and then white depending on if the
button is on or off now let's draw a
rounded rectangle g dot draw rounded
rectangle our corner size is going to be
corner size our line thickness will be 1
and our rectangle will be bounds dot 2
float
all right now let's draw our text g.draw
fitted text
we're going to draw the
button get name
we're gonna draw it inbounds
we're gonna be centered and we're gonna
occupy one line of text
all right let's test it out
boom
all right got some toggle buttons
fantastic
all right let's connect them to
parameters next
okay go to plugin editor.h go to the
bottom of compressor band controls and
let's add some attachment i'm just going
to copy this code we only need three of
these we're using a different attachment
we're using
button attachment
and we cannot use an alias
without redeclaring one so let's do btn
attachment like that and an indent
indent indent we don't need uh we only
need three of these
so we'll do bypass button attachment
solo button attachment
mute button attachment
and let's indent these so they all line
up nicely
okay
and now
head over to the constructor we want
compressor band controls
and let's use our attachment helper to
initialize them make attachment helper
our attachment is going to be let's see
we'll start with bypass button oops
bypass button attachment our name is
names um
we're doing mid band right bypass mid
band and our slider is the bypass button
i'm glad we templated that class because
it means we can use it with any
component not just
um
not just sliders all right let's do this
again
i'm just going to copy and paste this
and rename stuff
all right we've got bypass we got solo
attach
um we've got mute attach
let's see the solo button
this was the mute button
solo mid
and
mute mid
okay let's test it out
that was very quick
all right let's let's see um
let's um
let's close this this will be bypassed
close that rerun
all right bypass is still working all
right let's go
test this out in audio plug and host
and we adjust the sliders and the solo
bypass buttons and see if we hear any
differences
all right
here we go
oh headphones
[Music]
all right we're soloing the mid band
and we can adjust all this stuff
that is definitely working mute that
band seeing it dipped out very cool
[Music]
[Applause]
let's give it a real quick release time
[Applause]
[Music]
that is definitely working
all right
right past that turn that off
stop
save quit
all right we're getting there okay
all of these are working the next step
is to add buttons that let us select
which band the sliders are actually
controlling let's do that next
all right let's add three buttons to
allow switching of the bands go to the
header file
and just put them at the end of the list
low band mid band high band
let's go to the uh constructor and set
their name
there's a brand
i'm just gonna duplicate this
i'm gonna put this after the attachment
stuff this is low band
mid band high band
low
mid
high
okay these buttons need to be grouped
together so that when you click on one
the others toggle off
that's what the radio group id is for so
low band dot set radio group id
set them all to one
all right we'll do low band
mid band
high band these are all part of the same
radio group let's make them visible we
will position them next
paste and now copy paste
copy paste
copy paste
okay let's add another flex box
go to the resize function
we've got our band button control box
let's add another one for the select
buttons auto band
select
control box
equals create band button
all right let's add our vector
with our three buttons
low band first
mid band next
high band last
all right let's get rid of the end cap
let's replace it with a spacer
and now add the band
select box on the left
flexbox items
add flex item
here you are going to control the band
select control box
with flex of one
and we're gonna need one spacer after
this let's see i'm not gonna do it with
with with this flex actually i'm gonna
do it with a fixed width um let's see
okay so the band control box had a width
of 30
um and that was displaying a single
character of text so i know that this
needs to be wider because
it's displaying you know three or four
characters so let's try 50
and we need a spacer after it as well
all right let's take a look
all right those look nice like that that
looks good it's nice um
nice positioning of everything so i'm
happy with that so let's save this quit
this
those buttons don't do anything but we
will fix that in a bit
for now let's make a commit
of what we've done
what did we do we added um
added control buttons
to
band control what is this thing called
compressor band control class
presser band controls
that's what we did
stage
stage that
um let's see here's where we customize
the look and feel here's where we added
all of our buttons
here's where we
added them to the flexbox stage stage
stage commit all right awesome
if you get stuck or run into trouble
while coding this or simple eq just grab
one of my free products from
programming4musicians.com
and you can message me directly in the
slack workspace and i will help you
directly
let's make these band switcher buttons
work whenever we click on one of these
buttons we will simply reset the slider
and the button attachments and recreate
the attachments okay the tricky part is
figuring out
which button was clicked now we're going
to be doing all of this stuff before we
make our buttons visible so first let's
define a lambda that will be called
whenever each button is clicked
let's capture a safe pointer
that is alive for as long as this class
exists
all right we're going to just speak some
stuff into existence
all right we're going to do this after
we
set our radio group and before we set
everything visible all right here we go
let's make a let's make this lambda
all right we have
uh declared that a safe point or member
variable exists so let's um let's go
make one
okay go to the
plugin editor dot h at the bottom of the
compressor band control
let's add one here
juice
component
safe
pointer come on auto complete
there it is
all right and it is a compressor band
controls and it is an instance created
from this
and it's called safe pointer
and initialization requires curly braces
okay
all right go back to that constructor
okay
let's do a quick build to clear that
error
okay if our save pointers component is
valid let's call a function that updates
the attachments
if
auto
all right if the safe pointer component
exists let's call a function on it
alright i'm going to just call a
function that doesn't exist yet but it
will
update attachments
okay it doesn't exist yet but it will
let's go declare it next
plug in editor go to the bottom of this
put it right here void update
attachments
all right we've got our declaration in
place let's go implement this after we
finish doing what we need to do in the
constructor
so go back to the constructor because
we're not done there we can
do a quick build to clear that error
all right we've got this lambda so let's
assign it to the on click member
function
why is that still giving oh there it
goes error is gone because it says bill
succeeded so that's just
xcode is just taking a while to catch up
all right here we go
band dot on click equals button switcher
do the same thing for the other three
bands low band mid band high band oh
sorry don't no parentheses
all right we want low band mid band
high band okay whenever one of those
buttons is clicked it is going to call
this function now before we implement
update attachments let's make the low
band the default band choice by setting
the toggle state to true
and then we can call our attachment
updater function
which will connect all the attachments
to the appropriate sliders so first set
the toggle state to true
low band dot
set toggle state
true
and we do not want to send a
notification the reason is because
sending a notification will trigger this
lambda and we don't want that to happen
don't
choose notification type
don't send notification all right let's
call update attachments update
attachments
now we can go implement the update
attachments function
all right let's start this after the
paint function
right here void compressor band controls
update attachments okay there are a few
problems we need to solve in this
function
number one we have to figure out which
button was clicked now we can do this by
checking the toggle state of all of our
buttons
they are part of a radio group which
means only one button can be toggled on
at a time
problem number two we have to figure out
which parameters go with which buttons
and number three we have to create the
parameters like we did in the
constructor so first things first let's
figure out which button is clicked i
don't want to use integers for this so
i'm going to declare an enumeration and
declare a variable that uses that
enumeration as the type then i'm going
to immediately invoke a
lambda that will determine that
variable's value first things first here
is the enumeration
scroll a little bit
and here is the immediately invoked
lambda
all right this logic is very simple if
it's the low band we're going to return
low band type if it's the mid band we
return the mid band type if it's high
band well then the only thing that's
left if it's not lower mid is high
okay very simple
all right next the plan here is to use a
switch statement that works off of
whichever button was clicked to populate
a vector
that contains the names from our param
names enum that we can use
to look up
the parameters once we have that vector
we can easily figure out which parameter
to use with each attachment we have our
band type from this lambda now we simply
switch based on this band type
let's let the autocomplete fill out all
of the cases for us switch
band type
let's get rid of these
and press build and wait for auto
complete to tell us that we are missing
enumeration values
there it is
all right add missing switch cases thank
you
let's reindent
those correctly
all right let's get rid of this get rid
of these placeholders
okay we have all of our cases now in our
switch statement we can declare our
vector next and then fill it with values
from the param
names enumeration next i'm talking about
this enumeration right here this thing
from
a long time ago in this project
all right let's create our vector next
we're going to need our params namespace
using
namespace params
std vector
names
names
okay
we can fill in the switch cases next
with the param names for the selected
bands
so for the let's do the low band first
names equals
let's see um
we need to do this and it's going to
complain if i don't define the type
because it doesn't know
what i'm doing
let's see this is going to be names if
it's the low band then we're using the
attack low band we're using the
release
release low band and we're doing the
threshold
let's see attack release threshold
ratio
and the bypass mutant solo
all right this is what to do when it's
the low band
all right i'm gonna put this in curly
braces
okay we need to do the exact same thing
for the mid band
and the high band so grab this stuff
paste it and just start replacing the
values
1 2 3 h i g h
okay great
all right
fix any errors that come up while you're
typing it make sure that for the high if
the high button is switched you're using
high params if the mid button is
switched make sure you're using mid
params
all right so here's the thing to notice
from this we are always doing the same
order attack release threshold ratio
mute solo bypass
attack release threshold ratio mute solo
bypass same for here attack release
threshold ratio mute solo bypass
let's define another enumeration for the
possible positions in this name vector
and we will index into the names array
using this position
vector so enum position
attack
release threshold
ratio
mute solo
bypass
let's get our param name map
that's auto
params
whoops that begins with the p params
equals get params now the next thing to
do is to update the parameter that the
slider is connected to let's grab that
param helper lambda from the constructor
and we need to modify it to use the
names vector
to provide the parameter name so let's
go up here go to our constructor we want
the param helper
copy this thing here copy go back to our
attachment function
we're going down here after our position
enumeration
and we need to capture
our names vector and we're going to be
using our position
thing to index and do so let's just
change that pos just so we know what
we're doing
and now we're going to use let's see
let me call get param return get param
okay we're passing the ap vts yes we are
passing our params map and our name is
taken from our names
vector
at
the position this thing right here
okay so we're looking up um let's see
we have our names array
and we're pulling out a position from it
so if we pass attack into names and it
happens to be the high band we're going
to get back this enumeration value and
then we're going to pass that into get
params as the name of which position to
get for the map
okay it's a little bit of in direction
there to figure out all that stuff
all right now we need to reset the
attachments before we create new
attachment i'm not sure exactly why this
is necessary as make attachment ends up
calling the same destructor of the
slider attachment class
however if this is omitted then the
sliders don't display the correct value
when they are refreshed so if i figure
out the answer i will let you know but
for now just
you know trust me on this attack slider
attachment dot reset we have to do this
for all of the sliders all the sliders
and all the for all of the attachment
all right let me work on that now
now we can change our parameters and add
label pairs to our sliders so let's
cache the parameters so we are not
calling the helper function twice for
each parameter
now remember that
changing the parameter repaints so we
need to add the labels before we
actually change the parameter so let's
get our attack parameter first auto
attack param equals get param helper
and our position is going to be
the position
attack
okay remember we are
using our names
thing
to look this up
all right and our name
our names vector is
one of these three choices it could be
could contain all mid-band param lookups
it could be low band param lookups could
be high band param lookups
all right
that's how all that stuff works okay
let's get um let's add our label pairs
add label pairs
attack slider
labels our param is going to be the
attack parameter
and our suffix is milliseconds
all right and now we can change the
param
attack param
excellent
now do the same thing for the release
param and the threshold param
now for the ratio
in the constructor if you recall we
could not use
add label pairs instead we had to
manually code them up
so
let's grab this code because we're going
to reuse it
actually all this stuff is going to end
up getting commented out
but let's copy this and actually we need
to clear our ratio slider labels ratio
slider dot labels
dot clear
okay
all right copy this stuff
actually we don't need any of this now
because none of this this is all getting
set in that attachment um update
attachments class
we can come with that out now
oh we don't need our end cap
i'm a big fan of not having any warnings
all right way down here at the bottom
all right let's get our um our ratio
param
auto ratio param
as a
um let's see
it's a ranged audio
right now we can replace this
all right our ratio param is going to be
ratio param wrap
all right and then now we can change our
parameter ratio
uh ratio slider dot change param
ratio param
okay great now we are ready to start
updating our attachments
so let's use our make attachment class
directly ins uh our make attachment
function instead of that make attachment
helper well we could use that actually
let's see where is that helper there's
button switcher there's make attachment
helper
okay here we go grab this guy let's see
let's see if we can use this
make attachment helper
all right make attachment helper first
one is the attack slider attachment
our name is going to be the names array
and we want the position
attack
our slider is the attack slider
okay let's do that for the release
slider next
now for the threshold slider
and now the ratio slider
next to the button attachments let's do
bypass button first then we'll do solo
and finally the mute button
all right now we can go to the
constructor and delete the code that
configures the attachments and the
sliders because this function does all
of that for us this is a bit of a
monster function all right let's go up
to the constructor
all right we don't need any of this um
attachment stuff all right cool we don't
need any of this grit get uh get param
helper
which means we don't need these either
is that right can i get rid of that too
i can get rid of that
excellent
all right let's run this switch to the
standalone editor
that was a big
big chunk of surgery we did there on the
code
out of range
why is that happening
named that position what is being called
here
what position did i choose
ratio mid band
oh uh this is the wrong one
okay
for this
yeah this should not be the names ratio
this should be position
ratio
there we go okay
all right there we go okay we're
defaulting to the low band that's good
all right so to test this out
let's
uh let's see we're on the low band now
let's switch the threshold to like
whatever like negative 24. cool let's
switch to the mid band
that goes back to zero let's switch back
to the low band
negative 24. perfect all right cool
all right the sliders are currently
reflecting let's chest the low band i'm
going to change this from 50 to
150 whatever
go to the mid band
go back all right cool that works as
expected if i go to the high band and
change i'm going to change the release
super short so this was five
now it's 250 now it's five all right
perfect so the next thing to do
is to make the solo mute and bypass
buttons have custom fill colors to
reflect their state
then we will make the band selection
buttons reflect that state as well so
that way if you're on the high band
and the low band is bypassed this button
will reflect that it's bypassed even
though these buttons are currently
showing the high band state
we'll do that next
let's close this let's make a commit of
what we did
what did we do we added
let's see wired up band selection
buttons that's a good way to describe it
all right let's clean up that
constructor
um where is that that's here
we have a lot of code that does not need
to exist
let's get rid of this stuff
and this stuff
all right great
let's clean that up stage commence there
we go commit awesome all right
next we will um
next we will adjust the colors that get
used whenever you click on a button
okay the next thing to do is to make the
bypass solo and mute buttons change the
slider enablements as well as change the
color of the band select buttons also
because these buttons are not part of a
radio group that means we need to
manually make sure that only one button
is toggled on at a time
that means we need to modify the audio
parameters so that only one parameter
can be true at a time remember clicking
the button changes the audio parameter
and the gui then updates itself to
reflect the latest value of this audio
parameter so we need to accomplish a lot
of stuff whenever we click one of these
banned control buttons so let's use
button listener instead of the button on
click lambda to coordinate all of this
first things first
let's go to our header file
and let's inherit
from button listener
juice button
listener let's add a destructor and the
appropriate callback
all right there we go got my destructor
and the appropriate
callback for the listener class
let's add our band controls as a
listener to all of our
to our three buttons where are those
guys those guys are right here let's do
this before we set our name let's do
this yeah right here it's fine
bypass button add listener
this class all right do the same for the
solo and mute
paste that copy this
paste paste
let's add the destructor and stop
listening to these three buttons
put that right here pressure band
controls
just copy these guys copy these three
lines
paste it and change this to say remove
listener copy paste copy paste copy
paste
okay the next thing to do is to
implement the button clicked function
all right let's put this after paint
go to the paint function
and put it before update attachments
void compressor band controls
button clicked
step number one is to update the slider
enablements if you mute or bypass a band
if um
if a band is muted or the band is
bypassed the sliders should be disabled
it's extremely common for audio
engineers to be adjusting a parameter
you know tweaking a knob and they think
that the sound is totally changing like
totally different wow this sounds so
much better when i tweak this knob only
to find out that the plug-in was
bypassed the entire time when they're
done it's this placebo effect but it's
with audio so implementing this will
prevent this from happening so let's
call an imaginary function
that does this first and we'll implement
it next so here we go update slider
enablements
that's the first thing we will do
let's go declare the imaginary function
that we just called
copy this
header file go to the bottom of it put
it after update attachments and let's
put this right after oh let's give it a
return type void
let's put this right after our button
clicked class for right now
void compressor band controls
implementation real quick
okay here is the logic to implement
if the band is muted or bypassed disable
the sliders a simple or statement will
give us our disabled status auto
disabled equals
mute button
dot get toggle state
or
bypass button
get toggle state
if a button is mute if the band is muted
or bypassed it should be disabled
once we have our disabled state we just
set each slider to that state
attack slider
dot set enabled
if the mute button is on
then that means disabled is true and it
should be disabled if disabled it should
not be enabled so we want opposite of
that disabled
okay
if disabled is true then enabled should
be false so if so we want to pass the
opposite of disabled all right do this
for all
four sliders
attack slider release slider
threshold slider
ratio slider
let's try this out
run this
and now let's bypass
and cool we can't we cannot interact
with these
and now we can
perfect all right the next thing to
implement is replicating the radio group
functionality now we cannot use the
radio group functionality that comes
with the juice button clasp because
those require one button in the group to
always be on
we don't want that we want to be able to
solo and unsolo we want to be able to
mute and unmute bypass and bun and
bypass and also prevent being soloed and
muted at the same time so that's way
different okay
we need to be able to have
i'll show you what i'm talking about we
need to be able to have these buttons in
toggled off state and radio group will
not allow that at least one button needs
to be on in the radio group well not at
least one button needs to always be
having a toggle state of true in the um
in the radio group okay so that's why we
cannot use radio group
let's write a function that is called
after this guy that updates the solo
mute and bypass toggle states so we need
to pass in the button that was clicked
so we can update the non-clicked buttons
accordingly let's call our imaginary
function and then implement what it does
next
update solo mute bypass toggle states
and update it with the button we passed
in and we're going to pass it as a
reference because
yeah
because it's yeah let's let's just do
that
all right let's go declare it
copy this function name go to the editor
put it at the bottom
void
and pass in a juice
a regular juice button as a reference
clicked button excellent all right let's
implement it next go back to plugin
editor.cpp let's put this after slider
enablements before update attachments
void compressor band controls
update solo
whatever that huge name was that we came
up with
all right the logic here is pretty
simple if you click the solo button on
toggle the mute button and the bypass
button off
if you click the mute button on toggle
the solo and bypass buttons off
if you click bypass on toggle the mute
and solo buttons off and if you click a
but if you click a button off
don't do anything and we need to
remember to send the notification as
that is what alerts the parameter
attachment to update the audio parameter
all right so here is what this code ends
up looking like i'll show you the first
one if the clicked button is the solo
button and the solo button was clicked
on
set the bypass
to false and send that notification to
update the parameter
do the same for the mute button set the
mute button to off and send the
notification
all right now we need to do the same
thing for the mute button
as well as the bypass button okay there
we go
if the clicked button is the mute button
and the mute button was toggled on
turn off the bypass button and turn off
the solo button
if the clicked button is the bypass
button
turn off the mute button and turn off
the solo button let's try this out we
should be able to click on the buttons
and only one should be toggled at a time
all right solo
mute
mute bypass bypass off solo on soul off
mute on mute off
all right cool
that works as expected so the next thing
is to make these
solo mute and bypass buttons use a
custom color whenever they are toggled
let's make a commit before we go any
further
what did we do we added um
let's see we uh added
solo mute
bypass
click functionality that's a i don't
know any other way to describe it and
that's a pretty good description of what
it's doing
um added
extended click functionality
all right commit that stuff okay
all right like i said the next thing
that we have to do on our to-do list is
to make the band buttons for um first we
have to make the solo mute and bypass
buttons show a custom color whenever we
click on them and then we need to make
the band select buttons reflect that
state of the band but before we do that
we're going to do something else
before we tackle the next item in the
band controls to do list
let's create separate files for
all of the classes we currently have in
editor
um
editor.h and editor.cpp
so these
this these two source files are getting
pretty cluttered so what we're going to
do is one class or namespace
per source file so here is the process
we're going to use producer to create a
new set of source files we're going to
migrate the class over and we're going
to repeat this until all non-original
classes and namespaces have been moved
into their own source files once that is
done we're going to correct all of the
include directives and keep trying to
build until it builds successfully
so let's go over to producer let's sorry
let's go to our header file first let's
go all the way to the top alright first
thing we're going to do is look and feel
okay
first thing we're going to do is look
and feel
new cpp and header file
look and feel
all right that went in the wrong place
let's get rid of that
put it here look and feel
all right save and open
now go to plugin editor
and just start migrating stuff over
okay let's do the cpp file next
this is an instance where it's very
helpful to use the assistant editor
all right that's one class
oh we don't need this anymore let's get
rid of that
okay let's do rotary slider with labels
and we will put the ratio slider in that
class as well
because it's you know it has like
minimal there's no reason for it to be
its own
to be in its own separate source file so
we'll grab all of this and put it there
okay let's do ratio let's do a rotary
slider with labels
rotary slider with labels
grab these guys
cut
paste
and we need our juice header
we need to copy these functions
collapse collapse
and ratio slider
okay
cut and paste
all right next we can do our buttons the
analyzer and the power buttons
these guys are implemented in class so
we just need a header file for that
well you know let's do header and source
custom buttons
cut
custom buttons
include
juice header
all right let's move this analyzer
toggle button
copy
paste
add the fully qualified name
and get rid of this there we go
and we don't need the override
keyword okay uh placeholder component
and we can leave that
we do need to
yeah we'll just add those as like um
we'll just do like utility utility
components
utility comps
utility components
okay copy these guys
paste them here
juice header
plug-in editor all right
our placeholder constructor
might as well put the paint function
there
and now our rotary slider
there we go okay
next
all right we need some utility classes
for all of these templated guys
utilities i'm just going to call it
utilities
all right let's see we need to move make
attachment
that goes here
what else goes here
um get param that should go there
get vowel string declaration of it that
should go there
let's grab um get val string
that goes here
let's see um we can do this truncate
kilo value that's templated so that can
go here as well
and then add label pairs
all right let's see what else should go
there i think we can use our
draw background function where did that
go
that here that's in this class
draw module background let's do that one
too that should move as well
cut this
put that at the end of this cpp file and
grab the
declaration
okay
all right now we need a compressor band
controls
compressor band controls
all right you know let me let's organize
these
let's see sort
alphabetically
there we go
okay plugin editor dot h let's grab
compressor band controls
paste it here
and don't forget the juice header
all right let's collapse all of these
so they're easy to copy
sized
paint
button clicked
update enablements
update solo mute update attachments okay
copy all of these over
all right what do we have left
global controls okay
last one
global
controls
all right plugin editor we need our
global controls
paste them
here include the juice header
and now let's grab our global controls
from the cpp file collapse all these
down
okay cool it's just three functions very
cool
all right
and is there anything in plug-in
processor yes we have our params
let's do that next
params
let's add the juice header
and we can probably move this to the cpp
file um it's not necessary though
all right next one is compressor band
let's do that next
compressor band
all right let's copy this guy over
okay
include
juice header
awesome
and let's see we can do all of this
cpp file
very simple all right
just turn all these into declarations
oh you know we're here we can check off
some things we did our global controls
those are done
we have added our main band controls
that's done
we added solo mute bypass and we did
band select functionality
very cool
so we have split all this stuff up and
if we build it we're going to have a ton
of include errors
let's fix that stuff next
the way that you do this is just start
building it and tackling the errors
expected namespace so we need to include
that
include
params.h
just start building it until stuff
disappears
all right compressor brand control
unknown type name rotary slider with
labels let's include that include
rotary slider with labels
go to the next one ratio slider
that's part of that class that's fine
um okay
button listener let's just see what it
does let's just start clearing stuff out
look and feel needs to know about the
rotary slider with labels class in the
cpp file
include
rotary slider labels
you need to know about our utility
function kilo value
include utilities i believe is what i
called it yes
uh plug-in processor you need to know
about the compressor band
all right plug an editor you need to
know about look and feel
include
look and feel
what else do you need to know about you
need to know about global controls and
compressor band controls
include
global
holes include compressor band
controls
global controls you need to know about
rotary slider with labels
global controls constructor you need to
know about params
all right placeholder where is
placeholder located
include utility
utility components that's where that was
all right global controls needs to know
about get param that's in utilities
all right cool power button
you are located in those custom buttons
is that what it's called
that will be called that file yes
all right draw module background that is
found in the utilities
i need to know about the params
oh build succeeded all right let's run
it let's see if it looks the same
fantastic all right cool let's make a
commit of that
all right
refactored into separate
files
that's huge there's our compressor band
custom buttons global controls
and actually what i want to do
uh before i commit that i actually want
to put these into
dsp and source folders so here is let's
see programming simple mbcomp
uh not build source i'm going to add a
new folder
i should have done this when i created
the files
all right click
um how do i make a new folder in here
new folder
dsp
and then
i'm gonna make another new folder
gui
all right dsp stuff goes in here
compressor band goes in here that's in
dsp
params is part of dsp
um everything else seems to be gooey
gooey look and feel is definitely gooey
custom buttons
compressor band controls is definitely
gooey
rotary slider with labels
is definitely gooey
and utility components is definitely
gooey
utilities
this is all gooey stuff so we'll just
leave it in there
all right now let's fix
this
by deleting this
so we'll just delete the entire chunk
just remove the references and just drag
the whole source file in
perfect
save and reopen
okay now we need to fix all of these
includes now that they are organized
correctly
so let's do a build
and start fixing errors
look and feel not found because it is
found in gui
like that all right global controls
all those are in the gui
we can really just look through this
okay this is um
params is fine let's see compressor
that's all going to be in there so it's
really just plugin editor that needs
this stuff and then plug-in processor
needs that stuff that way
all right params you are going to be
located in dot dot slash dsp
like that
right include dot dot slash dsp
params yeah that was right okay
all right any of these files that need
it are going to be the same this is dsp
slash
same for global controls
all right build succeeded let's run it
just to make sure
cool
all right now we can make our commit
let's just stage all of this
okay
here's our compressor band
let's look at this all right compressor
band that's cool that's cool
also cool
[Music]
all right because we didn't we opted to
not move this to the cvp file
okay compressor band controls
all this stuff
all right
this is fine let's commit these 23 files
okay great that was an epic refactor
but now our plugin editor
is much simpler
let's customize these button colors
let's enable the ability to customize
the color per button by using the find
color member function of the component
class
these are toggle buttons that we're
currently doing
uh but we will use the text button color
ids to figure out which color we want
let's i just want to show you which ones
i'm talking about if we go to draw if we
go to the toggle button class and then
actually go to the text button class
there are several color ids that we can
use we can use
color id when the button is off when
it's on and then the text color for when
it's off and when it's on
okay so we'll be working with that stuff
all right let's work through this
revision let me show the code first
all right we are calling set color twice
right here and right here
one for the background that's what the
first one does when we fill our
rectangle and then the second one for
the border that's what this one does and
then the text that's what this line does
okay for the background we want to use
the button on color id and the button
off color id
okay
the trick is to remember to call find
color on the toggle button itself that
means we need to remember to set both of
these colors the button on color and
button off color
we need to set both of these on the
button itself in order for this find
color lookup to actually work we're
going to customize the border color
later when we work on the color scheme
for the entire plugin so for now let's
head back to the compressor band
controls class and assign some default
colors for these guys
head over to compressorbandcontrols.cpp
[Music]
all right we're going to do this after
we add our
uh
after we set our low bands name
we're going to
um we're gonna do low band and we're
gonna set the color and we need to do
the on color and the off color
so
low band dot set color
and then we need to provide the name
we're doing juice text
text button
color ids
and we're doing the
button on color
for this i'm going to do gray
all right for the off color let me copy
this
for the off color i'm going to do
black
now don't forget the on button and the
off button color need to be set for this
to work
all right let's do the same
do the same thing for the other two
bands
all right we just need to change the
names here
high band
high band
all right next let's set the colors for
the bypass solo and mute buttons when
these buttons are toggled on they should
each have a different fill color i'm
gonna go with yellow for bypass greenish
for the solo and then red for the mute
because usually when a button when a
track is muted
on a like an actual console it's got a
red led
all right and then if you solo it it's i
don't know maybe it's yellow or whatever
i don't know i haven't looked at a
console in a while regardless let's add
these colors next
all right here's the bypass we'll do the
bypass button first
set name
okay first color i'm going to do for
bypass i'm going to do yellow and black
yellow when it's on and black when it's
off for this is the fill color not the
border color
the solo button next
i'm gonna do lime green and black
and the mute button is gonna be red and
black
red when it's on black when it's off
okay let's test this out
let's do a quick run
all right cool so we get gray when it's
selected that's cool
and this is yellow this is greenish and
red
all right fantastic
the next thing to do is to make the band
select buttons these guys right here we
need to make their fill color reflect
the state of the band if the band is
soloed then we want this button to be
green if the band is bypass we want this
to be yellow if this is muted we want it
to be red every time we click a button
we need to refresh these colors for the
active band so let's head down to the
button clicked function
next all right head to the header file
and we're going to add a pointer right
here that is going to keep track of
which band is the active band this is
based off of which band select button is
currently toggled on juice toggle button
pointer active band and it's going to
default to the low band right now we
need to update which band is the active
band whenever we make new attachments go
to the cpp file go to update attachments
and we can do this in the switch
statement if we click on the low low
button then we need to say that the
active band is the low band if we click
on the mid band
and it's the mid band click on the mid
band button the active band is the mid
band and then finally if we click on hi
active band is the high band what's cool
about this is we don't have to check
toggle state to figure it out all right
let's go back to button clicked alright
let's call another imaginary function
update the active band fill colors let's
call it first then we will declare it
and then implement it
update
active band fill colors and we'll pass
it the button
that's currently being used all right
let's go declare it next go to the
header file let's put it down here void
update active band fill colors juice
button clicked button now this function
is basically going to call active band
arrow set colors with specific colors
let's go implement it now copy this
thing go back here and let's put this
above update slider enablements
put it right here compressor controls
update band fill colors
um what's it called
yeah that's right
oops let me just use autocomplete
there it is
okay first things first let's make sure
our active band is valid i don't see why
it would ever be but just you know just
make sure
all right and let's print out the name
just so we know what's going on
active band
active band
get name
next if the button's toggle state is off
we need to reset the active band's
colors back to the default colors so
let's call an imaginary function for
that if clicked button
dot get toggle state is false if the
button is off then reset active band
colors we'll fill that in we'll
implement that in just a moment
otherwise
we need to refresh the active bands
colors and we need to pull the colors
from the button that was clicked so
let's call another imaginary function
refresh band button
colors active band
and the clicked button okay let's
implement reset active colors next
first let's declare it header file void
reset active band colors
and let's put this above slider
enablements void compressor band
controls
reset active band colors so first the
button was clicked off let's restore the
active band to the default fill slash
off colors active band
set color and we're going to do the
button on color text button color ids
on color
and we want to do that gray color juice
colors
now we're currently using gray for the
default color but we will eventually
build a system that lets us look up
colors from the global color scheme it's
going to be similar to that
params names system that we built
earlier but it's going to be for colors
okay let's implement the other function
after we do the rest of this all right
so we've got our active color for on is
this and then we need to do the off
color and we're using black here
now changing the color doesn't cause it
to repaint so let's do that next
let's implement the other function
refresh band
button colors let's declare this guy
right here
this one right here
copy it go to the header file void let's
make it static so we can use it with any
button pair that we need static
and the first thing is going to be juice
button
and then juice button color source we're
going to pull colors from the color
source and apply them to the to the
first param
let's go to the implementation cpp file
uh put it above reset
void compressor band controls refresh
okay we're going to do band dot set
color and now we need to copy copy the
button on color id from the source to
the band button on and we're copying um
we are copying color source color source
dot find color this thing
since we want this color to persist when
we change the selected band we need to
also set the off color to the color
sources on color and what i mean by this
is if i click the solo button on the low
band
and then switch to the mid band i still
want the low band to
show i still want the low band select
button to show me that it is soloed
and when you switch bands it uses the
off color when it's no longer toggled on
so that's why we have to do it this way
so we go
band dot set color
i can just copy this line okay we are
setting the off color button color id
to the on color of the color source and
then once we set the colors we need to
repaint the buttons
and dot repaint
all right let's test that out all right
let's bypass and switch to the mid band
and it still shows up as yellow so
that's awesome the only issue is the
text is white instead of black
and then if we switch back
this is cool all right solo let's bypass
you
very cool solo
and bypass very cool all right that's
awesome that works as expected so that
is fantastic
all right here is a test what happens if
we mute a band other than the low band
let's see uh let's just me let's mute
the mid band
let's quit and relaunch what do you
think is going to happen
okay the button the mid band button does
not reflect the state of the band when
the gui opens once we click on the band
it happens so we need to update the band
select button colors when the gui is
loaded
disable that guy now we'll leave that on
actually it's a good way to test
okay so let's write a function that does
that and it's only going to be called
from the constructor as the band select
buttons reflect the band state correctly
after the gui has finished loading and
one of the buttons is clicked okay so
this is just like
we only have to do this in the
constructor all right let's declare it
first we're going to call it update band
select button states
go to the header file let's put this
down here void update band select button
states all right here is what it is
going to do number one it is going to
query the audio parameters for all three
bands
um for their solo mute and bypass states
it is going to update the band's select
buttons fill color
appropriately back again huh you want
some more time on camera is that what
this is
just going to make all the noise now
all right here is what this function
will do it is going to query the audio
parameters for all three bands um it's
going to look for their solo mute and
bypass parameters and it's going to
update the band select buttons fill
colors accordingly this function again
is only going to be used during
construction to ensure that the band
select buttons
show the correct colors when the gui is
initially loaded
let's go call it in our constructor
where is our constructor it's here at
the top and we can do this after we um
after we update our attachments and
before
before we make the low mid and high
bands visible and we also need to enable
we need to configure enablements as well
so let's do that to update slider
enablements and then we can do update
band select button states let's add this
before update slider enablement just a
good place to put it void compressor
band controls
update ban select button states
all right here's the algorithm for this
function
number one query the following params in
the following order solo mute bypass if
a parameter is on
set the band select colors accordingly
do this for the low mid and high bands i
want to do this in a loop so let's make
a vector that holds all of the program
name enum entries that we need to use go
check this out
first we need our params namespace
then we need our array of param names to
check
next we need to get to the parameter in
question as an audio parameter bool so
this will let us check if the parameter
is true or false easily let's get our
params const auto params equals get
params and then let's make a helper auto
param helper equals lambda lambda lambda
let's back up on screen we need our
params
and we need our apv do we need ap vts
yes we do but um
i'm lazy we're just going to capture
this and we also need a name to pass in
let's see let's implement this first
return
dynamic cast
juice audio param i never hold down
shift long enough
audio parameter bool and we want our get
param
this function which returns a point or
returns a reference we need to point to
that okay we need our params we need our
name
let's pass that in
const auto name and then we need our ap
vts all right great
now we just need to loop through our
vector of params to check
and
do some magic inside this loop all right
so four
size t zero is less than params to check
size right let's get a list so this is
the name of the params we're going to
check so auto list equals params to
check
whichever entry we're on so we might be
iterating either iterating through this
list we might be iterating through this
list might be iterating through this
list let's figure out which band is
currently being updated based on
our index auto band button
equals
if i is zero then we're working on the
low band otherwise if i equals 1 then
we're working on the mid band otherwise
we're working on the high band all right
now we simply check the solo parameter
the mute parameter and the bypass
parameter if any of these are true we
can use the static function we wrote to
change the colors of the band button
declared here
if auto solo equals param helper first
entry in our list
right here we could use an enum
but this is fine all right if it's this
and solo get this is going to return
true or false then we can do refresh
band button colors and our band is going
to be the band button and our color
source is going to be the solo button
okay let's check for the mute parameter
else if auto mute
equals param helper list one
mute get refresh the band button with
the mute button colors finally else if
auto bypass equals param helpers list
two
last one oops that's not where that
semicolon goes all right if it's the
bypass button that's currently on then
update our appropriate band button with
the bypass button all right let's test
it out all right cool the mid band is
currently on
so that test worked as expected i'm
going to change this to solo i'm going
to bypass you and i'm going to change
you to
muted all right let's save and quit
and rerun we should see
them as expected all right cool and the
low band is muted which it means
uh these are bypassed mute band is
soloed and the high band is also muted
so those are disabled so that's perfect
all right and solo and bypass all right
cool that is some excellent gui
functionality helpful for the user let's
make a commit of that
dialed in
custom
band control
colors
all right good times good times
let's look at our road map we have our
bands reflecting this
we're done with that all right and we
have we got custom look and feel going
so we can um we can mark that one off as
well we are up to the spectrum analyzer
next
uh okay we're gonna do an overview we're
gonna migrate it over from simple eq
we're gonna get it working and then
we're going to um we're going to get it
drawing and then we're going to
customize how it draws then we're going
to add bypass functionality to the
analyzer and to all bands at the same
time so we still got a decent chunk of
stuff to do
i'd say we're about maybe 60 of the way
done so the next thing we will tackle is
getting the spectrum analyzer from
simple eq
into here
if you get stuck or run into trouble
while coding this or simple eq just grab
one of my free products from programming
for musicians.com and you can message me
directly in the slack workspace and i
will help you directly
all right spectrum analyzer okay a lot
of code surgery in this one
if you have not completed the simple eq
project we will be reusing the spectrum
analyzer and related classes from that
project so you might take this
opportunity to pause this video
and start watching the simple eq videos
so you can learn how to build that
spectrum analyzer before you copy the
code over to this project
either way we are going to visit the
simple eq repository and copy over the
appropriate classes and get our spectrum
analyzer functional before we start
modifying it let's do that now
go to your browser go to the spectrum
go to simple eq
and we're going to go to the
um the plugineditor.h
okay we need to copy over what is this
thing called this is called the response
curve component if we go down here
we've got our let's see where is this
thing
yeah it's just called the response curve
component okay for whatever reason
that's what i decided to call it um i
don't remember why but
that's what i called it instead of
spectrum analyzer but we will be
renaming it here because it will not be
displaying the response of a filter
one of the first things we will do is
remove the
um the response curve display from this
all right let's go grab this class
response curve component
copy this
okay copy all of the response curve
component copied it
and now let's paste it in our plugin
editor dot h
paste it above the editor
and let's
um let's see we're going to replace the
placeholder
we're going to replace this placeholder
here for analyzer with an instance of
that
response curve component
analyzer
okay
now let's figure out what else we need
to copy over
by trying to build it and obviously we
need to copy over the cpp files so let's
grab those as well go to
source go to plugin editor and now we're
looking for a response curve
rotary slider here we go response curve
components
all right paint function
get frequencies get gains get x's draw
background grid draw text labels
uh resized parameter value change
process
timer callback update chain get render
area get analysis area grab all of these
functions copy them
go to plugin editor dot cpp paste these
all at the top
okay let's try to build it
okay first thing to do is to change this
constructor parameter
to
be the audio processor for this project
so go to plugineditor.h let's grab a
copy of this
simple mb comp audio processor
and let's change that here
simple audio
right and same for right here
okay we took care of this member
variable
and we took care of this constructor
all right let's try building it again
that should take care of those errors
all right cool
let's get rid of this mono chain
we don't need this we don't need the
response curve
uh we don't need the response curve
member variable and we don't need the
update chain function
next let's see okay we need path
producer so let's go grab that from
our repository
let's see that's going to be in the
header file first plugin editor dot h
we want path producer
where are you path producer there you
are okay path producer
copy all right put this at
the top above our response curve
component paste that
okay
next we need to copy over the single
channel sample fifo
now the explanation for how this thing
is built the single channel sample fifo
can be found in project 11. so if you're
interested in learning how this thing
gets built
you can uh sign up for that course this
is going to be found in
pluginprocessor.h from simple eq so
let's go grab that
source plugin processor dot h
all right single channel sample fifo
copy that
and let's paste it above our path
producer
actually uh this needs to live in
pluginprocessor.h so let's put it there
let's put it above
our class declaration for our processor
we need to copy over the channel
enumeration from simple eq let's do that
next go back to the repository and grab
this channel enumeration
i really don't know why i chose to do
the right channel first and the left
channel second because left is always
channel zero
right is always channel one but
i'm stuck with it now changing it would
be a huge um
huge code revision so we'll just leave
it as it is all right
put this above single channel sample
fifo in plugin processor dot h
all right let's build this and see what
happens
okay next thing is it wants a fifo so
let's grab that as well from simple eq
where's that that's right here
here's our fifo make sure you include
the array class that's part of the fifo
fifo needs that
i put that above
the channel enumeration
again if you want to learn how to build
this fifo from scratch and all the
design decisions that come with it you
can check out any of my advanced
plug-in courses because they all use it
project 10 uses it project 11 uses it
and project 12 uses uses it
all right let's build this again let's
see if we have any more errors in the
single channel sample fifo
none okay cool all right let's go back
to the editor
editor.h and uh cp and editor.cpp and
get the rest of these classes working
okay let's change these references right
here to the simple eq change it from
simple eq audio processor and change
them to
our simple mb comp audio processor
that goes there that goes there
build that all right it says no member
named block type in simplemb comp audio
processor all right let's see what this
block type is
go back to the repository
um let's just look for block type
let's see what our options are
okay there it is using block type equals
audio buffer so it's just an alias so
let's
um it's public let's just copy this line
and put it in our plugin processor dot h
and let's also copy over these two
channel instances
these two single channel sample fifo
instances as well
that are declared right below it let's
copy those
all right plugin processor
go down to the end of the public section
after ap vts is declared and put them
right there
all right let's do a little build and
see what errors are left
okay build failed
all right block type disappeared so
that's cool
all right what do we got next
okay we need this fft order type we need
that so that is found at the top of
where is that found
it's in here somewhere let's see let's
check plugin editor
there it is fft order all right let's
copy that
let's put that at the top of our class
at the top of our editor header file
all right let's try to build it
and what do we have here
oh that's cpp file stuff let's fix that
while we are here
um go back to the plugin editor copy
this simple mb comp audio processor
go back over here
run away
all right this needs to be changed
okay let's try that one more time okay
so now we've got an error with fft data
generator all right let's copy these
over next we're going to grab the fft
data generator and the analyzer path
generator these are both found in
let's see here's fft data generator
and here's the analyzer path generator
let's copy both of these classes
they both go in plug-in editor.h
above
path producer let's try that again
again if you want to learn how to build
any of these classes from scratch and
learn the design decisions that went
into them
check out my advanced courses project 10
project 11 and project 12.
they all use this spectrum analyzer so
you'll be able to understand how these
are put together
all right let's fix the cpp file stuff
okay we're getting rid of update chain
all right let's see what's next
update response curve let's get rid of
this function
actually we don't need it at all
same for update chain that's gone
entirely let's just keep building it
there's stuff that needs to be removed
all right remove this code that uh draws
the response curve
this line right here
and get rid of that entirely
all right let's next
um okay update chain that can disappear
response curve okay this stuff in resize
we don't need any of this that can all
disappear
all right um we don't need any of this
update chain update response curve
all right let's see what happens next
constructor must explicitly
initialize okay we need to do that
that's down in our header file
plug in editor all the way down to the
bottom
this needs an instance of its audio
processor
yeah it is the audio processor okay
let's try building it one more time
all right let's see what we get
uh we forgot to make it a visible child
go to plugin editor and let's add our
analyzer make it visible
all right here we go let's see what we
get
there it is we have our spectrum
analyzer in place that we can start
modifying it
uh let's rename it next and then modify
it to display what we need it to display
okay let's rename this class to spectrum
analyzer right click refactor rename
spectrum analyzer
okay cool let's clean it up next all
right let's delete these
all right let's see if there's anything
left in here that needs to be deleted
i think we removed a lot of stuff
earlier instead of just commenting it
out
yep that's it okay all right let's make
a commit now that we have a spectrum
analyzer
added spectrum analyzer and
associated
source associated classes
all right it's not wired up but that's
okay
we'll do that next
well first let's refactor into separate
files
all right so we'll do what we did before
we've got all of these classes so one
source file
one class one source file
go over to producer
and let's see first thing we're gonna do
is add
fft data generator
fft
data generator
all right just paste that here
include
juice
header dot h
all right next let's do the analyzer
path generator
uh collapse it
uh sorry
yeah let's collapse these first this
will make it easier to see what we have
to do all right three classes analyzer
path generator path producer and
spectrum analyzer
okay so let's see these are all in the
gui
spectrum
analyzer and let's see
path producer
path producer
and then analyzer path generator is just
a header file
analyzer path generator
all right let's take care of these
all right let's do spectrum analyzer
first
cut
paste this here
and don't forget the juice header
alright next is path producer
and don't forget the juice header
include
oops not that one
choose header
and then analyzer path generator
include
juice
header.h
what else do we got there's something in
uh that's it for this guy so let's
migrate over
stuff from cpp let's collapse the
spectrum analyzer
collapse all of these
let's grab all of them
it goes in spectrumanalyzer.cpp
all right next um let's see fft order
let's put this in
utilities
put this at the top
all right and then plug-in processor dot
h
has single channel sample fifo
and
the
fifo class so let's add these to the dsp
dsp folder
add new header file fifo
make sure that's dsp folder fifo.h
and then single channel sample fifo
all right
all right channel can go with the single
channel
sample fifo class
put this here
include
juice
header.h
let's migrate over the fifo
and include the juice header
okay
all right now we can fix all of the
includes try to build
let's go through the errors
plug and processor needs single channel
sample fifo
include
dsp
single channel sample fifo
we got no
let's see where was that name
no template named fifo so let's include
the fifo here
what is wrong with this
oh yes okay
unknown type name spectrum analyzer
let's include that
include
gui spectrum analyzer
spectrum analyzer does not know about
the path producer let's inform it
include
path producer
path producer does not know about the
fft data generator include fft data
generator
include what's the other thing analyzer
path generator
all right fft order
that was in utilities
uh that wasn't gui utilities
no template named fifo
include dot dot slash
dsp
fifo
all right path producer we can um we
need to include the audio processor
include
um let's see dot slash
plugin processor dot h
all right build succeeded let's run it
just to make sure
all right cool let's commit that
refactor
all right
refactored
separate files
set bar 8
file 3 vector
all right we will run audio through the
spectrum analyzer next and get it to
display what it displays
let's remove some stuff from our road
map we have not looked at that for a
while
go to the
pluginprocessor.h
wait at the top let's see what do we got
left all right we've done our spectrum
analyzer
uh we have our data structures for it
we need to do
let's see
this needs testing
and then we need to get this working
this is what we're gonna do in this
issue
all right let's tackle this one number
nine fifo usage in process block
this is where we will feed audio into
our single channel sample fifo
head on over to pluginprocessor.cpp
go to processblock
before we apply our gain let's send our
incoming audio into the fifos for the
spectrum analyzer so the spectrum
analyzer is going to show
um it's going to show the incoming audio
before any gain reduction
left channel fifo dot
update buffer
right channel 5.0 update buffer
all right let's switch to testing out
the vst version and run some audio
through the plugin
pst3
run let's see what happens
j sertion aha we forgot to prepare
i'm glad this guy was here this was
smart
if uh
yeah if i hadn't done this uh who knows
what this thing would do
all right let's go fix that
go to uh plugin processor dot cpp go to
prepare to play and we need to prepare
our fifos
put this down at the bottom
left channel
fifo dot prepare
samples per block
right channel fifo prepare
samples per block
all right now let's try it
all right
let's play some music through it
headphones if needed
excellent
all right let's test the accuracy next
just to be sure
and save this quit
let's make a commit
wired up um spectrum analyzer to
incoming audio
stage u
that's that
yeah
it's funny these two lines of code are
these four lines of code are what make
the spectrum analyzer actually work
that's good times
all right we're going to verify the
spectrum analyzer accuracy next
to verify the accuracy of the spectrum
analyzer we're going to need an
oscillator to generate a test signal
now we could use a daw for this um but
i'd rather use
internal code to do that
so let's go down to the bottom of our
header file
and after our split bands class let's
give ourselves an oscillator
the juice framework has one it's part of
the dsp module we will use that
let's go to prepare to play next
we need to configure it
let's do this after our
fifos let's initialize to prepare it and
then set the frequency
we need to provide a lambda that takes
in a
position
within the circle of pi and returns a
sample
float x this is our position within the
circle of pi
oops um and we can just do return st
sine
of x
this is going to generate a sine wave
all right let's prepare it all right
let's go down to where we are updating
our state
plugin processor.cpp process block
okay let's do this after update state
the move here is to clear our buffer and
fill it with samples from the oscillator
so let's give ourselves an if block
let's just say if true if it's true
you're going to do this thing you're
going to do buffer
clear
then you're going to
you're gonna fill it with oscillator
samples
do an audio block from the buffer
do a context
and now we can do ask.process
right this is going to fill up the
buffer with samples from the oscillator
all right this is going to be super
annoying to listen to because it's going
to be a full scale sine wave at 440
hertz so i suggest
muting your speakers i'm not going to
use headphones for this what we are
looking for is a single peak in the
spectrum analyzer at 440 hertz where did
440 hertz come from
it came from right here if we go to the
oscillator class way down at the bottom
the default frequency
is 440. that's where that comes from
because you'll notice we did not set a
frequency with that said turn down your
headphones
possibly turning them off or unplugging
them or turning your speakers off
and switch to the standalone version
and now let's run it we can test other
frequencies that line up with grid lines
later for now we want to see this peak
hit
the zero db line
oh let's change
all right let's try that one more time
okay
so it's pretty accurate in terms of uh
the
the pitch
let's try 500 and then 2 000 okay those
frequencies are actual lines on the grid
so we can go up to our prepare to play
and this is where we will set our
frequency
ask dot set frequency is that what it's
called yes it is all right let's do 500
let's test this out
all right that's pretty accurate
let's do
uh 2000 hertz
all right that's basically right on the
money all right let's add a gain
processor and test negative 12 db since
that is a grid line on the scale on the
left i'll show you what i'm talking
about real quick
that's over here this line right here
this is negative 12.
let's go declare it go to the
plug-in processor.h after the oscillator
go back to um
plugin processor.cpp we need to prepare
it let's do that after our oscillator
gain dot prepare
spec
gain dot set gain decibels negative 12.f
all right now let's just process the
context with it
process block
gain.process
ctx
okay let's test it out okay what i am
seeing is that the peak is not at
negative 12
it should be lining up with this grid
line and it's not
it's a bit lower than that and if we
turn the gain off let's comment this out
it's below the zero db line which is
this line right here
so there is an issue with the spectrum
analyzer mapping
that we need to solve and i want to test
a few more frequencies though just to
see if it's an issue with the amount of
energy in that particular frequency band
so let's try 50 hertz next go to
um prepare to play
let's try 50 hertz
all right let's try 50.
okay this is definitely below zero db
and we're not applying any gain
let's try 1 000
okay all right so we definitely have a
mapping issue with the spectrum analyzer
let's investigate that next
let's go back to process block let's
turn on our gain processing real quick
all right as you can see the fft is not
correctly displaying our test signal it
should be displaying at negative 12 but
it is not it is much lower than that i
want to make the gain adjustable while
we figure this out so let's use juice
live constant to give ourselves this
option
this will give us a slider to drag in a
pop-up window and we can use that to
adjust the test signal level let's close
this
let's right here we will go gain dot set
gain decibels
juice live constant
negative 12. notice i'm using negative
12 not negative 12 dot f that's because
if i do dot f
this will give us a float and i want to
do integers so that way i can have um
steps of like 12 11 10 9.
okay let's try this off oops cancel
let's try this one more time building
all right here's our live constant
editor
all right so now we can drag this slider
let's see how far up do i need to go to
make it zero
i have to go about 5 db maybe 4 db up to
get it to line up with 0. so there's
something going on with how the test
signal is being mapped vertically to the
screen coordinates
let's solve that
let's head on over to
spectrumanalyzer.cpp
and we're going to go to the paint
function
all right let's get rid of this y
transform
and see what happens
we're going to put 0 here
and we're going to put that on a new
line comment it out
and put that like that let's do the same
thing for the right channel oh i need uh
both of these there we go
all right do the same thing here put a
zero
put this on its own line
and then put the curly braces on there
uh put the parentheses on there online
all right let's test and see what
happens
okay so our setting is negative 12 and
now it's showing at right on negative
12. the problem is that we can now see
where negative infinity
is currently mapped to
so there's an issue with where negative
infinity is
in the rectangle that we are using to
convert our fft bin values remember with
the rectangle we are using to map these
values the top represents 0 db and the
bottom represents negative infinity so
let's look at the rectangle that we are
passing to the path producer
all right go to the timer callback
we are passing the analysis
area rectangle so let's take a look at
how this gets computed i go to get
analysis area
okay so we start with our local bounds
here and get render area that's what's
going on here
and in this function we remove a chunk
from the top then we remove a chunk from
the bottom
then we remove a little bit more from
the top
and a little bit more from the bottom
okay so let me get the whiteboard so i
can explain
um how we are mapping this stuff
okay we are mapping our signal
let's see let me let me first step back
all right this big rectangle on the
outside
that is our local bounds let me go this
way
that's our local bounce and then in our
get uh render area this is where we
remove a little bit from the top and a
little bit from the bottom
and that gives us this purple rectangle
on the inside
then we do get analysis area which
shrinks it even further
now we are mapping our signal between
this area here and here
the top line is 0 db
let me draw that here
this is 0 db
and this bottom line
is negative 48.
however
negative 48 is not negative infinity we
need down here to be negative infinity
so we need to update two things number
one the rectangle being passed to the
path producer
needs to have a proper bottom edge that
actually lines up with negative infinity
right now it lines up with this it's
this green greenish blue one so we
actually need to make a rectangle
that goes from here
like that
okay number two
we need to tell the path producer that
the decibel value
number two we need to tell the path
producer the decimal value that is
negative infinity for that we need to
figure out what is the db value of this
bottom edge if this is 0 and this is 48
or this is negative 48
what is this
this is
uh like negative 50 or 52 or something
and that's what negative and that is
what is
negative infinity in terms of uh this
mapping of values
okay so let's take care of number one
first the rectangle being passed to the
path producer needs to have a proper
bottom edge
that lines up with negative infinity
let's do that first
all right let's go to our timer callback
let's set the bottom of this fft bounds
right here to our component's bottom
fft bounds dot set bottom
get local bounds
get bottom
next we need to adjust the top and
bottom values in the function that maps
decibels to screen coordinates
that is over in the analyzer path
generator
analyzerpathgenerator.h
okay that's right here
all right we are mapping the bottom to
get height but we need to map it to fft
bounce get bottom so comment this line
out
and do auto
bottom equals fft bounds dot get bottom
next we are currently adding 10 to
whatever the bottom is that's right here
in this lambda this magic number is also
a source of inaccuracy so let's remove
that
all right let's get rid of this line
we also don't need that cast anymore
bottom
top
all right let's take a look at this and
see if we have an improvement
okay
better
now it's mapping negative infinity to
the bottom of the screen
but this is slightly off right here and
if we adjust this if i put this at
negative 24
it's still off that way if i go up to
zero
zero is lined up
negative 36
and this is because
it is not it's mapping
the negative infinity negative 48 to the
bottom of the screen instead of this
line right here so we need to define
what negative infinity actually is in
decibels relative to this 0 db line and
this negative 48 db line on screen range
let's do that next
all right let's head over to the path
producer
and way at the bottom
let's add
a negative infinity member variable
float
negative infinity
let's initialize it to negative 48
just as a starting point
all right let's add a setter function so
we can update this in our spectrum
analyzer after the component has actual
screen bounds
void update negative infinity
float nf
negative
infinity equals nf
now go to the cpp file
all right we need to
where's my path producer did i not
migrate this stuff over
i don't think i migrated this stuff over
oh you know why because it's here in
spectrum analyzer
right there path producer process
oops
let's collapse that
that belongs over here
okay
okay we need to look for
any negative 48s and replace them with
negative infinity
there's one
and here's the other
okay this shouldn't make any visual
difference but let's just test to make
sure
all right that's still off if i put it
at negative 36
what do we get
are we gonna get that same weird uh
difference yep that's fine okay and zero
zero lines up the top okay cool all
right no difference all right let's set
negative infinity for the path producer
let's head over to the resized function
in the spectrum analyzer spectrum
analyzer.cpp
go to the resized function
all right as i said earlier
the top line i'll show this
make sure your speakers are muted
uh make sure you're um
yeah well i'll mute this in post okay
the top line right here is 0 db
this gray line
and then the bottom line is negative 48.
however negative 48 is not negative
infinity we want the bottom of this
component to represent negative infinity
so first we need to get this analysis
area
since that area represents 0 to negative
48.
let's do that first auto fft bounds
equals get analysis area dot to float
then we need to j map the bottom of our
local bounds from the analysis area
range to the decibel range
auto neg inf
equals jmap
all right our source value is going to
be local bounds
as a float rectangle
and we want the bottom of it
all right our source range minimum is
going to be our fft bounds get bottom
and our source range max is going to be
f of t bounds get y
and our target range minimum
is going to be negative 48
our target range max is zero d is zero
uh float
so this negative 48 corresponds to the
bottom of our fft bounds and the zero
corresponds to the top or the y the y
value
and then we are mapping
our local bounds the bottom of it
based on this set of
top and bottom values
now we can update our path producers
let's print out what the bottom of the
window actually maps to in decibels
and update accordingly
okay let's test this out
all right that is almost perfect
still not 100 it seems
all right it seems like it's a tiny bit
off but
maybe it's not actually off let's look
at the maximum value being produced
where the fft bins are converted into
decibels
and i'd like to think that it should be
whatever gain level our gain processor
is set to since a full-scale sine wave
is being used
as the test signal but
let's find out
head to the fft data generator
all right fft data generator
go down to the bottom
we want to see the maximum decibel level
that the fft data has so let's use juice
jmax
to find out first declare a local max
variable
set it to negative infinity
this is where we convert everything into
decibels so we want to find the maximum
decibel level
all right now declare a local variable
that will hold our converted bin value
then use jmax to store the max value
between the current max and the
converted fft bins value that looks like
this auto data equals
this thing
f of t
data at index i equals data and then
max equals juice
j max
uh our data value and our max value
let's add a j assert false so we can
look at what that max value has
j assert false
i do not want to flood the console with
this max value which is why i am not
using
a debug macro here all right oh and
here's what our negative infinity turns
out to be it's negative 49.41
whatever
okay let's test this out we need to
press the continue button several times
until the fft buffers are filled with
data but let's see what we get we'll be
able to inspect and see what max is set
to
all right max is negative 41 continue 19
negative 16 negative 16 negative 16
negative 16 negative 13 negative 12.
all right
13 12.
okay negative 12 3 6 5 whatever whatever
okay
i'm happy with that
yeah negative three six five whatever
okay now why is this not exactly 12
it's because our oscillator's frequency
is not the same as that of one of the
frequency bins so let's change our
oscillator's frequency to match one
let's comment out this j assert false
and head over to plugin processor dot
cpp go to prepare to play
all right now we're gonna fix this
frequency here
we need to test with a frequency that
lines up with the center of an fft bin
the bins are spaced evenly between zero
hertz and the sample rate
so
we just need to divide the sample rate
by the number of bins minus one and that
will give us the bin width then from
there we just multiply this bin width by
any number n to find the center
frequency of the nth bin
i'm going to go with 50 because it's
kind of close to a thousand hertz
the fft order is a bit shift value so we
need to shift 2 to the left by our fft
order to get the number of bins then
just subtract one
since we don't count the bin with a
center frequency of zero hertz
that's what this looks like
comment this out we're going to do
oscillator dot set frequency we start
with our sample rate
get sample rate
and then we divide that by
uh
our bin
order which is fft order
um let's see what are we setting that to
i think we're doing it at like a low
value let's see um
the spectrum analyzer
where are we doing that is that in the
path producer class
there it is
right there
fft order order two zero four eight
all right let's copy that go back to
plugin processor
this is the fft order that we want
okay we take this value we shift it
we do bit shifting and then we subtract
one
from that and this gives us
the bin width
and then we just multiply this whole
thing
let's see this all needs to be in uh
um let's see that needs to go this needs
to be in parentheses
and this gets multiplied by whatever bin
i want so i'll do 50.
all right this is going to produce a
frequency that lines up with the center
of one of the fft bins
let's check it out
all right look at that boom right on the
money negative 12 and if we adjust this
let's do negative 24
right on the money and negative 36
right on the money all right
bug solved the fft analyzer is accurate
again
i hope you enjoyed um this whole process
because this was a really fun bug to
solve for me and i'm excited to share
how it gets solved because it's a really
interesting problem
that was good times let's make a commit
of that
and we've got some extra stuff in here
but that's okay we have these guys we'll
just leave them in there for now we can
turn this off in a minute
okay let's see what do we do in the
spectrum analyzer
um this is mapped to zero this is mapped
to zero
uh we moved that function
all right that's what that is okay path
producer um we gave ourselves a means of
supplying negative infinity based on the
window position
um in path producer this is where we
just migrated that function over
okay and then fft data generator this is
where we figured out the max value
um i don't know if we need to commit
this
we can just remove it later
an analyzer path generator this is where
we corrected a mapping issue
stage that all right
all right this is going to say corrected
fft
mapping inaccuracies
i hope i spelled that right
inaccuracies
don't judge me if that's spelled wrong
we need to fix a bug in the path
producer
the float vector operations copy
function is not meant to be used where
the destination buffer is the same as
the source that's exactly what we are
doing here
this causes undefined behavior and
causes address or thread sanitizer
issues if that stuff is turned on i
can't remember which one it triggers i
just remember that it triggered it at
one point and yeah either way we need to
fix it so we can use std copy instead we
also need to make sure that the temp
buffer has the same or fewer number of
samples as the mono buffer so let's do
this first
let's add a js search j assert
size
is less than or equal to monobuffer dot
get num samples
and now
um we can just force it
size equals juice j min
size
monobuffer get numb samples all right so
this makes sure
that
size is set to
monobuffer.getnumsamples or size
whichever one is smaller
all right for this we will need the read
and write pointers
in the monobuffer auto right pointer
equals monobuffer
get right pointer
channel num is uh we need
channel number is zero and our sample
index is zero
we need our read pointer
auto read pointer
equals monobuffer get read pointer
this one we're reading
channel zero
and we're starting at index size
basically these two lines right here
all right now for std copy the first
parameter
the first parameter is the location of
the first sample in the source buffer
that we want to copy
so that's going to be our read pointer
the second parameter is the location of
the last sample that we want to copy
plus one so wherever we want to copy to
the end of that
all right read pointer
plus
here we have our
monobuffer dot get num samples
minus size
all right and then the third parameter
is the destination right pointer
second parameter is kind of confusing so
let's break out the whiteboard just to
explain
uh before we do that let's comment out
the old code
okay
std copy is annoying because of how it
works but it's the right tool for the
job in this situation so i'm going to
explain
what is happening i've got rp
representing read pointer i've got um wp
representing the right pointer this is
the same block of memory okay it's just
i'm just showing eight
eight bytes for right now
okay
our goal is to add three samples to the
end of our array the way we're going to
do that with std copy
is to provide the right the read pointer
which is at the third index and then our
read pointer plus num samples minus the
size is the end of the chunk we want to
we want to read from
and then we say hey where do we want to
put this the destination
that's the very beginning
so again one more time we the first
argument is the read pointer
this is where we're gonna start reading
from then we say all right where's the
end
and that's the read pointer plus the
number of samples minus our size
our size is three our number of samples
is eight so we get three minus three
plus eight is eleven minus three gives
us
one past um it's basically gives us the
index after
um
the range we wanna copy it's that same
thing with like um string uh substring
where you say here's the first index and
then go up to but not including this
other index they're doing the exact same
thing here we start at this index we go
to this we copy from here up until this
index but don't include this index and
then we say all right we want to copy
all that stuff to the right pointer
which is at the beginning and this is
going to shift this whole chunk over
here which is going to give us
our three samples it's going to give us
room for our three samples at the end
that's how std copy works like i said
it's not the most intuitive thing to use
but it does not trigger the
thread sanitizer or
address sanitizer errors that
float vector operations do
okay so that's
um
that's how the std copy operation works
okay
all right we commented out the old float
vector operations so we can go ahead and
test this out
all right no visual difference this is
still at zero uh still negative 12 still
accurate
negative 24 all right cool so that's
fine okay cool so we can get back to our
roadmap now that the spectrum analyzer
has been dialed in and it is now ready
for modifying let's go take a look and
see what we have
left to do
all right this is done
and this is done
all right so we need to do this next
all right let's make a commit because
that was um
that was a pretty decent um
pretty decent bug that we fixed
fixed um
i think it's a sand i think it's address
center
issue in um
path producer
stage and stage
okay
all right let's disable our test
oscillator this is extremely simple go
to process block
and change this to if false
we can remove this stuff later if we
want to
i'm going to leave it in in case i need
to do more testing
this is more convenient than just com
commenting it all out we're just left
with a simple warning
um let's see
all right the next thing to do is
we're going to tweak some of these
graphics a little bit
and then once we do that
we're going to do a little bit of
refactoring and then we're going to
tweak the labels and then that's going
to wrap up the spectrum analyzer
so let's adjust these background
graphics
first
all right go to spectrum analyzer dot
cpp go to the paint function
now i want to reorganize this a little
bit i want to use the draw module
background first that i've been using in
other classes
so that's the main motivation is i want
this to have that same cool border that
our other modules have the global
controls and the compressor band
controls
draw module background is in the
utilities file so we need to include
that that's up here at the top include
let's go find it
setting is that in the guise yes it is
in the gui so it's just right there in
utilities
i go back to the paint function
okay right here
let's call draw module background
okay this function does not return
anything but i wanted to return the area
inside the module bounce
this area will be where we draw
everything and it is smaller than the
local bounce so let's change the
drawable
so let's change the draw module function
to give us this autobounds equals that
all right we're just kind of saying hey
this is going to give us something back
all right let's go fix that next
let's go to our utilities
utilities.cpp
all right bounds is what it is going to
return
bounds is the inner reduced rectangle so
let's return that
let's uh say that it's going to return a
rectangle here
and now let's change the return type in
the declaration
there is that function down here at the
bottom rectangle
okay cool
back to the spectrum analyzer
all right the next step is to revise how
the background grid is drawn it is
currently drawn relative to the local
bounds and we need to make it relative
to this bounding box that was returned
from draw module background so let's
revise the declaration first and then
pass these bounds
to it where we are calling it right here
all right go to the header file
all right comment out the old one and
add a juice rectangle as the second
parameter
let's copy and paste
juice rectangle
int
bounce
all right go back to the cpp file
cpp file
now we can pass our bounds to this
function
let's update the implementation next go
to the implementation draw background
grid
let's update this to take a rectangle as
the second parameter
all right next we need to make this
analysis area function take a rectangle
as its parameter
let's change the declaration first and
then the call site and then the
implementation
go to the header file
get analysis area
add a juice rectangle as the parameter
all right that updates
the declaration
go back to the cpp file
all right let's pass in the bounds now
and let's update the implementation next
this is way down here get an
get analysis area
change this
juice rectangle
int
okay we need to make get render area
compute its result based on this bounce
that we're passing in
so let's revise that function as well
and then after we finish that revision
we will update the implementation
let's go to the declaration
and add
a rectangle as the parameter
back to the cpp file
and now let's
update the call site
here we can say bounds equals that and
this is no longer an auto
now we can update this implementation
here
pass inbounds
all right we are providing a bounding
box now so we do not need to get the
local bounce
okay let's go back to where we were in
the paint function because we have a few
errors now since revising get render
area and get analysis area
we're going to get to those though let's
go back to the paint function
okay let's get this compiling before we
continue first of all we need to pass
our bounds to this
uh to these functions that want a
parameter so response area
um
is provided by get analysis area and
that requires bounds
in draw text labels let's
draw text labels let's see what error is
our first
spectrum analyzer okay this one um let's
see
just looking at my notes here
draw text labels is what it says to do
next
all right draw text labels
needs a rectangle
because get analysis needs a rectangle
so let's make draw text labels receive a
rectangle as the second parameter
and let's
call that here
bounce
and let's update that declaration real
quick
go to the header file draw text labels
okay go back to our
cpp file go to that paint function one
more time
okay we're down here and draw text
labels
let's pass our bounding box here um
let's add our bounds here into this get
render area
and in this one as well bounds
are there any others in here
okay let's do a quick build
okay we need to pass our local bounds
here
in our get analysis area so let's get
that auto bounds equals get local bounds
bounce
and we can dri dry this one right here
this should just be bounce
all right let's see what do we have next
okay the last place is
um right here
let's get analysis area so let's dry
this
getting the local bounds auto bounds
equals get local bounds
and now we can pass bounce here
and we can use our bounce here
all right let's test it out it should
all look the same except for having the
module border around it
all right no module border
all right let's investigate paint and
see if we missed something
aha this fill path is covering up the
background let's comment it out
see what we get
all right excellent we have a module
border
and we've got this uh line right there
we'll deal with that in a little bit
um and then we can also tweak these
positions for the text labels next
that was a lot that was very surgical
let's make commit of that
added
uh what do we do we added module border
to
spectrum analyzer
also disabled
disabled test
oscillator
okay
here's where we modify draw
draw module background to return the
rectangle that it
ends up
yeah
it returns the rectangle that is
being reduced
right here's where we updated our
declarations to work with bounding boxes
and then here's all the code surgery
that we did
all right let's move all of this code
into its own function
let's declare a private member function
spectrum analyzer dot h down at the
bottom
void draw fft
analysis we need a graphics and a
bounding box
we can take that from here
all right we're going to pass the
bounding box because we're going to draw
the paths
within
this bounding box
all right let's go call it
spectrum analyzer.cpp
draw fft analysis g bounce
all right let's implement it we just
need to copy this code
and then remove it
i'm going to put that right up here
void spectrum analyzer
draw fft analysis
and uh wants the juice namespace using
namespace juice
all right let's get rid of this code
here
all right let's go to our function
because it's got it we have a few errors
all right first error is it wants the
response area so let's take that from
here
got that since it's not used anymore
that can go here
all right let's run this
all right everything seems to look okay
uh let's do the um
we still have that white line
but let's run this let's actually run
some signal through this now just to
make sure
you can grab your headphones if you want
all right that's still working
cool
all right let's take care of that white
line that's being drawn
we can use the graphics reduce clip
region function to shrink the area that
we are allowed to draw within
if we combine this with graphics scoped
save state
this reduced clip region will stop being
reduced once we leave this function
so this lets us draw only within this
response area which is pretty handy so
first create a graphics save state
juice uh we don't need to write that
graphics
scoped stave save state
triple s
passing in our graphics instance and
then let's do g dot reduce clip region
response area
all right let's take a look at it
all right i don't see that white line
anymore
that's fantastic
all right and it's only drawing it
within the negative 48 0. that's awesome
okay the next thing is to fix these text
labels and the grid itself because
uh we don't care about you know plus 24
to negative 24. we carry about um plus
12
to negative 60 because that's what our
threshold range is that's what we want
to see on here
okay
let's commit this since that was a
decent bug to fix
fixed um
negative infinity
line being visible in spectrum
analyzer
also refactored
how fft paths are drawn
all right cool
all right let's continue cleaning up the
spectrum analyzer go to the paint
function
all right let's get rid of this border
we already have a border
that's the uh draw module background
so let's comment out everything except
the draw text labels
get rid of that
and get rid of this
all right let's test it out standalone
editor
all right cool it looks good all right
let's dial in the text labels next
all right let's take a look at this all
right first things first notice that
this text along the top is colliding
with uh this border so let's fix that
that's in the text labels function let's
go to that
all right this is where we draw our
frequencies
right in this chunk right here
all right this is where we draw it okay
the y position should be the y position
of the bounds that we're passing in not
one so that's the first fix right there
r dot set y
bounds dot get y
remember we're passing in a bounding box
that is inside of our uh module
background all right
let's look at that
all right cool they are no longer
colliding that's great
see
next the text on the right
okay this text is colliding with the
edge let's fix that
again it needs to be relative to the
bounding box that we are passing in not
the components bounding box let's go
where that is that's in the gains
that's gonna be this uh set x it's
currently
based off the components
right edge and we need it to be based
off of our bounding box right edge r dot
set x
bounds dot get right
minus text width
all right the text on the left let's see
how that is i'm pretty sure that's
colliding too and i can see where right
there
where did this go all right yep that
text is colliding all right so this is
good this is no longer colliding that's
great
this is colliding
this needs to be not
one to the right of the component left
edge it needs to be one to the right of
the
bounds dot
the bounding box left edge
oops
plus let's look at that
okay great our text labels no longer
collide let's do a quick commit of that
surgical edit
corrected uh no fixed
text collisions
with component edge
also uh removed old border
all right it is now time to introduce
the concept of negative infinity and max
decibels
as well as min frequency and max
frequency
these values are constants that we are
going to use in this project to ensure
we aren't typing
magic numbers whenever we need to supply
a frequency range we will use min
frequency and max frequency let's go
define those now
head over to utility.h
utilities.h plural
all right define these up at the top
put these right here
define
min frequency
20 hertz
and define max frequency
20 000 hertz
next let's define our decibel ranges
define
negative infinity
this is going to be negative 72
and then max decibels will be plus 12.
define
max decibels
12 dot f
finally we need to define our minimum
threshold for our compressor bands
define
min threshold whoops all caps
negative 60.
our next job is to replace all instances
of these values with our macros we will
start with the plug-in processor
there i go to
uh what's the name of this function this
is create parameter layout let's change
this threshold range
right here
this needs to be min threshold
and max decibels
whoops
max decibels
all right let's do a quick build am i
including utilities here
apparently i am all right cool
i did not think i was but i guess one of
these classes is including it
all right back to the spectrum analyzer
all right
let's change our mapping first
all right we're not going to do negative
24 to positive 24. we are going to do
negative infinity to max decibels so
comment this out replace it auto y
equals
jmap
our source value is gdp
we got negative infinity
max decibels
and then this is
let's see this is going to be
um
bottom but
cast doesn't float
and then top cast as a float
all right good times
all right we need to do this again where
else do we need to do that
um right here
in
draw background grid so we're doing it
in draw text labels
and then we're doing it in draw
background grid
so we can just copy this first just copy
this stuff
and let's fix this indentation
and you should be all the way to the
left
all right let's go to the resized
function because there's a negative 48
over there
all right comment out this line
and add negative infinity
and max decibels
that's the choices
all right let's test this out
and see how it looks with our test
signal we're going to re-enable our test
signal so be sure to take off your
headphones or turn down your speakers
when you press the go button put this on
true
all right let's test it out
all right we're missing grid lines it
still lines up with the grid line
uh but our labels are wrong it says plus
12 to minus 24 and then 12 to the
negative 48.
so let's fix that next
back to spectrum analyzer
all right we need to go to the get gains
function
all right let's change what we are
returning here first of all
uh let's dynamically create
the vector instead all right if we
change what negative
infinity and max decibels mean it can be
automatically reflected here so let's
start at negative infinity and increment
to max decibels using an increment size
of 12. start with a vector of values
let's return this return values
now we can do auto increment equals max
decibels we can change this if we want
for now this is 12 db steps
now we do 4 auto db equals negative
infinity
db is less than or equal to
max decibels
and we are incrementing
by our increment db plus equals
increment
all right let's do values.pushback
db
all right let's test this out
see if that solves our issue with the
gains
all right that looks good to me 12 to
96.
uh why does that say negative okay this
one says the right range it says plus 12
to negative 72 which is what we want
and
all right this is off
it's showing negative 12 and it should
be showing that should be showing here
we'll deal with that
all right let's make both sides show the
same range first
all right let's get rid of the code go
to the draw text labels function
um there's code in here that shifts the
value yes this code right here okay
let's get rid of that
don't clear it don't shift it
all right the only thing that we need to
actually change here is the x position
because we're drawing the same string
uh that we set here
this string right here this is the only
thing we need to change or sorry this is
the only thing we're drawing so we don't
need to change the text width we don't
need to change the size
we don't need to change the color we're
just drawing the same string in a
different position
all right
let's test this out
we should see the same range same scale
range on both sides of the fft now
there we go plus 12 negative 72 plus 12
negative 72. all right great
all right now
uh our fft is not mapping correctly this
is negative 12 and it's showing up as
zero so let's fix that next
go to the analyzer path generator this
is the source of the problem the problem
here is that we are mapping our y
position to the screen coordinates and
notice that the upper range is zero
and not max decibels so let's change
that
we want to make this
max decibels instead
negative
infinity
max decibels there we go
um let's see if
do we need to include the utility header
for that let's do a build and see
see what it does maybe it'll complain
maybe it won't all right no complaints
that's cool
let's run this now
all right
all right this is pretty good
all right let's change this to negative
24.
also pretty accurate
let's change it to zero
all right it might be off by like you
know one db or half a db
uh but for the sake of this tutorial
which is free i'm going to call this
good if you really want to know how to
make this stuff absolutely perfect you
can check out project 11 or project 12
where we
create a perfect
spectrum analyzer that is perfectly
accurate
all right let's turn off the test
oscillator we no longer need that
discard change
all right
one last test um let's do it with um
let's see why did i run the standalone
that looks clean now let's let's run
some actual audio through it make sure
it looks okay
run it grab your headphones
turn the volume back up
so you can hear what it's doing
all right
fantastic
okay cool all right next we're going to
draw the crossovers then we're going to
draw thresholds then we are going to
draw gain reduction
and that will conclude the spectrum
analyzer
let's make a commit of the work that we
did
what did we do
um let's see um standardized
how
ranges are defined
that's that that's what that is
um
fixed spectrum
analyzer labels these should be reversed
let's switch that
all right fix spectrum analyzer labels
and then we standardized
how the ranges are defined
all right sounds good
all right before we go and implement
crossovers and thresholds and gain
reduction let's go through the code and
replace any 20 hertz and 20 000 hertz
with min frequency and max frequency
where does that happen first
all right here's one in analyzer paths
generator
right here
okay this needs to be
min frequency
and max frequency
okay there is another in spectrum
analyzer
um we just need to search for twenty
thousand twenty one two three dot
all right spectrum analyzer
all right right here
in uh the get x's function
we're doing min
freak
and max
all right
and there should be two more let's just
look for 20 000.
only look in the actual project source
code
okay um
spectrum analyzer
um we're going to keep these hard coded
all right plugin processor
okay here's one right here this should
be min
min
frequency and then this should be
max frequency
all right i believe those are the only
two that remain
all right yes okay cool
all right those are the only two
let's make sure
all right
our gain sliders still works
our threshold slider
still cool
our frequency still goes 20 hertz to 20k
all right cool good enough for me let's
draw some crossovers next
if you get stuck or run into trouble
while coding this or simple eq just grab
one of my free products from
programmingformusions.com
and you can message me directly in the
slack workspace and i will help you
directly
we are going to draw our crossovers next
to accomplish this all we need to do is
get the frequency value from the
crossover parameter
map it to an x position and then draw a
vertical line the timer callback is
taking care of repainting the screen at
a regular rate let's go look at um our
spectrum analyzer.cpp so you can see
what i'm talking about go to the timer
callback okay this is
repainting at a regular rate so that's
good times okay so we don't need to do
anything special to refresh whenever the
crossover slider is dragged we just need
to declare some stuff and
add some functions and whatnot that can
get the parameter and pull the
crossovers and produce x values for us
to draw from top to bottom okay let's
declare a function for drawing the
crossovers and call it
first
go to the header file
spectrum analyzer.h let's do this at the
bottom
i'm just going to copy this draw fft
analysis
and
rename it to be draw crossovers
okay
super simple
let's go call it go back to that paint
function
and we're going to do this before we
draw our text labels draw crossovers
g
bounds
all right let's go implement it next
i'm just going to
put this right below the
paint function because i'm lazy
void
spectrum analyzer draw crossovers
all right i don't feel like scrolling to
put it in the order that it was declared
in
which would mean it's after that draw
fft analysis function okay
we are going to be using a lot of juice
functions in here so let's set up the
namespace alias as always
using names
namespace juice
okay then let's get our bounding box
bounds equals get analysis area
from our input argument
all right next we need to give ourselves
access to the two crossover parameters
let's go back to the header file let's
declare two member variables to do that
one for the low mid and one for the mid
high
all right let's initialize these up to
the constructor
where is the constructor way at the top
all right let's do this before we start
our timer using namespace params whoops
let's spell space correctly
let's get our params map
auto
param
equals get params
all right um let's see it doesn't know
where params come from so let's include
where those come from
include dot dot slash
dsp
params
oh uh conflict so let's make this param
names
all right let's copy the float helper
lambda from the plugin processor
constructor plug-in processor all the
way to the top where's that lambda float
helper this thing right here
copy that
go back to spectrum analyzer let's put
that here
and we need to change the capture stuff
a little bit
differently we're not using that let's
go like that and then this needs to be
param names
and this is going to be
apvts equals audioprocessor.apbts
and this we're capturing param names not
params
there we go
okay
now we can use it to initialize our
members float helper
low mid crossover
and we want our names low mid crossover
freak float helper
mid high
names
mid high
crossover freak
cool
all right we are going to draw a
vertical line from the top of our bounds
to the bottom of our bounds
so let's go to that uh function we were
working on
draw crossovers
and we need to cache the top and bottom
let's do that next const auto top equals
bounce dot get y
and then const auto bottom equals
balance dot get bottom
all right first we need to map the
frequency to a screen position so let's
copy the mapping code from our get x's
function wherever that is
get x's all right here's the mapping
code
and we can turn we can uh dry this later
use a free function if we want
let's change this push back into a
return statement we're going to stuff
this into a lambda
go back to our draw crossovers all right
auto map x equals
lambda lambda lambda
all right and here's where we're going
to
take our norm x
and we're going to return
left plus width times norm x all right
what do we need we need left
left equals bounds dot get x
we need the width width equals
bounce.get width
we need our frequency
indent that please all right float
frequency
um let's make this say
all right that's nice and
readable
all right now we can draw our crossovers
use the map x function to convert the
low mid into an x coordinate
auto low mid
x equals
map x
frequency is going to be low mid x over
pram
get
all right uh let's draw a vertical line
from top to bottom g dot set color
colors let's do orange because that'll
stick out and we can do g dot draw
vertical line our x is going to be low
mid x and our top is top and our float
our bottom is
all right let's do the same for the mid
high
auto mid high
x equals map x
mid high pram
get the value
drop
g dot draw vertical
mid high from the top to the bottom
let's test it out
all right we see some crossovers
let's put this right at 200
perfect
works like a charm but a 2k
default value default value
all right awesome
let's do thresholds next let's do the
same thing for the thresholds that we
did for the crossovers
go to the um header file
we have three compressor bands so we
need three threshold parameters let's go
um
yeah just copy these rename them and we
will initialize them in the constructor
next let's do one more
all right low threshold
param
let's just copy the word threshold and
change this to say
hi whoops
hi h i g h
mid threshold
all right cool
that takes care of the declarations
let's go construct these again
go to the uh constructor
let's use our float helper to make our
life very simple
i'm just gonna copy this three times and
rename it two three
low threshold
mid threshold
high thresh
low threshold
threshold low
thresh mid
and thresh
hi
perfect okay let's go draw
let's go to the draw crossover function
and update it to also draw thresholds
all right draw crossovers
okay here is how we are going to draw
these thresholds number one we draw a
horizontal line from the left edge to
the low mid crossover let me pull the
plugin up
so you can see what i'm talking about
all right we are going to draw a
horizontal line from the left edge
to this crossover right here
all right we're going to use uh the y
value is going to be the
low threshold param mapped to this
decibel range okay then we're going to
draw
a horizontal line from the low mid
crossover to the mid high crossover
again using the same y value is
mapped onto these screen coordinates
then we're going to draw a horizontal
line from the mid high to the right edge
of our
analysis area
so we're going to need the left x and
we're going to need the right x too
all right let's get those guys
const auto left
equals bounds dot get x const auto right
equals bounds dot get right now we can
map our thresholds to their y position
and then draw horizontal lines let's
grab the y mapping code from draw
background grid
that's this stuff right here
and turn it into a lambda
copy this
go back up to draw crossovers let's make
a lambda real quick
auto map y equals lambda lambda lambda
guts of it is this mapping function we
need to capture the top and bottom
bottom
top
and we need to pass in our decibels so
change that name db
float db
and now we just need to return it okay
great
now we can use it
i want to use a different color
than the color that i used for the
crossover so i'm going to go with yellow
colors
yellow
now we're going to draw the low band
threshold from the left edge to the low
mid crossover so g dot draw horizontal
line our y is going to be map y
and we are mapping our low
threshold parameter
and our left side is going to be the
left edge and our right is going to be
low mid x
okay
pretty simple
let's test it out just to make sure it
works
we should see a yellow horizontal line
for the low band depending on what it is
set to
all right cool it is set to negative 23
and i see that
this line is right above the gray
so that's cool let's put this on 12.
all right nice and accurate
awesome that is working as expected
that means we can do the other ones uh
this line is a little bit hard to see
i might change this later to draw a
rectangle that is you know taller
with a center y
of
this thing whatever this y value is
uh but for now i'm just going to leave
this as is and we're going to draw the
other lines
draw horizontal
draw horizontal okay we are mapping the
mid
threshold param and we're mapping the
high threshold param
our left side is going to be the low mid
x and our right side is going to be the
mid high x
for the mid threshold for the high
threshold our left side is the mid high
x and our right side is
the right
all right let's test it out
all right let's adjust the mid threshold
cool and let's adjust our crossovers
fantastic
now if you want to make these draggable
or if you want to learn how to make
these draggable when you click and drag
on them
you can learn how to do that in project
12. we cover how to make this a very
interactive gui so you can adjust all
this stuff all right the last thing to
do is to draw gain reduction
all right we are nearing the end of our
road map let's go mark off a few items
ah let's make a commit first actually
what did we do we um added a
spectrum
let's see spectrum
analyzer
shows crossovers and thresholds
that's what we did stage
um we also adjusted um
used
macros for min max frequencies
all right here's our spectrum analyzer
with our draw crossover fanciness
we're nearing the end of our road map so
let's mark off a few more items
plugin processor.h we are drawing the
crossovers that's done
um and we need to
draw the gain reduction so let's do that
next
let's go to the compressor band class
all right first of all we're going to
need some atomic members that will store
the rms levels
one for the input and one for the output
all right these should be initialized to
negative infinity uh we're going to need
to include our header file to make use
of negative infinity um
these are going to get the rms level of
the buffer
before and after processing all right
let's put these here
in the private section
std uh let's see i'm doing two of them
so i don't want to type twice so let's
do the old option
drag and do std atomic
float
um let's see rms
level
db
curly brace
negative infinity
closing curly brace semicolon
all right let's change this to be
input and this is output cool
let's include
um utilities for that
include
uh let's see yeah utility so dot dot
slash
dot dot slash
all right gui utilities dot h
let's just make sure that that's cool
all right all right build succeeded
all right next we need some getter
functions
so let's write a pair
again
i'm going to type it twice
float
get
rms
level db
these are const functions
and they return
rms level db
colon all right let's fix these names
get rms output level
and get rms input level
and this is going to return
the input returns input output returns
output cool
all right let's go to the compressor
band uh cpp file
we just need to sample the rms level
before we compress and then after we
compress our buffer has multiple
channels so we want to compute the
average rms level over all of these
channels we're going to need to write a
function to do that i am lazy and do not
want to figure out the types that we are
passing in so i'm going to template this
function
because templates are awesome
okay go back to the compressor band
header file put this after
these guys
all right this is fairly simple to write
first of all we need the number of
channels let's uh write a template
function now
template type name
t
float compute rms
rms level
const t buffer
okay
first we need to compute
the rms level of each channel
um let me start over first of all we
need the number of channels in the
number of samples
then we are going to need to compute the
rms of each channel and add them all
together
then we just divide this summed value by
the number of channels and that gives us
our averaged rms level for the buffer
let's do that
all right so first we get the number of
channels and the number of samples
then we get a we set an rms level to
zero and now we walk through every
channel and get the rms level for that
particular channel for all samples
then after summing them all together we
just divided by the number of channels
and that is our averaged rms level for
the buffer
nice and simple all right let's go use
this function next compressorband.cpp
go to the process function
all right
let's get the pre-rms level of the
buffer and remember this is not
expressed in decibels so auto pre-rms
equals compute rms level buffer
okay and then let's get the post rms
level
compute rms level buffer
and i don't want to write juice
decibels gain to decibels twice so i'm
going to do a
helper lambda
return
juice decibels
gain two decibels
and now we can use it to store our pre
and post rms levels as decibels in the
atomic members so rms
input level dot store
convert to decibels the pre-rms
then rms output dot store convert to db
post rms
all right the next thing to do is to get
these values into our spectrum analyzer
head on over to the editor
for that
plugin editor dot h we need to pull
these compressor rms levels p-o-l-l we
need to pull these compressor rms levels
at a regular interval so let's inherit
from timer next
juice timer
let's add the appropriate callback
void
timer callback
let's go start the timer in our
constructor let's do this after set size
i'm going to do a 60 hertz timer so it's
refreshing 60 times a second
and now let's go implement it let's do
this after resized
void simple mbcomp editor
timer callback all right
the compressor bands are not public
so let's make them public first before
we start polling them here
go to uh pluginprocessor.h
way down to the bottom
move these to the public section all
right go back to plugin editor timer
callback
now that those compressors are public we
can create a vector and get these rms
levels so i'm going to create a vector
so i only have to pass one object to the
spectrum analyzer instead of six
this means that the function that i
write i only have to type one parameter
uh declaration instead of six so you
know simplify my life a little bit
here we go declare a vector and grab the
input and output rms levels from each
band
let's go write a function in our
spectrum analyzer to receive this vector
spectrum analyzer dot h
let's make an update function in the
public section
void
update
now we're going to need to compute the
gain reduction from the values that we
are getting so let's let's see i'm
getting ahead of myself
all right first let's declare this it's
going to take an std vector
of float values
all right we're going to need to compute
the gain reduction from the values that
were passed to us
let's declare three variables that can
hold those values
all right
three floats let's put these at the
bottom
way down here with our params
float low band gr
initialize them all to zero since no
gain reduction is happening
to begin with float mid band gr
okay
cool back to the editor let's pass that
vector
to the um spectrum analyzer
uh analyzer is that what i'm calling it
updates values all right our analyzer
has been updated with fresh rms levels
of uh input and output
uh gain buffer levels whatever we're
calling it rms input levels let's go
implement this update function next
all right let's go to spectrum
analyzer.cpp i'm going to put these
below the
uh draw crossovers function
all right void spectrum analyzer update
first let's make sure we have six values
j asserts values dot size equals six
um i don't know why it wouldn't be that
but
you know
just to make sure
all right next i am going to help myself
out and give myself an enumeration that
i can use to index into this vector and
keep track of which indexes point to
which rms
levels that looks like this
all right now i can simply update my
gain reduction
my gain reduction member variables and
then repaint the gain reduction is a
negative value usually so we want to
subtract the input
from the output as the output is almost
always lower than the input level so
that looks like this
low band gr equals values
low band out
minus values
low band in
all right very simple
all right let's do the rest and then
repaint
all right in order to draw the gain
reduction correctly we need to know the
following coordinates per band
this is going to happen in where are we
doing this we're doing this in our draw
crossovers draw crossovers is where we
need to go
in order to draw the gain reduction
correctly we need to know the following
coordinates per band the left x the
right x where 0 db is as a screen
coordinate and whereas the gain
reduction is
expressed as decibels again as a screen
coordinate so let's
um compute zero db
auto zero db equals map y
zero dot f all right we've got the left
x and the right x that's what this stuff
is and this stuff here
so we just need to map the gain
reduction before we can draw our gain
reduction
that's pretty easy to get
so let's get our color first i'm just
going to give it some alpha so it
doesn't cover up the grid lines
g dot set color
i'm going to use hot pink because i want
something that sticks out colors hot
pink
with alpha
give me an alpha of 0.3 f
all right
now i am going to use the rectangle
static function left top right bottom to
create the rectangles that will
represent the gain reduction and then
i'm going to fill them up
so here we go
and i'm going to draw these behind
i'm going to draw these behind the
actual
threshold levels
all right g dot phil rect
and we're gonna do rectangle
um
we're gonna do float and we want the
left top
right bottom okay our left is going to
be left our top is 0 db
our right side is going to be the low
mid x
and our bottom is going to be the low
band
gain reduction mapped
map y
low band gain reduction
all right let's put that all
separate lines
okay let's do this again for the next um
for the mid band
all right so this is mid band
it mid-band gain reduction this one is
high band gain reduction
okay our left side for this one is the
low mid x and our right side is the mid
high x
for this one it's mid high x
and then the right edge
all right let's feed some audio through
the plug-in we're going to test this out
we should see some gain reduction
uh not standalone
we're going to use um
audio plug-and-host we're going to feed
some actual audio through this and we
should see some gain reduction
rectangles light up
let's see what happens do we have any
errors nope just the warning about that
stuff that's marked false the test
signal
all right here we go
there we go look at that rectangle
that's awesome let's adjust the mid-band
get that squishing
all right
[Music]
all right very cool
[Music]
awesome okay there are only three things
left to do in this project let's save
and quit this
let's make a commit and then we'll talk
about those three things that remain
uh this was added added gain reduction
display
is that all we did
yeah that's right game reduction uh
timer is part of that here's the gain
reduction
that's where we passed it to the
spectrum analyzer those are our members
that display the gain reduction
and here's how we actually made it
happen
and then here's where we compute the
gain reduction so this was cool bit of
code surgery on this one pretty involved
but good times
all right let's talk about the major
three things we have left to do let's
look at our road map plugin processor.h
at the top all right we are currently
drawing our gain reduction done
all right analyze your bypass button
that's not going to be difficult
um global bypass button that's got a few
tricks to it and then the color scheme
and the color helper stuff i want to
talk about that at the very end
so we are nearing the completion of this
project i hope you are enjoying the
journey
let's tackle the control bar next
uh the first thing we will do is add the
analyzer button
just like in the simple eq project this
button will toggle the analyzer on and
off let's go to the plugin editor.h
let's just put this right here
all right first things first let's
define a class for it
okay we already copied the code for this
button over earlier
that's right here here's our analyzer
button
so we just need to include that file
include
gui custom buttons
and then we can give ourselves an
instance let's put this in the uh
just toss it right here
analyzer button
analyzer button all right
next we need a constructor to make it
visible and a resized function to give
it some bounds
plugin editor dot cpp go to the top
stick that right here
add and make visible analyze button
uh let's make it
uh toggled on by default analyzer button
dot set toggle state
should be on true
uh don't send a notification
all right
let's make it sit on the left and be
about 50 pixels wide i'm gonna want a
small gap between the top of the
component let's start our resized
function void control bar
resized um as i was saying let's make it
sit on the left side of the gui be about
50 maybe 60 pixels wide i'm gonna want a
small gap between the top of the
component and the bottom
um and also between the component and
the spectrum analyzer
so i'm going to trim a little bit off of
the top and the bottom of our local
bounce
auto bounds equals get local bounds
an analyzer button dot set bounds
and we're going to do bounds dot remove
from left
50 and then we need to take some off the
top dot remove from top
just a little bit
with
trimmed
uh not remove from top we want with
trimmed top with trimmed top
all right this returns a version of this
rectangle with the given amount removed
from its top edge so that's what we want
with trim to top
four
and with trimmed bottom
all right because we're removing four
from the top of
this rectangle the rectangle that's 50
pixels that was removed from the left
edge we're trimming four off of the top
of that thing
all right
that's the width trimmed stuff versus
the remove stuff can be kind of tricky
the first few times you use it all right
let's get rid of our placeholder once
and for all
go to the plugin editor get rid of the
placeholder control bar and make it a
control bar
awesome
get rid of all this stuff
all right plugin editor.cpp
let's connect the control bar analyzer
button
uh to the actual analyzer and toggle
enablement accordingly let's do this
before we make it visible
control bar
dot analyzer button dot on click equals
lambda lambda lambda semicolon you go on
a new line oops and we're going to
capture this
and we're going to do analyzer dot
toggle
analyzer
analysis enablement and it should be on
if the analyzer control button
if the control bar analyzer button
toggle state says so
so let's just get that state
bool should
i'll use auto auto should
be on
equals control bar
analyzer button get toggle state
all right now we just need to make it
visible let's uncomment this line let's
test her out run some audio see if the
spectrum analyzer turns on and off
all right let's test her out
all right we're going to run some audio
we're going to click that button
[Music]
all right perfect
save
stop
quit
perfect all right um
global bypass is next all right
we have included
uh let's see where's our header editor
file all right
all right we already included our custom
buttons so let's add our power button
next super easy um declare an instance
power button
global
bypass button all right great let's add
it as a child go to the plugin editor
dot cpp
up here
add and
make
visible
global bypass button
all right let's give it some bounds and
um see what we got
all right i'm going to make it 60 wide
maybe that'll look cool let's see i'm
going to stick it on the right side
globalbypassbutton.setbounds
bounds.remove from right
60 and i'm going to trim off the top and
trim off the bottom
with trimmed top i'm gonna do a little
less than four so i'll do two
with
that width with trimmed bottom see i
might change that later
let's see how we see how it looks
should see a little power button in the
upper right hand corner
alright perfect
it doesn't do anything let's make it do
something
alright
clicking the bypass button should toggle
the bypass parameter of each band before
we set up the bypass buttons on click
lambda let's declare a function that
will toggle the global bypass state
all right let's go declare this as
private plugin editor.h go down to the
bottom
put this here void toggle global
bypass state
all right let's go set up the lambda
plug in editor.cpp
and do the lambda right after our
control bar
control bar
dot um whoops let me spell that right
dot global bypass button dot on click
equals lambda oops
equals lambda lambda lambda
we're going to capture this one more
time
all right we're going to call our toggle
global bypass function
all right
let's go implement that let's put this
after timer callback void simple editor
toggle global bypass
okay first we need to get the toggle
state of the button if the button is off
meaning it's green
everything should be enabled so auto
should enable
everything
equals
control bar
global bypass button
get toggle state all right again if this
is on
sorry if this button is off meaning it
is currently drawing as green everything
should be enabled so if it's off then
this should be true if this is off that
means it's false which means this should
be true so we want the opposite of that
all right next we need to get all of the
bypass parameters let's write a function
to give us that
plugin editor.h put it after this uh
let's return an array
std
array all right we are returning three
instances of audio parameter bull
it's called get bypass params nice and
convenient
all right let's get to the params
auto params equals get bypass per amps
let's write this function next
all right put this down here
std array
juice audio parameter bool
three of them
simple
editor
get bypass params
we need to query the audio processor
value tree state for these parameters so
we will need the usual namespace aliases
and references when looking up the
parameters let's do that now
all right let's copy the bool helper
uh first i need to include the right
params file include
dot dot slash dsp
is that where dsp is no dsp is
right there params
all right
let's copy the bool helper from plugin
processors constructor and modify it for
our needs plug-in processor
scroll down for the bool helper copy and
put it right here
all right so specifically we needed to
return a pointer instead of a reference
right now this is returning a reference
and this is also modifying
um it's modifying the input parameter we
don't care about that so we're not doing
that we're going to return whatever it
figures out return param
and then ap vts um we can just capture
that that should be that um then we need
auto declaration here auto param equals
whatever param we get from the ap vts
casted to a
audio parameter bool if the cast is cool
this will not fire and hopefully we will
return a pointer okay great
now we can use the helper to get three
boolean parameters
auto low
bypass param equals bool helper
names bypassed low band
all right let's do that for the other
two bands
there we go mid band high band bypass
all right now we can just package them
into an array
return
low bypass
mid bypass
high bypass
all right cool
all right we have our parameters now
whenever we change audio parameters we
need to tell the host that it is part of
a guester this is so that the host can
store these changes in automation
let's write a helper lambda to do this
we are going to be updating three
parameters so the first lambda argument
will be the parameter second will be
whether or not the parameter should be
bypass auto bypass param helper equals
lambda lambda lambda first param is the
parameter auto param second is whether
or not it should be bypassed bool should
be bypassed
all right now we can begin our change
guester param
begin
change gesture
then we can set the params value based
on if it should be bypassed or not
param set value notifying host
should be bypassed
then it should be one otherwise should
be zero
um it's important to remember that set
notifying set value notifying hosts
wants a normalized value between zero
and one all right and then we can end
our change guesser param and
change guess
now we can loop through our parameters
for auto param
params if everything should be enabled
then should be bypassed should be false
that means we want the opposite of
should enable everything passed in as
the parameter so bypass program helper
passing the param and should be bypassed
is the opposite of should enable
everything
all right
let's test that out
all right let's do this okay so the
active compressor bands band select
button changes
the other band select buttons do not for
instance this is showing as bypassed but
this state is not updated
and if we click on those bands like same
for the high one it's bypassed but this
button is not reflecting that state
so we need to fix that
we need to update the colors of the band
select buttons that are not the active
band whenever we toggle the global
bypass button
let's do that next we need to add a
member function in compressor band
controls that will update these bands
colors so head on over to compressor
band controls
all right let's declare a public
function
void toggle all bands
bool should be bypassed
all right let's put this below button
clicked in the implementation
button clicked
void
compressor band
controls
toggle all bands
here is how this function is going to
work we're going to use an array of
pointers to all three band select
buttons and we're going to loop through
that array
here's the logic we are going to
implement
if the global bypass button is clicked
off meaning that everything
is bypassed we need to set every band
buttons on color to the bypass fill
color and then we need to set every
band's off color to the bypass color as
well
if the global bypass button is clicked
on meaning nothing is bypassed we need
to set every band buttons on color to
the default fill color
and we need to set every band's off
color to black as this is the default
off color
when the band select button is bypassed
and not the active band it will still
display the correct fill color
and finally we need to manually repaint
after we change a button's color
let's implement that now
here's my
here's my vector of buttons
we're going to loop through each button
we're going to set the color based on if
we should be bypassed
we're going to
pull it from the bypass button if it
should be bypassed
and if not we're going to use our
default gray color
and then we are also going to set the
off color
if it should be bypassed we're going to
use that on color again
otherwise we're going to use black and
then we're going to manually repaint
okay
very simple
all right head back over to plugin
plugineditor.cpp
let's call our function now below this
band controls dot
toggle all bands and if it's if it's if
everything should be enabled then it
should not be bypassed so we're doing
this again
all right let's
test it out
all right
all right awesome
toggle them on and off okay very cool
the next thing to do is to update the
global bypass button if we manually
bypass each button separately for
example if i go
low as bypassed mid button is bypassed
high band is bypassed this should turn
off
and then likewise if we have all bands
bypassed when the plug-in loads
then the global bypass should also
reflect this let's tackle that
next
all right the final task is to make the
global bypass button reflect the bypass
state of the bands if we toggle them
manually we are going to use our timer
callback to do this let's go look at
that real quick
all right
we are going to declare a function to
update the global bypass
and then we're going to call it here and
implement it next let's go to the header
file plugin editor.h declare a private
function void update global bypass
button
go to timer callback
and we will call it after we update our
analyzer
all right
it's gonna
i'm gonna put it right below timer
callback
void
simple editor
update global bypass all right the logic
here is pretty simple we need to get all
the params all of the bypass parameters
we need to figure out if all of them are
set to true
and then we set the global bypass
buttons toggle state accordingly and we
need to make sure that we don't send a
notification when setting the toggle
state
if we were to send a notification it
would trigger that on click lambda which
is something we don't need to have
happen because that's gonna fire all
this stuff
let's get all of our params
auto params equals get bypass params
we can use std all of
to check if all of the params are true
bool all bands
are
bypassed equals std
all of
params.begin
params oops
params.end
and our predicate is a lambda i am the
lambda lambda
const auto param we want to see if the
param is true or not so return param get
finally now that we know whether or not
all of the bands are bypassed we just
need to set the toggle state so control
bar
dot
global bypass button set toggle state
and remember do not send that
notification
juice
notification type don't send
okay so remember
if all of the bands are bypassed then
the button should not appear as green
if it only appears as green when the
toggle state is off
so this is most likely false which means
all bands are bypassed which means our
toggle stage should be false all right
let's test this out here's what we're
going to do we're going to enable all
the bands
we're going to manually bypass them one
by one and see if that button switches
all right
let's turn this on
turn this on
and if we bypass this is this one going
to change
it does all right great and clicking it
turns them all back off
okay so the next test is if we do this
if they're all on
and then i turn off a band is this going
to turn on
yes it does
awesome that works as expected
now what happens if we close the gui
when all bands are bypassed
is this button going to be set correct
let's save and quit
and rerun
and see what it does
all right perfect
that works as expected okay that wraps
up the functionality for the plug-in for
this tutorial the last thing that i want
to do is customize some of these colors
and show a few tricks that i use to do
that
let's make a commit of our work
uh implemented global controls
implemented
global
controls um let's go to our plug-in
processor let's mark these guys off
done and global bypass done our roadmap
is now complete
that is fantastic all right plug an
editor here's our control bar here's
where we did all this bypass stuff
there's our editor
here's all the
bypass code that we
implemented control band this is how we
update the colors of the control band
based on whether or not it should or
should not be bypassed
all right commit six files
all right
do color stuff next
all right head over to look and feel i'm
going to show you a trick that is going
to help you dial in your colors the
first thing is to declare a macro that
toggles whether we use juice live
constant or not
put this
right here
define
use live constant
all right next i'm going to write a
helper macro
that will make use of this macro right
here
this macro doesn't do anything except
return what was passed to it if the
macro is true
then the juice live constant editor is
true otherwise this function just
returns what was given to it the only
downside here is that the juice live
constant editor doesn't show the
relevant code
in the code snippet viewer and it
triggers a jsert but
who cares you know it's for what we
needed to do
it's awesome
if use live constant
we're gonna define a color helper
function
where we pass in c and
we use juice live constant
c like that
else
define
color helper
and if
okay the next piece of the puzzle is to
declare a namespace that holds all of
the colors i plan on using
and it wraps these colors and getter
functions so i'm going to demonstrate
one first
all right in this function all i do
is call the color helper function with
whatever color i want
so return color helper
i'm going to go with blue for right now
okay now i just need to replace whatever
color i'm using when setting the
slider's border with a call to this
function instead
let's go to lookingfield.cpp
let's go find where that is drawn
that's going to be drawn in the draw
rotary slider
at the top
all right this is where i draw the
border
so i'm going to replace this line
uh with a call to the um get slider
border color g dot set color
enabled
if it's enabled use color scheme
get slider border color
otherwise do uh
colors
gray
otherwise do this thing
all right let's test it out and it will
trigger a j assert but we can just
continue past that it'll still work as
expected
oh um sorry let's do this in the
standalone version
and why is this showing an error
redefinition
i don't know why it's saying that
all right here's that j assert i was
talking about
okay
let's pull up our
plugin here
all right so you can click on this color
right here and adjust all of the colors
directly which is a great way
to dial in
um you know your colors in your gui
once you find a color that you like
oh that's a cool color
um yeah copy the hexadecimal value
and paste it where you were passing the
default color to color helper that was
over here in
not look and feel
that was over here in lookandfeel.h this
color right here so i would just paste
this instead and then wrap it in a juice
color constructor
juice color
like that because there's a juice color
constructor that takes a hexadecimal
value
all right let's do another let's do the
module border
all right let's go declare this function
inline juice color
get module
color
return color helper
juice
colors
blue violet
all right we're returning the color we
want
now let's use the function as needed in
uh look and feel
that'll go right here
g dot set color
if it's enabled use color scheme
get slide uh get module border
otherwise use dark gray
and then let's
head over to
the draw module border color
find that in utilities dot cpp
there you go all right we need to
include our look and feel so we can use
the color scheme
um look and feel
all right
and now we can set the color to the
module border instead of that blue
violet we can do
color scheme
get module border color
all right let's run this it's going to j
assert
all right that's one
there's the other
all right let's find our plug-in window
here we go so what's cool about this is
we get two colors now
so we can adjust all of these
like that you can see how it's adjusting
the fill color of the knobs as well as
the um
border color
and then we can dial in this thing
and again once we find a color that we
like
that's kind of cool
once we find a color that we like we
just copy the hexadecimal over to our um
copy it over here and replace the colors
all right so there you go that's a nice
helpful tip for how to dial in the
colors you know once you get this
color set to what you want if you want
this like red color or not so much this
uh
maybe you want this to be like an alpha
color and you can do that too
that looks kind of cool
this pop out more
once you get this color dialed in to
what you want um just copy the
hexadecimal and replace it in your color
scheme helper
and you'll have your colors dialed in
so it's you know a pretty handy way if
you don't have a graphic designer to
provide you colors
and like give you like a real fancy gui
it's just one of those things that we
can use to tweak our gui and make it um
a bit easier to make changes in a
dynamic way that are easy to update
okay so i hope you found that tip useful
um i've used it a few times and i think
it's a pretty it's a pretty efficient
way to dial in gooey colors all right
all right so there you go that wraps up
the tutorial
i am going to dial in some more of these
colors and tweak the gui a bit to my
liking i'm going to encourage you to do
the same you can check out the completed
project at the link in the description
and if you want to learn how to build
the big brother of this plugin check out
my course project 12 which is available
at www.programming4
you will be building it from
instructions written in a jira board i
will be reviewing your code every step
of the way it is not a follow-along
course like this video was you're going
to be getting your hands dirty and
figuring it all out for yourself alright
thank you so much for watching and
supporting this be sure to check out my
youtube channel my instagram and my
twitter accounts check the links in the
description including me starting from
scratch videos as well as simple eq and
my other courses and as always if you
get stuck or run into trouble while
coding this or simple eq just grab one
of my free products from
programming4musicians.com
and you can message me directly in the
slack workspace and i will help you
directly thank you for tuning in i hope
you appreciated this tutorial and i hope
you learned a lot from it i will see you
in the next one